Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Hier ist die Freakshow Nummer 298,
um genau zu sein. Und wir wollen ja ganz genau sein. Richtig?
Unbedingt.
Unbedingt, genau. Wir wollen total genau sein. Ganz genau.
Insofern muss ich mal ganz genau zusammentragen, wer da ist.
Roddy ist da, schaut mich gerade mit so einem ganz genauen Blick an. Aber hallo.
Kalibrierend, würde ich sagen.
Ganz genau.
Kalibrierender Blick.
Mit der nötigen Akkuratesse.
Also wie so ein Laserstrahl in gewisser Hinsicht. Also wirklich im Millimeter
Gravitationswellen vermessend.
Ja, ich gucke nur so, weil ich ein bisschen müde bin und versuche das zu kaschieren.
Das ist dir hervorragend gelungen. Ralf, wie sieht es bei dir aus?
Was für einen Blick hast du so drauf heute?
Ich bin wach, ausnahmsweise. Wach und gesund.
Was kommt auf uns zu?
Selten hier zu hören.
Wach, gesund und das Bier ist noch nicht getrunken.
Das Thema kannte dir nur die verschlafene Performance von Ralf.
Er ist schon ganz hektisch. Zittert auch ein bisschen.
Ich hatte in der Tat so ein paar anstrengende Wochen. Mit irgendwie drei Keynotes
in drei Wochen und ich mache das ja total gerne und stürze mich ja sofort auf
jede Bühne, wenn man mich nicht davon abhält.
Und ich glaube, es war auch einigermaßen erfolgreich. Zu einer der Sachen kommen
ja vielleicht noch, aber das hat dann doch etwas auch an der Substanz gezehrt,
dass ich die letzte Sendung dann mal ausgesessen habe. Aber heute bin ich fit.
Alright, das ist gut.
Ich kann mal ganz zu Anfang gleich mal eine interessante Erkenntnis teilen,
die ich hatte, weil mir ein Link zugeworfen wurde und dann dachte ich mir so, oha, dachte ich mir so,
weil Podcasting ist ja jetzt so, je nachdem wie man das so definiert,
ungefähr so 20, 21 Jahre alt.
Dachte ich. Stellt sich raus, gibt es schon länger.
Also normalerweise würde man ja sagen, als der erste iPod rauskam und Apple
das mit RSS und so dafür genutzt hat.
Wäre jetzt mein Take gewesen, wann Podcast startet.
Das wären dann ziemlich genau 20 Jahre jetzt, weil vor 20 Jahren kam iTunes
4.7 raus und da hat Apple quasi die Podcast Funktion in iTunes eingebaut.
Ich glaube, es ist ziemlich genau 20 Jahre her jetzt.
Aber ich erinnere mich, dass es Podcasts vor der Apple-Podcast-Funktion in iTunes gab.
Klar.
Es war ein bisschen schmerzhaft, aber der Name Podcast kommt ja vom iPod.
Ja.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, also genau. Konkret kommt es von Ben Hammersley, so einem Schreiberling,
der so über die Online-Welt berichtet.
Und der hat diesen Begriff mal geprägt, weil er das sozusagen wahrgenommen hat
und die Technologie, ja das hat sich so ein, zwei Jahre vorher entwickelt, weil das ja quasi durch,
ja letztlich durch Dave Weiner, der das in dem RSS-Standard hinzugefügt hat.
Quasi Realität wurde. Aber das war, sagen wir mal, auch noch unabhängig vom iPod.
Das mit dem iPod dann zu verbinden, das war dann wiederum so eine Initiative
von Adam Curry, dieser etwas streitbare, aber durchaus umtriebige.
Amerikaner, der in Holland wohnte und MTV Reporter,
MTV Host war und dann halt Podcasting gestartet hat und dann aber auch sehr
viel dafür getan hat, dass das zum Leben kommt und dann hat er eben Leute zusammengesucht,
die so diese Software dann schreiben sollen,
die dann diese Dateien abholen und auf den iPod schieben.
Das hieß dann iPodder, wurde später irgendwie in Juice umbenannt,
wahrscheinlich wieder wegen Namensrechtsgedöns und so.
Und ja, das war eine etwas grauselige Software, aber immerhin, es gab eine.
Und ja, ich weiß nicht, Steve Jobs hat wohl das so in der Nase kitzeln gespürt, So,
dass auf einmal dieses Podcasting da war und dass das einfach eine supergeile
Idee ist, was man mit dem iPod auch noch machen kann.
Und dann heißt es halt auch noch irgendwie Podcasting und dann war einfach kein Halten mehr.
Und dann hat er halt seinen iTunes-Leuten gesagt, ihr baut das jetzt hier mal
ein und wir machen jetzt ja auch gleich Podcast-Verzeichnis und pipapo.
Und einmal richtig und das war ja dann eigentlich, sagen wir mal so,
der Turbo, der dann geschaltet wurde.
Und das war ja dann auch für mich der Grund, endlich dann mal meine schon seit
Monaten gehegten Podcast-Pläne dann auch mal in die Realität umzusetzen.
Und dann hatte ich zwei Monate später meine erste Podcast-Webseite online.
Das Chaos-Radio-Podcast-Network. Egal. Ich wollte aber gar nicht über mich reden,
sondern über die Tatsache, dass ich zur Kenntnis nehmen muss,
dass das jetzt noch ein bisschen länger her ist,
dass es so Sprache, die an viele Leute verteilt wird.
Man nennt das Radio.
Tim.
Ja, aber auf rein.
Kannst du mal mein Mikro ein bisschen lauter machen? Der Chat beklagt sich auch schon.
Ja, das kann ich in der Tat tun, wobei du bist hier schon ganz schön.
So, und was es aber schon vorher gab, wie ich jetzt feststellen durfte, war das hier.
Ah, wie Sie hören, hören Sie nichts. Das hat damit zu tun, dass ich hier nochmal
die Dings ausschalten muss.
Das ist hier aber auch vom User-Interface wirklich ein bisschen.
Das ist auch ein zweiter Versuch.
Telefon-Hirmundo.
Telefon-Hirmundo. Telefon-Hirmundo.
Was?
Telefon-Hirmundo ist, welche Sprache?
Klingt nach Schwedisch, aber es ist wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Nee.
Könnte noch italienisch sein?
Mach nochmal, wie er das ausspricht. Ist das original ausgesprochen?
Okay, ich werfe noch Ungarisch in den Ring.
Aber das war es dann. Ja, es ist Ungarisch.
Okay.
Telefonermondo heißt so viel wie Telefon Herald und also sozusagen Telefon Newspaper.
Und das war tatsächlich ein Dienst, der in Ungarn lief, wo es tatsächlich Subscriber
gab, die über Telefon quasi einem Broadcast zugehört haben.
Und da, also Leute haben dann sozusagen Telefonnummer und dann haben sie wirklich
in diesem Telefonnetz so eine Broadcast-Schaltung gehabt und dann gab es auf
der anderen Leitung einen Menschen, der die Nachrichten vorgelesen hat.
Und auch mehrere Leute gleichzeitig konnten hören, dass das war so nicht einer
nach dem anderen und der das jeweils so in 1 zu 1 Sessions.
Sich anrufen und hat jedem nochmal.
Das vorgelesen. Das fände ich jetzt noch ein bisschen lame.
Aber das war ein Multicast, also im Sinne von hat da angerufen und hat gerade
das gehört, was man hört.
So verstehe ich das, genau.
Das würde ich jetzt mal mit Podcasten aber nicht vergleichen,
weil Podcasten lädt man ja runter und dann hört man es, wenn man es hören will.
Zeit autonom.
Von welchem Jahr sprechen wir denn hier? Wir können uns da wirklich trefflich
jetzt drüber streiten, welchen Status es jetzt wirklich hat,
aber es ist insofern bemerkenswert, als dass es sozusagen noch vor Radio da war.
Und jetzt kommt die Jahreszahl, 1893, das ist 132 Jahre her.
Okay.
Das heißt, wir haben 125 Jahre Podcasting verpinnt. Schade.
Genau.
Wie ist das eigentlich mit einer Dial-A-Joke-Nummer? Ist das Podcasting?
Dial-A-Joke.
Weiß nicht, was war das?
Steve Wozniak hatte angeblich sowas.
Ah, okay.
Wenn man anrufen konnte und dann hat er einem einen Witz erzählt.
Aber es war dann wohl eher ein Anrufbeantworter.
Er hat wohl live erzählt, aber es war on demand. Also du hast angerufen und
hast deinen Witz gestreamt bekommen.
Na okay, das würde man heute sagen.
Streamst du auch immer, wenn dich einer anruft?
Ich streame sowas von.
Entschuldigung, es klingelt, ich muss mal kurz streamen.
Telefon Hermondo, genau. Tatsächlich haben sie das dann irgendwie….
Gibt es eine Sendung davon? Aber ich meine, gut.
Erzählt halt irgendwas auf Ungarisch. Es gab natürlich keine Aufnahme.
Keine Aufzeichnung, ja.
Aber das ist wirklich bemerkenswert. Aber das war im Prinzip der erste Dienst,
wo so Spoken Content einem größeren Publikum zugestellt wurde.
Und das hat sozusagen auch noch eben das eigentliche Radio.
Als dann Radio kam, haben sie das umgestellt und dann haben sie über diese Telefonleitung
das Radio übertragen. Also das war dann sozusagen nochmal ein alternativer Distributionskanal.
Das macht natürlich Sinn, dann nicht nochmal ein weiteres Programm zu machen.
Aber die einzige Quelle, aus der man quasi hätte zitieren können,
waren in dem Sinne die Zeitung.
Und das ist natürlich super, weil du kannst halt irgendwo Hörer abnehmen, zack, bumm und so.
Das Bemerkenswert ist, dass sie einfach diese Technologie hatten.
Ist überliefert, wie teuer das war?
Weil ich glaube, in der Anfangszeit war Telefonieren gar nicht mal so billig.
Ich muss mal kurz hier...
Gut, vielleicht war es auch eine Flatrate, weil sie sowieso keine Zeiten abrechnen konnten.
Aber...
Also ich glaube, ein Abrechnungsmodell,
war da jetzt wirklich nicht drin.
Minecraft.
Naja, auf jeden Fall dieser Herr Pushkas, der Pushkas, Tivadar Pushkas,
der hat wohl immer so einen Ingenieur und Erfinder und hat wohl auch mit Thomas
Edison zusammengearbeitet und war überhaupt ganz findig und hat halt irgendwie
da dieses Telefon Switchboard mit seinem ganzen Relay Technology erfunden.
Ja, und das will ich jetzt hier einfach mal anerkennend erwähnen.
Und der hat das dann live eingesprochen?
Ja, also ich denke, es war dann so eine feste Uhrzeit. Genau.
Und dann hast du halt eingeschaltet und dann kam das. Es gab halt kein...
Also es gab nichts anderes als live.
Also es gab keine Aufzeichnungstechnologie. Da hat es jetzt so keine Bänder.
Magnetband kam später.
Das kam alles sehr viel später. und ich meine auch als das Fernsehen hier gestartet,
das hat es ja sehr, sehr, sehr lange gedauert, bis die überhaupt in der Lage
waren, ihre Sendungen aufzunehmen.
Oh, die hatten einen Konzertsaal oder Konzertraum mit Klavier, das finde ich ja spaßig.
Da gab auch Musik.
Gab auch Musik, Alter.
Also quasi, also wie Meta-Ebene, bloß halt einfach noch viel,
viel, viel, viel früher. Das ist erstaunlich, ne?
Ja. Telefon. hier im Mundur.
Okay Hier ist die Welt Hier im Mondo,
Das mal so zum Auftakt Dachte das interessiert euch,
Also Es gab natürlich hier noch einen Bericht dazu Wo ist mir das um die Ohren
geflogen Hier Hackaday World's first podcaster Wird da berichtet Naja.
Worst Falls Podcaster.
Was möchtest du mir gerade mit deinem Handgemenge sagen? Ich hätte gerne die drei.
Die drei, Fernbedienung Nummer drei.
Fernbedienung Nummer drei. Oh ja, danke schön. Nummer vier ist hier. Danke.
Dann kann ich in Ruhe.
Kannst du natürlich stumm schalten. Hast du jetzt schon nichts mehr zu sagen?
Ich bin noch geliefert für die Sendung.
Ihr könnt mir auch alle beim Trinken zuhören.
Nee, das muss jetzt nicht sein.
Siehste mal.
Alright. So, dann müssen wir aber mal ein bisschen Feedback geben.
Ralf, du hast die letzte Sendung gehört.
Ich hab die letzte Sendung gehört.
Wie war denn das? Wie ist denn das, so ein Freakshow zuzuhören?
Ich war...
Kann die überhaupt noch was, die Show? Kann man das jetzt einfach...
Also ich war fast ein bisschen froh, dass ich nicht dabei sein musste.
Dass ich nicht dabei sein musste. Weil ich teile wirklich völlig eure Einschätzung,
dass diese letzte Apple Keynote wieder einen neuen Tiefpunkt in Sachen Belanglosigkeit
irgendwie produziert hat.
Du meintest, du seist irgendwie eingenickt. Dasselbe ist mir in der Tat auch passiert.
Und ich dachte, okay, früher, ja, wir erinnern uns die guten alten Zeiten,
wo man sonst wie aufgeregt war.
Und mein Gott, wo kriegt man überhaupt einen Stream her und die Live-Blogs noch
nebenan verfolgt, ob man irgendwas verpasst hat. und heute rauscht das so völlig
belanglos nebenher durch.
Wir erzählen das ja jetzt auch wirklich schon seit drei Jahren,
aber ich bin der festen Überzeugung, Apple müsste da was tun.
Also die werden natürlich irgendwie ihre Analysen haben, warum das alles super
ist für ihren Verkauf, was sie da machen. Aber das ist so uncool geworden alles.
Es ist unfassbar uncool. Mir ist das auch tatsächlich auch vor ein paar Tagen
nochmal durch den Kopf gegangen. Es ist vor allem so,
Es ist so furchtbar auf Safety gespielt. Nichts darf mehr schief gehen.
Es gibt keinerlei Dynamik. Und wenn ich so an Apple-Kino zurückdenke,
dann fallen mir halt als erstes immer so Momente ein, wo Steve Jobs erstmal
den Saal anbrüllt und sagt, ich soll das Wi-Fi ausschalten, damit er hier seine
ordentliche Demo machen kann und sowas. Weißt du, das ist einfach...
Ja, oder wo er frustriert die Kamera von der Bühne wirft.
Es reden halt auch nie zwei Menschen miteinander. Das ist auch so ein Punkt.
Ja, es ist halt irgendwie Talking Head after Talking Head after Talking Head.
Wobei da war jetzt auch die Apple Kino noch nie verträgt.
Ja, aber man hatte zumindest so ein bisschen so, jetzt holen wir mal XY auf
die Bühne und der freut sich dann und so.
Du hast zumindest mal aneinander vorbeigegangen und dann so laut ignoriert.
Also ich Ich glaube wirklich, die müssen wieder mit Publikum machen.
Das denke ich auch, weil es gibt ja gerade viel Debatte darüber,
ob Tim Cook jetzt überhaupt noch tragbar ist.
Er hat ja eh gesagt, er ist in zehn Jahren nicht mehr da und alle so, ja warum zehn Jahre?
Also ich denke mal, er wird jetzt auch die Jahre schon runterzählen,
wir wissen bloß eben nicht wie viele Jahre.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht, was das Problem ist. Das Problem ist eigentlich, er ist...
Ja, jetzt hätte ich fast gesagt, er ist kein Steve Jobs, hö hö hö, wer ist das schon.
Aber er war schon immer ein bisschen steif.
Er ist halt ein Verwalter der Dinge.
Er ist nicht eine kreative Kraft.
Er ist nicht derjenige, der spürt, wohin Apple gehen sollte und wenn er den Falschen zuhört,
die nicht das Richtige spüren und er nicht spürt, dass sie nicht richtig liegen,
dann geht es halt in eine falsche Richtung.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, alles geht in die falsche Richtung.
Apple war super erfolgreich unter Tim Cook und hat irgendwie den Businesswert
ins Unermessliche gesteigert, alles gar keine Frage.
Aber das ist ja nicht der einzige Value, also es ist ja nicht das einzige,
was zählt und es ist auch nicht,
ich meine Apples wirtschaftlicher Erfolg
war ja nicht entscheidend für das Verhältnis, was man zu Apple hatte,
sondern es war ja der generelle Appeal, der quasi mit Apple verbunden war.
Klar, Underdog hat halt immer irgendwie Vorteile und wenn du erstmal der Größte
bist, dann wird es schwierig, aber das ist ja nicht das Entscheidende.
Das Entscheidende ist ja, dass sie eigentlich gesagt haben, wir machen hier
Catering zu einer Gruppe von Leuten,
die einen gewissen Qualitätsstandard als Minimum ansieht und die sozusagen bestimmte
Dinge wertschätzt, die nicht unbedingt einen Mainstream. Wertschätzt.
Ja, er ist auch halt einfach ein Wirtschafts-CEO.
Also ich habe da neulich einen Blogpost geschrieben, wo sich jemand bitterlich
darüber beklagt hat, dass also Steve Jobs hat angeblich irgendwann mal gesagt,
wir schütten keine Dividende aus und Aktien kaufen wir auch nicht zurück.
So und der Mensch in dem Blogpost hat sich aber bitterlich darüber beklagt,
dass Apple tatsächlich in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren mehr Geld für Dividende
und Aktienbuybacks ausgegeben hat als für Produktforschung.
Was besonders im AI-Bereich, wo sie also ein Zehntel der vorderen drei oder
vier an Geld ausgeben und an Hardware einsetzen, um Modelle trainieren zu können.
Weswegen halt Siri auch immer noch irgendwie...
Naja, so ein Kleinkind ist halt, ne?
Ja, also das kann ja alles funktionieren, wenn er halt dann unter sich die richtigen
Leute fördert, die es dann halt drauf haben.
Und beim Hardware-Bereich, finde ich, fluppt das ja.
Gibt es nicht viel zu meckern.
Da gibt es wirklich nicht viel.
So eine Vision für 4000 Euro.
Ja, haben wir ja alles diskutiert so. Aber so der Design-Bereich haben wir alles
schon rauf und runter irgendwie diskutiert.
Also seit Johnny Ive mit allen Problemen, die er hatte, mit zu viel Reduktion
und so weiter, da war halt auch nach Steve Jobs noch jemand,
der halt wirklich so Attention to Detail und wie sieht das denn nun wirklich
irgendwie auf der Subpixel-Ebene aus?
Da hatte der halt mal einfach einen Blick für. Und wenn man sich jetzt das Liquid
Glass anguckt, also ich teile eure Einschätzung auch der letzten Folge,
dass das auf iOS gut funktioniert,
da finde ich das wirklich ganz schick und stört mich das überhaupt nicht,
dass das alles so ein klein bis weniger lesbar ist und dafür aber so ein bisschen iCandy hat.
Aber auf Mac ist das Ganze so ein inkonsistenter Brei, wo du also fünf Apple-Apps
aufmachst und die dann doch so leicht unterschiedliche Interpretationen haben,
wie das jetzt hier mit den Buttons aussieht und der Transparenz.
Und da fehlt so der einheitliche Strich da irgendwie durch und sowas hätte es
unter Steve glaube ich nicht gegeben, aber vielleicht hätte es das auch unter
Johnny Ive nicht gegeben und das schmerzt mich schon.
Dass du eigentlich keine Mac-App mehr aufmachst dieser Tage und denkst so,
boah, das sieht aber geil aus.
Das ist mal ein richtig schönes Design.
Ja, da ist der Fokus deutlich von runter.
Das muss man einfach so sagen. Der Fokus vom Mac ist runter.
Dass sie überhaupt noch so viel machen, wie sie machen, könnte man schon als
erstaunlich bezeichnen.
Ja klar, aber sie verdienen halt mit iPhones, weiß ich nicht wie viel,
80% ihres Geldes oder so.
Ja, aber ich meine, der Mac ist ja kein Nischenprodukt bei Apple.
Definiere Nische.
Da ist eine strategisch wichtige Plattform. Es ist ja nicht nur so,
ja, es kaufen auch noch ein paar Leute ein paar Laptops, sondern da werden die
Anwendungen drauf entwickelt.
Wann hast du das letzte Mal Xcode benutzt?
Ich benutze Xcode nicht, weil ich mache keine Anwendungsentwicklungen auf dem
Mac, aber alle Anwendungen, die auf dem Mac gemacht werden, werden auf dem Mac gemacht.
Also alle, die für das ganze Ökosystem gemacht werden, werden auf einem Macintosh gemacht.
Und ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass der Mac an sich unattraktiv ist.
Ich halte das nach wie vor für die sportlichste Dessor-Plattform, gar keine Frage. oder?
Darum geht es nicht, dass andere noch schlimmer sind. Ich finde nur,
man merkt schon, dass der Fokus nicht mehr drauf ist.
Es ist nicht mehr die Nummer 1 Plattform, die das Leben und Sterben von Apple ähm,
sichert, sondern es ist halt jetzt nur so eine Plattform, die man als strategisches,
Gewicht noch am Bein hat und mitschleppt, aber eigentlich macht man sein Geld
woanders. Das merkst du bei Apple einfach, finde ich.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, also für mich ist das keine ausreichende Erklärung.
Ja, weil ehrlich gesagt kann ich mir jetzt nicht, denke ich jetzt nicht,
die laufen jetzt alle bei Apple rum und dann so, ach ja, Macintosh.
Wer interessiert sich denn dafür schon?
Das Ding hat einen Wert. Was ich eher sehe ist,
dass wir jetzt so viele Generationswechsel in der ganzen Entwicklung haben,
dass die Leute, die heutzutage den Mac vorantreiben, nicht mehr diese Bindung
an so ein paar Kernwerte haben, die den Mac immer mal ausgemacht haben.
Und es ist ja auch heute schon schwierig, Leuten den Reiz zum Beispiel von macOS 9,
macOS 8, also dem alten macOS zu erklären, weil es natürlich im direkten Vergleich
zu macOS 10 natürlich in jeder Hinsicht alt und überholt ist.
Nur gab es halt so ein paar Errungenschaften, die das alte macOS versucht hat in die Welt zu bringen,
letztlich aber quasi gegen die Dominanz von Unix und dem Internet so ein bisschen
abspecken musste, die aber nichtsdestotrotz sinnvolle Dinge waren.
Ich will mal ein Beispiel geben.
Wenn du auf einem alten macOS ein Programm hat, jetzt eine Datei geöffnet.
Und dann war die Art und Weise, wie das Programm mit dem Betriebssystem sich
über diese Datei ausgetauscht hat, so, dass es dort eine Referenz gab auf diese Datei.
Also das Programm hat irgendwie diese Datei geöffnet und hat über so eine,
ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie das jetzt hieß bei macOS, wusste ich mal.
Ich glaube File Record oder sowas in der Art.
Irgendwie so. Eine Datenstruktur ist eigentlich auch egal, wie es hieß,
aber es gab sozusagen so eine Datenstruktur und die war das.
Und diese Datenstruktur, die landete dann auch in den Preferences und was waren
meine letzten geöffneten Dateien und das war einfach das Einzige,
womit das Programm auf diese Datei zugegriffen hat. Pfade gab es nicht.
Und der Vorteil war, du konntest diese Datei danach irgendwo anders in einen
anderen Ordner legen und du konntest die auch umbenennen.
Also du ziehst sie aus dem Ordner raus, legst sie auf deinen Schreibtisch und
nennst die Hasenbärchen 23 und dann startest du dieses Programm und das Programm
weiß immer noch, wo diese Datei ist.
Und das kannst du aber auch machen, während das Programm offen ist,
kannst du die im Finder umbenennen und sofort heißt die auch in dem Programm
anders. Und du kannst da oben reinklicken und so weiter.
Und heute ist halt alles so Pfade und umbenannt und dann kackt das Programm
schon wieder ab, weil du es irgendwie erlaubt hast,
während das Programm die Datei offen hatte, die woanders hinzulegen und dann,
oh nee, was ist los? Ich weiß nicht mehr, wo oben und unten ist.
Das geht aber immer noch. Der
Entwickler muss natürlich die entsprechenden Technologien unterstützen.
Ja genau, aber darauf wollte ich so ein bisschen hinaus,
dass dieser Anspruch, dass das ein wichtiges Feature ist und dass man alles
dafür tun muss, dass das sozusagen auch funktioniert, den sehe ich halt mittlerweile
bei Apple selbst schon nicht mehr im Betriebssystem.
Und weil einfach die Leute, die das Betriebssystem vorantreiben,
nicht mehr diese Genauigkeit haben und nicht mehr genau genug die Fehler ausmerzen,
die dieses gute generelle Defaultverhalten ermöglichen.
Das geht so ein bisschen verloren.
Ja, ich glaube, da ist aber auch so ein bisschen, also zumindest bei iPadOS
hatte man lange das Gefühl, Dateien sind Ebay und die will man eigentlich gar
nicht irgendwie dem User zugänglich machen. Und...
Jetzt mit dem letzten iPadOS oder dem vorletzten iPadOS, wo sie endlich mal
diese Dateien-App richtig aufgeräumt haben, sodass sie auch benutzbar ist,
hat sich das, glaube ich, ein bisschen geändert.
Also jetzt besonders mit der 26, wo Apps dann doch wieder mehr mit Dateien machen
und mehr Fenster öffnen und auch ein Fenster pro Datei und solche Sachen.
Also ich glaube, da gibt es jetzt schon eine Gegenbewegung zu.
Da muss man halt mal gucken, wie gut die tatsächlich dann auch ankommt.
Aber ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass Apple jetzt dann doch versucht,
auch iPadOS und iOS da so ein bisschen als Brechstange zu benutzen,
um diese ganzen Features dann auch für den Mac wieder benutzbar zu machen.
Also keine Ahnung. Ich habe so das Gefühl, es gab so eine Zeit lang,
da war Datei, das ist wir, Datei und so weiter.
Ich meine, es gibt ja auch Programme, jetzt nicht unbedingt von Apple,
aber dieses Fusion, Autodesk Fusion,
da ist halt der Standard, du speicherst nicht deine Datei irgendwo auf den Rechner,
nein, sondern natürlich in die Cloud des Anbieters.
Also das ist auch bei vielen anderen Drittanbietern so, dass du das Gefühl hast,
nein, Dateien werden nicht mehr lokal gespeichert, die speichert man natürlich in die Cloud.
In die eigene Cloud.
In die eigene Cloud, ja und das löst natürlich so dieses ganze,
ich habe lokal ein Dateisystem und das ist auch gut und das kann auch Dinge
auch so ein bisschen irgendwie hinten runterfallen lässt.
Also mir ging es jetzt nicht primär ums Dateisystem, es war jetzt wirklich nur
ein Beispiel für so ein Verrotten der Erkenntnisse.
Das ist schon insofern ein gutes Beispiel, als dass mein absolutes Hassobjekt
ist ja im Finder ganz oben links der Filter zuletzt benutzt.
Wo man eigentlich erwarten würde, was immer ich gerade auf dem Rechner gemacht
habe, dort finde ich die Sachen schnell mit einem Klick wieder.
Ich weiß nicht, nach was für einem System dort Dateien erscheinen, kategorisiert werden.
In 80 Prozent gefühlt, das ist jetzt anekdotische Evidenz, wenn ich an irgendeiner
Datei gerade was wurschtel, ist die dort nicht zu finden.
Also du hast das auch im Finder, dieses Zuletzt Benutzen.
Genau, im Finder. Ich rede nur vom Finder jetzt. Weil also, was ich nun wirklich
ständig habe, ich habe das glaube ich auch schon ein, zwei Mal in der Sendung
erzählt, so eins meiner Lieblingsfeatures auf Windows.
Ich habe auf der Arbeit ja Windows und arbeite wahrscheinlich mehr vor einem
Windows-Rechner als vor einem Mac, was so meine Lebenszeit angeht.
Wenn ich deine Mail verschicke und einen Anhang dranhängen will,
der letzten Datei, die ich bearbeitet habe, dann machst du halt Outlook auf
und sagst neue Mail und an wen geht die.
Dann hast du oben rechts den Dateianhängen-Button und da ist ein kleiner Pfeil
und dann klickst du auf diesen kleinen Pfeil und dann hast du die letzten zehn
Dateien, an denen du gewerkelt hast und klickst die einfach an und schwupps ist sie drin.
Und es funktioniert einfach. Egal, was ich auf diesem Windows-Rechner mache,
ob ich eine Word-Datei mache, ob ich eine PDF erstellt habe oder was auch immer.
Du kannst dir sicher sein, diese letzten zehn Dateien sind exakt an dieser Stelle mit einem.
Versuch das mal auf dem Mac, die letzte benutzte Datei in eine fucking E-Mail anzuhängen.
Also ich habe den gerade mal aufgemacht, weil ich habe den noch nie benutzt.
Du musst glaube ich in die Listensortierung gehen, ansonsten.
Nee, nee, das ist schon okay, da kann man ja so ein bisschen sehen.
Interessanterweise ist mindestens die Hälfte, wenn nicht zwei Drittel der Dateien,
die da auftauchen, sind alle in meinem iCloud Drive drin und die habe ich als
letztes vom iPad aus benutzt, im iCloud Drive.
Also hat er sich jetzt gemerkt, ich habe auf dem iPad zuletzt diese Datei benutzt,
was jetzt, ja, kann man sich jetzt streiten, ob das gut oder schlecht ist.
So, was heißt aber benutzt? Was ist das für ein Wording?
Habe ich die jetzt irgendwie erstellt? Habe ich daran was editiert?
Habe ich mir die angeschaut? Was ist denn benutzt eigentlich?
Also ich kann es dir sagen, bei mir ist jetzt eine Datei, die habe ich benutzt.
Also verändert war eine Numbers-Tabelle.
Dann zwei PDFs, die ich nur angeguckt habe.
Eine STL-Datei, die ich erstellt habe und dann….
Es beantwortet sich, wenn du im Feinder mal auf die Spalte guckst,
nach der es sortiert ist. Die heißt nämlich zuletzt geöffnet.
Naja, du kannst ja sagen, was du, du kannst auch hinzugefügt am,
kannst auch danach sortieren.
Das ist jetzt kein, das sagt dir nicht, was der eigentliche Filter ist,
damit hier was erscheint oder nicht erscheint.
Doch, denke schon.
Du kannst das dann nach beliebigen Spalten sortieren.
Ja, aber das ist, glaube ich, das Kriterium an der Stelle.
Das sagst du so in deinem jugendlichen Leichtum?
Ja, sag ich.
Also zum Beispiel, schönes Beispiel, ich habe jetzt hier...
Der macht ja noch so eine Zwischenkategorisierung der Zeit, was ich erstmal
gut finde. Heute, gestern, vorherige sieben Tage.
So, jetzt habe ich also unter heute zwei Dateien.
Gestern, zuletzt geöffnet, eine Datei, vorherige sieben Tage.
Die erste Datei dort, wann war sie zuletzt geöffnet? Gestern.
Warum steht die denn nicht unter gestern?
What the fuck? Magie.
Ja, nee.
Ja.
Also ich glaube nämlich ist es eher hinzugefügt, was das Sortierkriterium macht.
Also ich habe diese Zwischendinger nicht.
So, aber zuletzt geöffnet. Heißt das auch Quick Look? Also PDFs öffne ich ja
überhaupt nie, sondern mache immer nur Quick Look mit Space,
weil das reicht mir völlig zum Lesen, für meine Benutzung dieses PDFs.
Zählt aber nicht. Ja, scheiße.
Du hast diese Unterteilung, wenn du den Sortieralgorithmus auf zuletzt geöffnet einstellst.
Was ist denn der Sortieralgorithmus?
Da oben im Sidebar hast du so ein Pop-up geduldet.
Hä?
Nee, nee, Tim, ist es wirklich alles Mist? Guck dir das mal an.
Ich glaube ja, dass das alles Mist ist.
Ich habe jetzt mal ein PDF aufgemacht. Dann wird das zuletzt geöffnet,
aktualisiert. Aber es landet immer noch nicht in der Heute-Spalte.
Äh, ah, okay hä, ach, das hab ich das Gruppieren, ach, Gruppieren ja,
Gruppieren hab ich ohne deswegen hab ich keine Gruppen ja.
Gruppieren find ich schon sinnvoll.
Aber naja, egal, Details wir waren eigentlich bei Apple und warum die Keynote
nicht mehr zackt die Frage ist, wenn jetzt irgendwie Tim guckt,
dann wirklich mal sagt, so das war's,
abgesehen davon, dass wir alle glaube ich auch nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung
haben, wer ihm denn nachfolgen könnte könnte man sich ja mal was wünschen.
Und ich denke mir, also,
The new Apple, ja, also was sollten sie machen?
Redest du jetzt Themen oder redest du Leute?
Nein, ich kann nicht sagen, wer jetzt der neue Chef wird bei Apple,
weil ich glaube, da gibt es auch in der ganzen Community keinerlei Konsens.
Es gab so ein paar, weiß ich nicht, vor Jahren dachten alles,
dass es dieser Williams wird, aber der hat jetzt irgendwie angekündigt,
dass er in Rente geht, also wird das wohl eher nicht.
Und steht jetzt niemand so offensichtlich in der zweiten Reihe.
Es gibt natürlich, sagen wir mal, die sichtbarste Person ist natürlich hier
Air Force One, der natürlich ein hervorragender Präsentator wäre.
Wie heißt der denn nochmal?
Ich weiß es auch gerade nicht. Air Force One.
Aber alle wissen, wer gemeint ist.
Es gibt ja nur einen Air Force Formula One.
Craig Federighi.
Doch, doch, doch, Federighi.
Genau so.
Craig.
Der ist lustig und kompetent, aber ist halt ein Engineer und vielleicht nicht
unbedingt CEO-Material.
Na ja...
Egal, wir wissen es nicht. Irgendjemand wird es sein.
Und wenn diese Person dann aus dem Schatten tritt, dann ist die Frage, was wird anders?
Ja, also was würdest du tun, Roddy, wenn du morgen, Chef, was würdest du anders
machen als Tim Cook, wenn du morgen bei Apple wärst?
Was wären deine ersten Entscheidungen?
Du, ganz ehrlich, das ist mir zu hypothetisch, weil ich werde nie Apple-Chef sein.
Ich kann ja mal sagen, was ich mir wünschen würde.
Ja, davon rede ich doch.
Und zwar eins der Dinge, die ich mir wünschen würde,
ist, dass sie tatsächlich wieder mehr Geld in Development, in Research und Development stecken.
Also dieses Aktien zurückkaufen, um den Kurs zu stabilisieren,
das ist zwar kurzfristig kann das sinnvoll sein, aber auf die Dauer ist das
ja keine Löhre. Du weißt ja schon.
Warum sie das machen.
Ja, um den Kurs zu stabilisieren.
Ja, aber warum machen sie das?
Damit die Aktionäre nicht...
Nee, also ja auch, aber nicht nur. Es ist halt einfach viel der,
Um die eigene Workforce zu halten, haben halt viele auch solche Aktienoptionen.
Das heißt, die Mitarbeiter, die wichtigen Mitarbeiter, die leben auch in gewisser
Hinsicht von dem Aktienkurs selber.
Und deswegen ist das einfach ein wichtiger, also eigentlich kannst du sagen,
das ist im Wesentlichen das Personalkosten.
Ja, einerseits ja, andererseits ist es so, dass du die Aktienpakete ja immer im Voraus bekommst.
Also sie geben dir dann Aktien über die nächsten drei Jahre verteilt,
die irgendwie alle Vierteljahr oder alle halbe Jahr dann Westen, wie es so schön heißt.
Also solange du nicht kündigst, kriegst du die dann auch ausbezahlt,
die Aktien. Aber wenn du kündigst, sind die halt alle weg.
Das hat dann zur Folge, dass du, wenn du kündigst,
halt weiß ich nicht zigtausend potenzielle Aktien verlierst und dann kostet
dich das Kündigen halt so viel, wie du noch Aktien kriegen würdest,
wenn du bleiben würdest.
Ja, aber auch was die Aktien wert sind und diese Aussicht, dass der Aktienkurs
auf jeden Fall stabil bleibt und potenziell halt weiter steigt,
ist sicherlich nicht unwichtig.
Egal, kann man so sehen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall Teil der Überlegung, warum sie das machen.
Ja, das ist das eine. Das zweite ist, dass ich so das Gefühl habe,
dass sich Apple immer weniger gegen die N-Gertification wehrt,
wo du halt dann doch zum Beispiel, dass in die EU Features kommen,
die gar nicht EU-kritisch, nicht kommen, die gar nicht EU-kritisch sind,
sondern die Apple einfach nur nicht bringt, weil sie irgendwie versuchen,
dass die EU ihnen nicht in die Suppe spuckt. Beispiel?
Das iPhone Mirroring zum Beispiel. Das hat mir noch keiner erklärt,
warum das in der EU ein Feature ist, was nicht funktioniert.
Na, kann ich dir sagen.
Weil sie halt nicht gezwungen sein wollen, das Feature für Android zu öffnen. Ganz einfach.
Und das ist generell ihre Linie, was den Marketing Act betrifft.
Das ist das Kernproblem.
Wir haben derzeit eine Gesetzgebung in Europa, die eben diesen Unternehmen,
im Wesentlichen halt Apple, also den großen Playern, vorschreibt,
dass wenn sie jetzt Vertical Integration machen mit ihren eigenen Produkten,
was ja eins der Kernfeatures von Apple ist an sich, dass sie sowas tun,
dass sie sozusagen ihre Produkte selbst gut in ihr,
Gesamtangebot integrieren und dadurch eben,
weil es ja ihre eigenen Sachen sind und weil sie damit ja gute Sachen machen
können, wenn sie das richtig tun,
einen höheren Level an Usability haben.
Richtig.
Aber jetzt werden sie quasi gezwungen, dass wenn sie das machen,
dass sie von Tag 1 nicht irgendwann mal,
sondern sie müssen von Tag 1 auch sofort noch die Möglichkeit bieten,
dass andere Hersteller dann den Spaß auch haben dürfen.
Und das schafft natürlich mehrere Probleme auf einmal.
Erstens, du, also erstmal werden sie quasi gezwungen, ihren.
Also ein Kern-Alleinstellungsmerkmal preiszugeben.
Weil es gibt ja gar nicht viele Unternehmen, die so arbeiten wie Apple.
Eigentlich gibt es nur Apple, was so arbeitet wie Apple. Andere Problem rein technischer Natur ist,
das bedeutet ja, wenn du, also so was, iPhone Mirroring ist eigentlich ein sehr
gutes Beispiel, weil die Integration von dem iPhone Mirroring ist ja nicht trivial.
Das ist ja nicht nur Screensharing und dann siehst du deinen iPhone Bildschirm
auf dem Mac, sondern das geht ja weiter. Das ist ja eine Meta-Verbindung.
Du kannst da Drag und Drop machen, das Telefon weiß, dass es ferngesteuert wird,
schaltet sich dann schwarz.
Also da ist sozusagen schon eine ganze Kaskade von Dingen mit drin,
die jetzt nur über dieses, oh ich sehe meinen Bildschirm, Security,
Handshaking, die ganze Krypto, die sozusagen sicherstellt, dass das Telefon
auch wirklich nur auf deinem Rechner auftaucht und nicht von irgendeinem anderen
Rechner in dieser Welt genauso gemirrert werden kann,
wenn halt die ganze Krypto nicht stimmt und so weiter.
Das alles entwickeln sie damit und sie sind derzeit gesetzlich verpflichtet,
weil sie diesen Status haben, dass sie ja den Markt beherrschen, ja angeblich.
Also ich weiß, es heißt anders, dominante Plattformformulierung habe ich jetzt gerade vergessen.
Auf jeden Fall sind sie dazu gezwungen und deswegen müssten sie in dem Moment,
wo sie iPhone Mirroring anbieten, so vermuten sie zumindest und die werden ihre
Gespräche sicherlich mit der EU geführt haben.
Müssen sie das quasi auch allen anderen Herstellern, Samsung,
Google, wer auch immer gerade ankommt, die sagen so, ja, das wollen wir aber jetzt auch machen.
Dazu müsstest du aber dann quasi deine intern erarbeitete API für diesen ganzen
Kram sofort als Third-Party-API publizieren, die unter Umständen noch nicht
mal komplett ausgereift ist, wo du...
Erstmal so, was weiß ich, fängst erst mal mit dem Feature-Set an,
dann stellst du, oh hier ist aber noch ein Bug drin, Security-Architektur,
nächste Version kommt, alles ist anders.
Das gab es auch schon sehr oft, dass du so einen ersten Aufschlag hast,
dann haben sie festgestellt, dass sie da in die falsche Richtung laufen in der
Integration und dann haben sie das alles nochmal neu geschrieben.
Das könnten sie ja machen, das würde ja für die Third-Partys nur noch schwieriger
werden, das zu unterstützen.
Ja, aber was ist denn das bitte für ein, also ich kann ehrlich gesagt diese
Denke nicht nachvollziehen, warum jetzt ein Unternehmen dazu gezwungen sein sollte,
automatisch die Sachen, die sie für sich und ihre Gründen entwickeln,
automatisch auch allen Kompetitoren zur Verfügung stellen, von Anfang an, also von Tag 1 an.
Also noch nicht mal ein nach fünf Jahren oder so, oder wenn es eine gewisse
Popularität hat oder irgendwelche Einschränkungen.
Und das ist das Kernproblem in dieser ganzen Debatte.
Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, oh ja, Apple und so, ihr macht das ja nur out
of spite und jetzt tut ihr nur so, als wäre das ein großes Problem.
Aber wenn ich mir das anschaue, wie das definiert ist, kann ich das ehrlich
gesagt sehr gut verstehen, dass sie das machen und wir werden noch mehr Features nicht sehen.
Ich glaube, wenn sie wollten, könnten sie es schon machen. Also da bin ich relativ überzeugt von.
Sie haben ja auch andere komplexe Standards veröffentlicht.
Und anderen zugänglich gemacht.
Ja, aber das ist ja Ihre Entscheidung, was Sie jetzt machen.
Ja, klar, das ist Ihre Entscheidung. Nur, ich finde, es ist ein bisschen vorgeschoben, ist es schon.
Ja, aber jetzt mal andersrum. Warum sollten Sie denn das tun müssen?
Also warum müssen Sie auch Android auf dem Bildschirm lassen und sozusagen eine
API für alle anderen machen,
damit die kostenlos genau dasselbe Feature haben, wie Apple für ihre eigenen Produkte.
Zugegebenermaßen glaube ich auch nicht, dass das so ist, weil jeder kann eine
Mac-App schreiben, die Ähnliches kann.
Also ich meine, eine Mac-App, die sich zu einem Android-Phone verbindet und
das fernsteuert, ist ja jetzt kein Hexenwerk.
Da müssen sie sich halt ihren eigenen Standard ausdenken.
Aber Drag & Drop ist ein gelöstes Problem. Kopieren und Einsetzen ist ein gelöstes Problem.
Es geht ja darum, dass die EU sagt, der Code, der das für das Telefon macht,
muss das auch für alle anderen machen.
Es geht nicht darum.
Dass niemand sowas ähnliches bauen darf.
Ich glaube, so direkt sagt es die EU nicht.
Genau das sagt die EU. Das ist genau das, was da drin steht.
Und das ist der Grund, warum wir diese Features nicht sehen.
Weil sie halt einfach sagen, wir machen das nicht.
Wir arbeiten nicht für unseren Wettbewerb. Wir sehen es überhaupt nicht ein.
Und ich kann das ehrlich gesagt ganz gut nachvollziehen. Also es ist...
Ich verstehe das nicht. Und das ist halt einfach ein Nachteil für ein Unternehmen,
dessen Produktstrategie vertikale Integration ist.
Das ist nun mal nicht die Strategie von allen anderen.
Ja klar, wenn ein offene Standards dazu zwingen, dass man kein User-Login machen
kann, ist das natürlich ein Produkt, das ist ein Nachteil, das ziehe ich ein.
Aber dass ich als Kunde kein User-Login unbedingt will, das ist natürlich,
von der anderen Seite kannst du das auch.
Was meinst du jetzt mit User-Login?
Naja, du hast ein Vendor-Login, wenn du Features nur dann bekommst,
wenn du auch aus dem gleichen Hause kaufst.
Das ist ja so, als würde dir der Autohersteller das Benzin auch noch verkaufen
und du müsstest bei BMW auch immer das BMW-Benzin kaufen,
weil andere Hersteller haben nicht die Möglichkeit,
Benzin zu produzieren, die du in deinem BMW verfahren kannst.
Also das ist schon sinnvoll, dass man sagt, hey, an gewissen Stellen müssen Standards offen sein.
Ja, aber es ist ja kein Standard. Ja.
IPhone Mirroring ist ein Feature, was so keiner vorher gebaut hat.
Das ist kein Standard. Das ist ein neues Feature.
Und das wird ja nicht automatisch zum Standard, nur weil Apple das jetzt einführt.
Ein Standard ist doch was ganz anderes. Standards gibt es viele.
Was eigentlich auch von Google für Android?
Keine Ahnung. Frag mich nichts über Android. Bin ich kein Experte zu.
Nur die Frage, warum macht Apple das nicht? Das ist die Antwort.
Weil sie derzeit gezwungen werden, quasi ihr Kernentwicklungsmodell,
wie sie ihre Produkte auslegen, so nicht mehr durchzuführen.
Und ich finde es unangemessen.
Ich meine, man kann darüber argumentieren, dass wird ein bestimmtes Feature aussehen.
Popularität erreicht und in sich wichtig ist.
Weil die Einschätzung ist ja, Apple ist an sich wegen ihrer Dominanz auf dem,
auf irgendwelchen Märkten ist sie jetzt sozusagen also auf dem Mobilfunkmarkt vor allem, ja,
weil iOS wichtig ist und das sehe ich ja auch komplett ein, also da sage ich ja gar nichts dagegen.
Natürlich ist sie dominant und natürlich ist ich bin auch der Meinung,
um es klar mal dazu zu sagen, ich bin auch der Meinung, das soll auf jeden Fall reguliert werden.
Ich sage nicht, da soll nichts reguliert werden.
Die Frage ist nur, was genau reguliert man?
Und gerade bei dieser ganzen Debatte um Apps und alternative App-Store,
das habe ich ja auch schon tausendmal erzählt, wie ich das sehe,
ich sage halt, reguliert den App-Store als solchen, da kommt ihr schneller voran.
Schreibt einfach genau vor, was da gemacht werden darf und was dort nicht gemacht werden darf.
Aber unabhängig von dem App-Store ist es ja jetzt so, das ist ein diese generelle
Einstufung gibt von diesen Plattformen,
iOS und jetzt eben auch iPadOS, dass da quasi Features jetzt automatisch auch
allen anderen zugänglich gemacht werden müssen und zwar vollkommen unabhängig
davon, wann und das sofort.
Und das finde ich.
Also ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen. Warum muss das dann jetzt automatisch
vom Tag 1 an eine offene Sache sein?
Wenn man jetzt feststellt, oh ja, iPhone-Mirroring, das ist ja ein Feature,
ohne das kann ja die Welt nicht mehr leben.
Leute sind ja im Prinzip gar nicht mehr in der Lage, mit ihrem Telefon zu arbeiten,
wenn sie nicht auch in der Lage sind, das auf ihren Desktop-Computer zu mirroren.
Wenn das der Konsens der Welt ist und wenn irgendwie die Weltwirtschaft davon
abhängt und alle schwitzen und stöhnen und sagen, ja, aber wir können ja kein
Mirroring machen mit unseren Devices, deswegen müssen wir jetzt was mit Holz
machen, Dann kann man ja sagen,
okay, wir haben hier einen wichtigen Aspekt der mobilen Betriebssystemökonomie
entdeckt und diese Feature-Kategorie,
die muss jetzt spezieller Regulierung unterlegen und Anbieter sind jetzt gezwungen,
dieses Feature nach drei Jahren auch anderen zugänglich zu machen.
Komplett anderes Playing-Field, weißt du, das ist, das kann man argumentieren,
aber derzeit ist es halt, nee, weil ihr, weil diese Plattform so ist,
darf jetzt nichts mehr nur noch für euch sein und das halte ich,
ehrlich gesagt, finde ich okay.
Gut, ich kenne jetzt die Regularien nicht gut, aber ich habe das Gefühl,
das ist eine extreme Interpretation dessen, was da drin steht,
aber gut, wie gesagt, ohne Ohne jetzt tatsächlich zu wissen,
was da drin steht, hat es an der Stelle keinen Sinn, weiter zu diskutieren.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Also eigentlich war die Fragestellung ja eine ganz andere.
Was würde ich anders machen?
Also mein Gefühl war so ein bisschen, als Steve Jobs noch CEO war,
kamen so die Geräte so zack auf zack.
IPod, iPhone, iPad, die Uhr kam ein bisschen später, aber ich glaube,
die ist auch noch so eine Ausgeburt von Steve.
Apple TV gab es da auch schon.
Ja, Apple TV gab es auch schon, obwohl ich dem ja nie so richtig viel Bedeutung beigemessen habe.
Und ich habe so das Gefühl, dass das…,
Tim Cook eigentlich nur noch den Niedergang verwaltet, obwohl jetzt auch kein
Niedergang stattgefunden hat, muss man der Fairness halber sagen,
aber auf der anderen Seite kann man natürlich,
man kann sich halt darauf konzentrieren, neue Zitronenbäume zu pflanzen oder
man kann sich darauf konzentrieren, die Zitronen, die man hat,
härter auszupressen und ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl,
dass zu wenig Bäume gepflanzt werden und zu viele Zitronen zu hart gepresst werden,
um mal so einen ganz blöden blöde Allegorie zu sehr.
Okay, also lässt sich auf keine konkreten Maßnahmen jetzt...
Naja, weil ich, weil nee gut, das hat ja einen Grund, dass ich kein CEO für
irgendwen bin, weil ich jetzt die Genialität oder zumindest den Überblick,
den Steve hatte, vielleicht dann doch nicht habe.
Aha, aha, was machst du hier eigentlich in der Freak-Schule?
Deswegen haben wir dich doch hier eigentlich da dumm rumlabern.
Nee, also Ja, keine Ahnung. Sagen wir mal so, produktmäßig, das habe ich schon mal gesagt,
ich glaube, dass Apple gut daran täte, ein Gaming-Handheld rauszubringen,
weil der Markt wird explodieren.
Ich glaube, dass die Ära Gaming-PC so langsam ihrem Ende entgegen geht und ein
mobiles Gaming mit einem, ich sag mal,
Switch-ähnlichen Gerät oder Steam Deck oder wie heißt das Ding,
Rock Ally oder wie sie alle heißen.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Zug, der wird sehr, sehr bald aus der Halle fahren.
Und wenn man da nicht aufgestiegen ist, dann fährt er ohne einen aus der Halle.
Da bin ich mir relativ sicher, dass das ein Ding ist, was funktionieren kann.
Und also da würde ich sagen, sollte Apple auf jeden Fall in dem Markt mitschwimmen.
Ja, Apple hat immer Probleme mit Spielen gehabt.
Keine Ahnung wieso. vielleicht auch, weil sie nie Hardware zu den Preisen angeboten
hat, die die Leute in dem Alter, wo sie viel spielen, sich auch großartig leisten können.
Obwohl, wenn ich mehr angucke, was Nintendo jetzt haben will,
was dieses ROG Ally kosten soll, dann frage ich mich, ob die sich nicht auch
so ein bisschen mit dem Preis vertan haben.
Aber scheinbar scheint sich die Switch 2 ja unglaublich gut zu verkaufen. Ähm,
Ja, ansonsten keine Ahnung. Also das ist auch ein anderes Thema,
was ich gesagt habe. Die Vision ist zu teuer.
Da entsteht kein Third-Party-Markt, wenn keine Leute das Ding kaufen.
Und wenn es keine Leute kaufen, dann macht auch keiner Third-Party-Applications dafür.
Da müssen sie unbedingt in der nächsten Generation ran, maximum 2000 Euro, sage ich mal.
Wenn nicht sogar ein Einsteigergerät für 1000 oder so rausbringen,
damit es ein gewisses Massenphänomen wird, die dazu führt, dass Leute sagen,
okay, dafür will ich auch Software machen, da will ich dabei sein.
Ansonsten, ja, keine Ahnung. Also beim iPhone zum Beispiel denke ich mir immer,
da haben wir jetzt dasselbe Brot neu aufgeschnitten.
Wir haben ja alle gesagt, dass die Keynote langweilig war, weil es war halt schneller.
Manche waren an einigen Stellen dünner und ansonsten war es das und die Kameras
waren besser. Aber dieses Orange.
Ich hätte in der Tat gerne dieses Orange.
Ein göttliches Orange, aber ich werde dafür nicht, was soll das kosten? 2000 Euro? Egal.
Da machen sie ein komplettes Redesign des Telefons und für dich ist das so ein
bisschen schneller, höher, weiter?
Ja, weil es ist schneller, höher, weiter.
Das ist ja auch das, was die Leute wollen.
Also du willst mir doch nicht erzählen, dass eine Vapor Chamber jetzt irgendwie das geile Feature ist.
Doch klar, natürlich ist das das geile Feature, weil das halt das Problem löst,
was das iPhone vorher hatte und sie haben es halt durch ein komplettes Redesign
gelöst oder offensichtlich gelöst.
Ich habe keinen iPhone 17 Pro, werde mir auch keins kaufen, aber alle Tests
zeigen ja relativ deutlich, dass diese Wärmeproblematik damit sich komplett geändert hat.
Aber bleiben wir mal ganz kurz, was Apple tun sollte. Du meinst also Produkte,
alles muss billiger werden?
Ralf, was bist du jetzt CEO?
Nicht alles muss billiger werden, aber...
Ja, aber du machst es primär an Produkten fest. Das ist das,
was ich jetzt rausgehört habe. Wann würdest du arbeiten als CEO?
Also, ich habe gerade auf der Arbeit wieder festgestellt,
Und das hat mich überrascht, weil damit hatte ich selber überhaupt nicht gerechnet,
was für einen Riesenunterschied es macht, vor einem wirklich großen Screen zu sitzen.
So wie plötzlich sich meine Büroarbeitsorganisation einfach nur die Screen Estate 4K Auflösung ändert.
Oder auch mehr.
Ich kann nochmal raussuchen, welchen Monitor ich da jetzt habe.
Wie gesagt unter Windows kann man aber auch schön Mac dran anschließen.
Irgendwie 300 Euro, gar nicht viel Geld und es ist irre, wie viel produktiver
und mehr Übersicht man dadurch hat.
So, das hätte ich jetzt auch gerne zu Hause. Der Women's Acceptance Faktor geht aber gegen Null.
Und da glaube ich, wäre eine Vision Pro, die super runter reduziert ist auf,
die kann eigentlich fast nichts außer einen irren großen Screen dir aber in
super Auflösung vors Auge zu setzen.
Würde mich sehr, sehr, sehr heiß machen,
und ich brauche dann keine Simulation meines Gesichtes von außen und es muss
nicht aus irgendwie Aluminium sein und irgendwie sonst was einfach nur der Use
Case gibt mir einen gigantisch großen Screen mit einer vernünftigen Brille was
sich irgendwie super flüssig,
bedienen lässt und Retina Auflösung hat dafür würde ich 2000 Euro ausgeben,
aber eben nicht 4000. Ja, da bin ich echt bei Roddy.
Da musst du aber aufpassen, nicht, dass die EU Apple verbietet,
irgendwie Mac Mirroring auf der Vision zu machen.
Ja, also das wäre echt ein Use Case, das hätte ich gerne zu Hause. Ähm...
Und das mit dem Gaming, das erzähle ich auch schon seit längerem,
wenn sie zumindest mal einen Controller machen würde, wo irgendwie das iPhone
sich vernünftig reinplackt, ja, da gibt es ja sogar Drittanbieter, die sowas machen,
wäre auch eine Variante, aber da glaube ich nicht dran, weil wie du schon sagst,
das ist einfach nicht in der DNA von Apple drin, da müsste dann wirklich irgendjemand
mal von einer anderen Firma rüber machen,
ja, so ein Betriebsleiter, Xbox oder halt irgendwie von Playstation oder so,
der da wirklich diese DNA mal reininjiziert.
So von sich aus wird Apple das nicht tun.
Und das dritte, was ich aber wirklich mir wünschen würde, ist,
dass die mal so ein UX-Neudenken-Thema mal aufgreifen würden.
Ich habe das vor drei Jahren hier schon mal ausgeführt.
Ich finde, man muss nochmal neu denken, wie man eigentlich arbeitet mit so einem Rechner.
Wenn ich arbeite, dann ist es eigentlich so Projekt an Projekt an Projekt,
aber auch mehrere irgendwie parallel.
Und ich möchte einfach so Environments, Workspaces haben, in dem,
so, jetzt möchte ich mich um Thema X kümmern, ja, Masterwall,
was sind jetzt die zehn Ressourcen, die ich dafür eigentlich brauche,
so, und die möchte ich dann sofort parat haben.
Und die will ich aber nicht irgendwie in 30 Screens die ganze Zeit da haben
und ich will sie schon überhaupt gar nicht in irgendwelchen Ordnern zusammenführen, im Dateisystem,
aber trotzdem so Informationen auf verschiedenen Ebenen von einem Rechner,
wie kriege ich die projektorientiert in so eine vernünftige Arbeitsmappe irgendwie
zusammen und wie bildet sich sowas in der UX ab.
Vielleicht mocke ich da irgendwann mal was zusammen und hau es mal in die Welt
raus, wie man sich sowas irgendwie vorstellen könnte.
Irgendeiner muss ja mal anfangen. Also ich glaube, dieses Thema ist einfach nicht zu Ende erzählt.
Wie man mit wenig Klicks gut sich eine digitale Arbeitsumgebung irgendwie zusammenbauen kann.
Und das kann dann auch gerne in einer Vision mit irgendwie im dreidimensionalen
Raum irgendwie verortet sein.
Auch alles gerne. Aber das, was ich pro Tag an Zeit verliere,
weil ich einen quasi Domain-Change irgendwie mache und gerade mein Thema der
Arbeit ändere und mich dann erstmal wieder zusammensuchen muss,
wo waren jetzt hier eigentlich die Geschichten, die ich dafür brauchte,
das deprimiert mich total. Das muss besser gehen.
Und Apple schafft es derzeit mir noch nicht mal, meine letzten fünf editierten
Dateien anzuzeigen. Und das muss echt anders sein.
Okay, also auch bei dir Produkte, Produkte, Produkte. Letztlich,
wenn ich das richtig raushöre.
Ich wollte einen anderen Aspekt mal betonen. Also wenn ich jetzt CEO wäre,
was würde ich anders machen?
Services.
Bitte?
Nee, Services.
Ja,
wenn nicht Produkte, dann Services.
Services is a trap. Das ist der große Stolperstein, über den Apple die ganze Zeit stolpert.
Das ist natürlich good for the shareholders.
Services, klar, Revenue, iCloud, Pipapo, Subscription, alles reinballern.
Apple TV hast du nicht gesehen.
Ich finde ja auch, ihr Angebot ist nicht im eigentlichen Sinne schlecht.
Ich finde, sie sind was so Storage-Preise betrifft ein bisschen also sowohl
im Verkauf ihrer Produkte als auch im Verkauf ihrer Services.
Die Storage-Preise sind eine Frechheit. Das könnte man anders gestalten,
aber das ist jetzt eine reine Preis-Diskussion.
Sagt aber natürlich auch ein bisschen was aus, weil Apple kommt halt super greedy rüber.
Und das ist definitiv ein Problem, denn sie sollten generell nicht greedy rüberkommen.
Sie sollten eigentlich überhaupt nicht irgendwie so rüberkommen,
wie alle anderen sowieso rüberkommen, weil das ist eben nicht ihr Ding.
Also Apple muss wieder cool werden und das ist natürlich schwierig,
weil Apple ist nicht mehr der kleine Laden von vor 30 Jahren,
sondern sie sind halt mittlerweile irgendwie.
Top 1, 2 oder 3 nach Marktkapitalisierung und das macht natürlich was mit so einem Laden.
Es sind groß, tausend Standorte, viele Produktlinien, alles mögliche.
Überall haben sie ihre Finger mit drin. Sie sind natürlich auch so ein Player
und jetzt müssen sie sich halt auch gegenüber der faschistischen Regierung von
Trump irgendwie verhalten und kriegen natürlich von allen Seiten Flack und das
ist sicherlich auch kein Spaß.
Und nichts, was sie gerne machen, aber es gehört halt dazu. Ich will aber nicht
über Trump reden, sondern einfach, was müssten sie sozusagen ändern.
Also ich bin jetzt CEO und dann kommt das erste Board Meeting und dann lege
ich meine Agenda hin und sage, Leute, so geht das nicht weiter hier.
Ja, Produkte, alles schön und gut so, aber es gibt jetzt hier ein paar Leute,
die müssen wir mal richtig lieb haben.
Und wer ist die Gruppe, die am meisten lieb gehabt werden muss?
Entwickler.
Entwickler, Entwickler, Developers, Developers, Developers, Developers.
Ach, dieser Vogel.
Also ich würde irgendwie so ein Bold-Move machen und mal überlegen,
was könnten wir den Entwicklern schenken?
Und zwar nicht unbedingt Geld, das vielleicht auch.
Also allein schon mal so den Prozentsatz für kleine Developer vielleicht einfach
nochmal runtersetzen. Haben sie schon gemacht so.
Aber da kann man auch noch irgendwie ein zweites Tier einführen und so weiter.
Oder das so wie generell zu so einem Sliding Window machen, damit würden sie
sich auf jeden Fall schon mal einen gewissen Respekt holen.
Das wäre jetzt noch nicht ausreichend, aber es wäre, sagen wir mal, das Erste.
Das Zweite ist, neben den besseren Konditionen,
Einfach sehr viel Energie darauf zu legen, so eine offenere Fehlerkultur zu
haben, weil einfach die Bugs, die in diesem komplexen Betriebssystem Zoo drinstecken,
die sind so nervig, wenn die irgendwie keinerlei Reflexionen finden,
das nervt alle, das nervt User, das nervt,
also es gibt einfach zu wenig Möglichkeiten.
Okay, sie haben diese Beta-Testings gemacht und es ist nicht so,
dass da jetzt gar nichts passiert, aber es ist definitiv nicht ausreichend.
Und Entwickler müssen da einfach noch mehr supported werden.
Ich weiß, das ist alles teuer, aber den Spaß müssen sie sich erlauben,
weil sie müssen wieder mal gut gefunden werden von ihren Entwicklern.
Da kann ich gleich mal einhaken. Es gibt nämlich, also gerade wenn man iOS macht,
gibt es so ganz viele Dinge, die fürchterlich nerven.
Die wahrscheinlich einfach zu fixen wären von Apple.
Und Apple versteht es aber nicht, dass es so ein großes Problem ist.
Da ist das Erste, wie viele Tester kann ich in meinem Account haben?
Wie viele Testgeräte kann ich in meinem Account haben?
Und du kannst auch nicht sagen, ja okay, ich brauche aber mehr Geräte,
kann ich jetzt mehr Geld einwerfen?
Nein, du hast 100 iPhones, du hast 100 iPads, 100 Apple Watches und 100 Vision
Pros, die du in deinen Account als Testgeräte reinmachst.
Und da ist es völlig egal, ob du drei Millionen User hast oder 30.
Das ist, weißt du, und ich meine, das kostet 100 Euro im Jahr.
Und ich glaube, ich könnte meine Firma überzeugen, 300 Euro reinzuwerfen,
wenn wir dann 500 Geräte und 500 Internal Users als Tester haben könnten.
Also das verstehe ich so überhaupt nicht.
Und dann Code-Signing.
Code-Signing ist die Pest. Es ist wirklich die Pest, weil die ganze Software,
die dahinter hängt, einfach mal unbenutzbar ist,
keine ordentlichen Fehlermeldungen wirft, du nie so genau weißt, woran es hakt.
Gut ist bei Krypto im Allgemeinen so, also Krypto-Software, nicht Krypto-Coins,
dass du immer nicht so genau weißt, woran hängt es jetzt.
Das ist so eine Kultur, möglichst nichts zugeben oder so.
Nur wenn der Schlüssel und alles, was du damit tust, exakt passt, dann darfst du.
Weiß ich nicht. Ein guter Krypto-Algorithmus sollte einem als User trotzdem
den Hinweis geben, so nett, dass du den Schlüssel versucht hast,
ich brauche da mal einen anderen oder sowas in der Art. Und dann ...
Wie soll ich sagen, ein schnellerer Compiler wäre eigentlich auch mal ganz gut.
Okay. Ein schnellerer Compiler ist immer gut.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt alle sagen, unser Compiler muss nicht so schnell sein.
Da werden sie schon irgendwie was probieren.
Mir geht es jetzt eher um, wie stehen wir zu unseren Kunden und wie stehen wir
zu unserer wichtigen Community.
Weil Apple hat lange Zeit auch davon gelebt, dass sie die besonderen Entwickler
hatten, die die coolen Applikationen gemacht haben.
Ein Photoshop und so weiter und viele Quark Express, also so viele Dinge sind
auf dem Mac entstanden, weil die Leute, obwohl es schwierig war dafür zu entwickeln,
trotzdem gesehen haben, dass das so eine Plattform ist,
die sich einfach auch um die kleinen Details kümmert und wo Dinge auf einmal
einfach sind, die woanders unmöglich sind.
Gut, das mag heute jetzt nicht mehr so das Thema sein, aber es hat ja zehn Jahre gedauert,
nachdem es Windows gab, bis du sagen konntest, mein Windows kann problemlos
drucken oder mein Windows kann problemlos einen Ton abspielen.
Das sind ja so Dinge, die dann wirklich ein langer, langer, langer Prozess waren,
wo man sagen kann, das Thema ist jetzt auch durch.
Das war einfach lange Zeit nicht durch. Ich will jetzt nicht auf Windows rumhacken,
mir geht es nur darum, das sind so Sachen, die haben beim Mac einfach...
Super funktioniert von Anfang an in den 80ern.
Also du hast so ein Macintosh genommen und so ein Laserbreiter daneben gestanden
und du hast da ein Kabel reingesteckt und dann taucht der da im Chooser auf
und dann klickst du da drauf und dann sagst du drucken und dann kam die fucking
Seite raus und die sah auch genau so aus, wie du es haben wolltest.
Also okay, war jetzt kein Visivik, aber im Wesentlichen entsprach das schon
dem, was du da gesagt hast und das hat so lange gedauert auf allen anderen Plattformen
und Grüße auch an die Leasings-Community an dieser Stelle,
da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das mit dem Ton und mit dem Drucken und wie
heute schon so weit ist, aber jetzt könnt ihr euch in den Kommentaren wieder beschweren.
Egal, ich will hier nicht bashen, sondern mir geht es darum,
was sozusagen, ich bin ja CEO und als CEO stehe ich ja jetzt hier auch in der
Verantwortung und muss jetzt Maßnahmen beschreiten Und Maßnahme eins ist,
make Developers sozusagen wieder cool, wichtig,
gib ihnen auch das Gefühl, dass sie wichtig sind und da gehört natürlich auch
dazu, diese Developers-Konferenz wieder in eine Developers-Konferenz umzuwandeln
und nicht in so eine Marketing-Veranstaltung.
Moment, Moment da muss ich mal einen dissentigen.
Meinung zu Lass mir hier erstmal meine Thesen auf den Tisch legen was ich jetzt
alles ändern würde also das ist absolut wichtig die Keynote muss wieder eine Keynote sein,
Also on stage. Da müssen Menschen auf eine Bühne gehen und die können gerne
ihre vorproduzierten Videos einspielen in größerer Hülle und Fülle als sonst.
Aber da muss einfach mal jemand aus Fleisch und Blut stehen und in dem Steve
Jobs Theater, was sie ja quasi nie benutzen.
Es steht da rum und ist nur so ein hausinternes Kino.
Oder um ihre Entwickler anzuschreien. Aber man kriegt ja nie was mit von dieser Bühne.
Ich meine, was erlaube Apple? Ich meine, jetzt bauen sie sich das Scheiß, das sieht geil aus.
Und alles, was sie da machen, ist so, du darfst jetzt hier mal 10 Minuten einen neuen iPhone anfassen.
Sie haben zu viel Schiss, dass es nicht geil ist, wenn sie das machen.
Ja und das muss ich sagen, also das ist dann Feigheit vor dem Feind.
Also ich meine, das müssen sie schon bringen.
Dann generell, was halt wirklich ein Problem ist, gut, das probieren sie sicherlich,
aber so make native apps great again, also es muss wieder einen Selling Point geben für native Apps.
Dieser ganze Scheiß mit Elektron und Web und so weiter, schwere Programme,
die sich alle auch nicht mehr so in dieses Macintosh-Spiel mit einspielen,
das muss besser gemacht werden und ich vermisse einfach da den Push,
um zum Beispiel Entwickler dazu zu bringen.
Sprich, es ihnen auch leicht zu machen, nicht zu zwingen, sondern es leicht zu machen.
Warum gibt es denn diese iPhone-Apps nicht auch als iPad-Apps?
Und warum gibt es denn nicht alle iPad-Apps auch als Mac-Apps?
Also wenn das nicht ein Automatismus ist, obwohl es ja theoretisch möglich ist,
dann ist es wohl offensichtlich immer noch zu kompliziert.
Ja, auch da muss ich einhaken.
Na gut, kurz.
Sie sind auf dem Weg, der Weg ist aber länger als du denkst.
Man kann ein Fan von SwiftUI sein, man kann SwiftUI hassen, man kann SwiftUI
aber nicht vorwerfen, dass es nicht mindestens ein Großteil dessen,
was es versucht zu tun, auch hinkriegt,
nämlich tatsächlich das Programmieren von UIs deutlich zu vereinfachen.
Und vor allen Dingen auch das Programmieren von UIs, die auf allen Geräten funktionieren,
deutlich zu vereinfachen.
Wir sind immer noch nicht am Ende und meiner Meinung nach ist SwiftUI auch schlecht dokumentiert.
Also es ist immer wieder schwierig zu finden, was kann ich denn mit einem UI-Element machen,
weil sie im Prinzip da immer nur so die Klassenbeschrift-Description rausnudeln,
die irgendwann mal ein Programmierer da reingehackt hat, ohne mal einen richtigen
Katalog zu haben, hier das ist alles das, was sie tun kann.
Aber das ist der Punkt, es ist schlecht dokumentiert, es kann theoretisch irgendwas,
aber praktisch reicht es nicht und das muss halt ein Schwerpunkt sein.
Also das muss, meiner Meinung nach ist das mit fast das Wichtigste,
was man im Development-Bereich machen kann und dann natürlich halt irgendwie
Bugs killen, dass das einfach mal Priorität hat und dass die Leute in der Lage
sind, da was hinzubekommen.
Klar, weil du willst die Plattform sein. Du bist der King, wenn du die Plattform
bist und alle anderen spielen auf deiner Plattform.
Und dazu musst du aber auch eine geile Plattform sein, sonst gehen die Leute
woanders hin und stricken ihren Webkram.
Übrigens noch eine kleine Sache, die ich vorher noch anmerken musste.
Hast du mal ein aktuelles Windows benutzt?
Nein.
Was ist denn das aktuelle Windows?
Ein 11. Ja.
Microsoft hat ja jetzt mehr oder weniger allen Leuten den Teppich unter Windows
10 unter den Füßen weggezogen.
Und es ist ganz offensichtlich so, dass sie Windows 11, jetzt die Personal Edition,
quasi als Beta-Test verwenden.
Und du kriegst immer wieder ein instabiles Windows ausgeliefert.
Dazu kommen jede Menge Werbungsgedöns, dass sie da auch noch einbauen und andere
In-Jetification-Maßnahmen.
Also ich muss sagen, wenn sich Windows so weiterentwickelt, dann braucht Apple
nur auf der Stelle zu stehen und sie werden im Vergleich immer besser.
Aber das wollen wir nicht hoffen, dass sie das tun.
Ja, also Windows interessiert mich nicht, ganz ehrlich. So, jetzt noch.
Macht auch nichts, muss niemanden interessieren.
Jetzt bin ich gleich fertig mit meiner Antrittsrede in Bezug auf Produkte. Also Gaming.
Ja, skip, skip, skip.
Also ich glaube, das kriegst du nicht mehr in die Flasche bei Apple.
Also das wird irgendwie nix. Also das ist glaube ich einfach so eine Szene,
mit der kommt Apple einfach kulturell gar nicht klar.
Also das ist einfach diesen Gaming-Markt, da sehe ich einen großen Canyon zwischen
Apple als Firma und wie diese Szene funktioniert und wie dieser Gaming-Markt
funktioniert, aber das ist auch für Apple nicht so wichtig.
Naja, der Gaming-Markt hat im Moment auch große Probleme, das muss man ganz ehrlich sagen.
Die ganzen AAA-Studios hauen einen Flop nach dem anderen raus.
Die Indies tun, was sie können, aber knapsen auch am Geld rum.
Also momentan ist da irgendwie der Great Reset meiner Meinung nach kurz,
steht kurz bevor, weil zu viele Leute zu viel Geld auf einfache Art und Weise
verdienen wollen und damit ganz fürchterlich die Nase fallen.
Naja, auf jeden Fall mein Kommentar, Apple Gaming Produkt werden wir nicht sehen
und das ist wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut so. Wo,
sie definitiv was tun müssen, ist halt die Vision Pro.
Ja, da sind wir uns einig.
Du hast es ja schon selber gesagt, Screen Estate ist geil und das ist halt auch
wirklich so mein Erlebnis.
Ich habe ja nun mal dieses Teil so und für einen halben Preis kann ich sagen,
I get my money's worth. Also ich habe einfach da ein Produkt,
wo ich sagen würde, das ist zwar für 2000 Euro,
immer noch jetzt kein billiges Ding, aber ich akzeptiere es,
dass es halt so ein Beta-Produkt der Zukunft ist.
Aber es kann halt so ein paar Sachen, die kann halt sonst gar nichts und das ist schon geil.
Aber was halt super enttäuschend ist, und das geht auch wieder in diese Developer-Ecke,
Jetzt haben sie diese Version 2.0 rausgebracht, das Ding ist jetzt fast zwei Jahre alt.
Von Vision OS.
Von Vision OS, genau, also das
ganze Produkt und damit natürlich auch das Betriebssystem in Version 2.0.
Und es ist einfach arm, wie wenig Apps dort native sind.
Also ganz viele der Standard Apple Apps sowie Kalender und so weiter sind alle iPad-Apps.
Okay, gut, das ist ja auch zum Start her ein gutes Ding,
dass das so funktioniert, aber wenn Apple selber nicht in der Lage ist,
auf ihrer eigenen Plattform ihre Idee eines User-Interfaces auch auf ihre ganzen
Standard-Apps zu übertragen,
das stimmt mich so ein bisschen skeptisch.
Ich sage nicht, es geht nicht oder es ist nicht möglich.
Ich sehe nur, dass sie da zu wenig Energie reinstecken. Also ich denke,
sie stehen da sehr viel mehr in der Pflicht, überhaupt erstmal ein bisschen vorwegzulaufen.
Ich glaube, sie haben sich zu sehr darauf verlassen, dass das so ein Selbstläufer
wird in irgendeiner Form und dass sie über die Business-Apps genug Traktion bekommt.
Das kann ich nicht einschätzen, das kann durchaus sein, dass es in dem Bereich
durchaus auch Verkaufszahlen gibt für so Special Interest, aber so für den generischeren
Apple-User ist es schwierig.
Natürlich auch wegen des Preises, aber das ist ja auch klar.
Ich meine, das Ding hat einfach so viel Hightech am Start.
Das ist dann halt einfach teuer. Natürlich wird das billiger werden mit der Zeit.
Wollen wir mal schauen. Es gibt ja das Gerücht, dass jetzt relativ bald schon
eine zweite Version rauskommt, auch wenn, glaube ich, keiner so richtig erwartet,
dass das ein großer Sprung wird. Naja, egal.
Wir können das Apple-Kapitel jetzt auch, denke ich mal, abschließen,
aber sie müssen cooler werden, sie müssen besser mit Developern arbeiten und
sie müssen vor allem auch mal mehr Flexibilität zeigen.
Also ich meine, dass es kein MacBook gibt mit eSIM, ist einfach mittlerweile
jetzt einfach nur noch lächerlich.
Das ist nur noch ein Treppenwitz.
Ich verstehe es einfach nicht mehr und wenn sie jetzt nicht bald ihren C1 Prozessor
da reinschmeißen, dann will ich mit denen nicht mehr reden.
Also das ist so das Ding.
Also, ein Bereich, wo sie was tun können, ist etwas, womit ich jetzt mal angefangen habe.
Ich weiß, super late to the party, aber ich habe es ja nochmal gemacht und wir
reden ja hier über das Leben mit Technik im 21.
Jahrhundert. Ich habe mir ein Homekit-Gerät gekauft.
Oh.
Oder sagen wir mal Home Automation. Was denn?
Naja, first things first. Da ich jetzt in einer Wohnung wohne mit Zentralheizung,
habe ich das erste Mal die Option eines automatischen Thermostats.
Oh.
Und da der Winter anrollt, dachte ich mir, das könnte doch mal eine gute Investition sein.
Was hast du denn geschoppt?
Ich habe mir die Eve Thermo gewohnt.
Ja, davon habe ich auch fast ein Dutzend.
Nur zwei, aber ja.
Die sind ja relativ pricey, würde ich sagen. Für so einen Teil zahlt man offiziell 80 Euro.
Straßenpreis eher so 70 Euro gebraucht, natürlich billiger.
Ja, es gibt einmal im Jahr bei Eve irgendwie so ein...
Jetzt zum Beispiel gerade.
So ein Sale, da greife ich dann immer zu und lege mir ein paar auf Halde.
Gerade 25% Rabatt gibt es gerade, weil sie irgendwie 10 Jahre feiern.
Habe ich jetzt zufällig gesehen gerade.
Na, da muss ich gleich mal kippen.
Ja, und in dem Zuge musste ich mich dann überhaupt erstmal ein bisschen wieder
in diese Welt reindenken, von der ich bisher immer ein bisschen Abstand genommen
habe, weil ich einfach nichts zum Automatisieren hatte.
Und habe dann glücklicherweise für die relativ hohe Zahl von Heizkörpern,
die ich bestücken muss, damit das Ganze sinnvoll ist,
auf Ebay einen Schuss gemacht von so B-Ware, womit ich mir schon mal erklecklich viel Geld gespart habe.
Allerdings funktionierten dann erstmal von den Geräten 75% nicht.
Du hast ja mal einen Schnäppchen gemacht.
50 Prozent gespart und 75 Prozent kaputt.
Das ist natürlich super. Ja, sie waren nicht wirklich kaputt,
wie sich rausgestellt hat.
Der Händler war ein bisschen, naja, dachte erst irgendwie, wieder einer,
der nicht weiß, wie man Batterien einsetzt und so.
Aber tatsächlich war es so, dass bei der Hälfte der Geräte,
die ich da beanstandet habe, schlicht und ergreifend bereits ein Update stattgefunden
hat, dieser Geräte von der HomeKit-Software auf Meta,
auf das neue standardisierte Protokoll, was ja in gewisser Hinsicht so auf HomeKit-Basis
entstanden ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, und auch einfach besser ist.
Und wahrscheinlich auch einfach besser ist, weil neuer ist. Und in dem Moment,
wo du deine Eve Thermo-Geräte auf Meta geupdatet hast, dann haben sie halt einen anderen Code.
Das heißt, ich könnte tausendmal diesen QR-Code scannen. Kein Wunder,
dass die App sich nicht mit diesen Teilen verbunden hat.
Aber den Code hat hoffentlich der Verkäufer beigelegt.
Nee, hatte er nicht, weil er wusste auch nichts davon, dass diese Geräte auf Meta geupdatet waren.
Aber ich konnte tatsächlich einfach die Seriennummer an den EVE-Support schicken
und die haben mir dann die Meta-Code zugeschickt.
Oh, das ist erstaunlich.
Ja, mit anderen Worten, sie wissen also von jedem Gerät, ob es irgendwann mal
aktualisiert wurde. Das ist durchaus etwas, was Sie sich merken.
Also in dem Moment, wo die Software sagt, wir machen jetzt hier mal eine neue
Firmware drauf, registrieren Sie auch diese Seriennummer in Ihrer Datenbank.
Und ja.
Oder aber sie generieren die Metacodes aus der Seriennummer.
Das wäre natürlich bitter.
Ja, offensichtlich. Warum soll das bitter sein?
Weil dann jemand den Algorithmus reversen kann?
Theoretisch schon, aber...
Naja gut, ich meine, sagen wir mal so...
Also das weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht. Vielleicht haben sie den auch
einfach nur generiert und das hinterlegt in ihrer Datenbank.
Das könnte ich mir halt durchaus vorstellen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Auf jeden Fall sind sie in der Lage, wenn du dir diesen Code nicht gemerkt hast
und nicht den neuen Aufkleber drauf gemacht hast oder das sonst wie abgespeichert
hast, dann kannst du quasi das über den Support wieder erfragen.
Habe ich für sie getestet, funktioniert.
Die anderen Geräte waren dann tatsächlich wohl defekt.
Keine Ahnung, was damit ist. Die habe ich erstmal wieder zurückgeschickt und
ich kriege dann neue und dann wird hoffentlich auch alles funktionieren.
In dem Zuge habe ich mir dann andere HomeKit-Devices nochmal angeschaut,
nochmal so geguckt. so okay wie, also Home-Automation, die sich quasi mit Apple Home verbinden lassen.
Wir wissen, es gibt ja tausend andere Sachen, wie man das machen kann.
Man kann natürlich Home Assistant verwenden und da gibt es dann wiederum Treiber
und Integration für alles mögliche.
Aber ich habe hier auch so ein Home Assistant laufen und muss sagen,
meine Erfahrungen damit sind eigentlich eher so meh, weil User Interface ist so,
gut, das ist Apple Home auch, Aber ich habe das hier auf so einem Raspberry
Pi laufen und ich muss den aber irgendwie alle zwei Wochen rebooten,
damit ich da überhaupt irgendwie drauf kann, weil er sich irgendwie immer wieder
die Karten legt aus Gründen, die ich nicht verstehe.
Ja, und von daher habe ich mir so jetzt meine Strategie ausgelegt,
okay, was will ich denn jetzt eigentlich haben, insbesondere für meinen Endgegner, Licht.
Licht ist der Endgegner.
Ja, Licht ist für mich der Endgegner insofern, als dass ich ohnehin,
sagen wir mal, nicht besonders gut bin in Licht, also so Lichtgestaltung und Lichtentscheidungen.
Welche Lampen will ich denn jetzt eigentlich wo, wie haben, die dann wie geschaltet werden?
Wir starren zur Decke der Meta-Ebene, wo so eine richtige Klischee-Ikea-Ballonlampe von 1980 hängt.
Seit 16 Jahren.
Und es sieht auch so aus, als wäre da eine Glühbirne drin, oder?
Wie eine Glühbirne.
Mit Faden und so? Glühfaden? Nein. Nein, okay.
LED, mein Freund.
Ja, ja.
Und?
Naja, auf jeden Fall,
gibt es ja da verschiedenste Möglichkeiten. Wir haben ja hier auch schon mal welche besprochen.
Unter anderem diese Produktkategorie, man baut sich einfach was in seinen Lichtschalter ein.
Ja, die Shellys. Die Shellys und ähnliche. Es gibt ja noch ein paar andere Hersteller,
der Name mir jetzt wieder gerade nicht einfällt.
Yves hat auch einen, aber der ist einfach für das, was er kann,
viel zu teuer. davon würde ich abraten.
Komme ich gleich zu. Die Shelleys haben ein Problem, das sie nämlich jetzt sozusagen
meinem neuen Mindestkriterium nicht entsprechen. Sie machen zwar Meta.
Aber nicht Thread.
Obwohl sie es könnten. Die neuen Geräte sind angeblich ESP32 basiert,
der sehr wohl in der Lage wäre, diese Thread-Kommunikation zu machen.
Das steht da wohl in der Spezifikation.
Wenn er den richtigen Funkstandard mit dabei hat.
Das ist wohl der Fall. Sagen alle Foren, ich habe es selber nicht überprüft.
Tatsache ist, sie machen kein Thread und wenn man halt kein Thread,
also vielleicht nicht ganz folgen kann, Thread ist, also Meta ist quasi das
neue Protokoll, was funktioniert.
Ich vermute, sich an HomeKit im Design orientiert hat.
Ja, ist so ein Nachfolger von HomeKit.
Ja, so wie QuickTime zu MPEG-4 übergegangen ist.
Containerformat, ja.
Ja, so ist das mit HomeKit und Meta. Und während aber die Kommunikation der
Geräte vorher primär entweder über Bluetooth lief oder über WiFi,
was beides so seine Probleme hat, nämlich so Range und sich ändernde Konfigurationen
und WiFi generell schwierig.
Weil Und vor allen Dingen in so einem Point-to-Hub-Modell.
Genau, also auf jeden Fall gab es verschiedene Schwierigkeiten.
Will man eigentlich auch einen einheitlichen Funkstandard und den gibt es halt
auch und der heißt Thread, kein schöner Name, aber so ist es nun mal.
Und in die großen Apple-TV-Geräte, die man heute kaufen kann,
aber auch in alle HomePod-Minis sind zum Beispiel solche Thread-Router eingebaut.
Das heißt, wenn man auch nur eins dieser Devices rumstehen hat in der Wohnung,
ist es theoretisch denkbar, dass jedes irgendwo installierte Device eine Verbindung bekommt.
Zumindest, wenn man mehrere davon hat, dann reichen die das halt auch entsprechend weiter.
Es gibt eine kleine, etwas verkomplizierende Sache.
Alle Geräte, die dauerhaft am Strom hängen, sind auch Router.
Und Geräte, die nur eine Batterie haben, sind meistens nur Endgeräte, die ruten nicht.
Um Strom zu sparen. Was aber nicht so ein Ding ist, weil zum Beispiel diese
EVE Energy Zwischenstecker zum Beispiel, die hängen ja immer am Strom.
Die geben Router ab, dann diverse Leuchtmittel, wenn die immer am Strom hängen
und du die quasi nicht durch Strom ein- ausschalten schaltest,
sondern irgendwie anders und Farben und hast du nicht gesehen,
die sind dann auch Router.
Das Schöne ist, je mehr Routergeräte man halt hat, desto robuster wird das Netzwerk,
weil das halt so ein Mesh-Netzwerk bildet, das,
wirklich gut funktioniert, also muss ich sagen, ich hab das über drei Stockwerke
und das ist einfach, das funktioniert einfach,
auch der einzige Grund, warum ich einen HomePod Mini hab, sonst hätte ich so
einen Teil nicht weil der für mich halt Threadborder-Router ist wie man das so schön nennt.
Gut zu wissen, dass EVE-Energy das macht.
Kein Apple TV irgendwo rumzustehen, die machen das ja auch.
Doch, aber es ist nicht neu genug, um einen Thread-Border-Router machen zu können.
Dafür brauchst du nämlich die letzte Generation.
Aber das nur so am Rande.
Okay, EVE-Energy macht das auch, gut zu wissen. Ja, und jetzt liegt,
also die Shellys fallen halt für mich raus, weil kein Thread.
Und ich kaufe mir jetzt nicht was, was kein Thread macht und dann noch Zigbee und irgendwie,
irgendwelche Bridges und also ich will da nicht bridgen, ich will einfach so
Meta-Native unterwegs sein, deswegen kommen halt nur solche Sachen für mich in Frage.
Jetzt dieser Eve-Light-Switch, den es gibt, der hat halt den Charme,
dass er eben auch so für Doppelschaltungen geeignet ist und dann eben auch alles so mitbringt.
Doppelschaltung?
Ja, wenn du jetzt so eine,
zwei Schalter oder drei Schalter hast, die eine Lampe anmachen oder so,
das geht halt auch damit.
Ja. Im Prinzip ja, ist es dann schwierig zu verkabeln.
Das solltest du dir nochmal genau angucken.
Ja, es ist zumindest dokumentiert, wie man es dann verkabelt.
Alles da drin ist schlecht zu verkabeln.
Man braucht halt schon irgendwie eine Lichtinstallation mit Neutralleitern.
Das ist sozusagen dann die Voraussetzung, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Wie auch immer, der ist auf jeden Fall auch arschteuer.
Ich finde ihn für das, was er macht, finde ich ihn zu teuer.
Während ich die Rollladensteuerung...
Also 100 Euro, ne?
Ja, ja, 100 Euro für einen Lichtschalter finde ich schon ganz schön viel.
Finde ich auch ganz schön viel.
Wert wiederum die Rollladenschalter. Die sind wirklich genial und ich finde,
die sind ihre 100 Euro auch wert, weil die können etwas, das ist halt super genial.
Du kannst denen quasi über die EVE-App im Telefon und den Magnetkompass sagen,
das Fenster ist in dieser Richtung.
Westen, Osten, Süden und dann weiß er, wann kommt die Sonne ins Fenster und
wann geht die Sonne wieder aus dem Fenster raus und du kannst für den Sommer
programmieren, dass er automatisch beschattet.
Sprich, wenn die Sonne rumkommt, macht er den Rollladen runter und wenn die
Sonne vorbei ist, dann macht er den Rollladen wieder hoch. Das ist wirklich sehr genial.
Also gut, wenn man sagt, sowas brauche ich nicht, dann ist es natürlich trotzdem viel Geld.
Aber also ich habe jetzt von denen ein paar im Einsatz und ich muss sagen,
ich liebe sie, aber gut, das muss ja jeder selber wissen.
Tim, hast du von Shelly hier das Posting aus April, wo sie ihre Meta-kompatiblen Devices aufführen?
Das sind nicht so wenige. Guck mal.
Ja, Meta schon, aber nicht Thread.
Das ist das Ding. Also Meta machen sie jetzt alles und da dachte ich so,
aha, okay, interessant, aber leider machen sie halt nur Meta über Wi-Fi oder
über Bluetooth oder über Zigbee.
Und wenn du Glühbirnen, also Birnen, ja Leuchtmittel haben willst, die bunt machen.
Ich bin ja immer noch Fan von diesen Nanoleaf Essentials, die können nämlich
inzwischen auch Matter.
Die konnten schon von Anfang an Thread, aber die können jetzt auch Matter und
sind jetzt gar nicht so teuer. Ja, so ein Leuchtmittel.
Philips hat jetzt angekündigt, ich weiß nicht, ob es schon lieferbar ist,
auch Philips Hue Leuchtmittel mit Thread und Meta zu bringen.
Da gibt es auch eine Essentials-Serie, die wohl gar nicht so teuer ist.
Da muss man sich nochmal im Einzelnen angucken.
Wie gut es ist.
Essentials? Also was ist da so Essential?
Bei Nanoleaf? Keine Ahnung, das ist einfach ein Name.
Also Nanoleaf sind ja... Bei You machen sie jetzt auch Essentials.
Achso Essentials, die irgendwas sagen sie, dass die Farbgenauigkeit nicht so genau ist und so weiter.
Und ob das jetzt aber wirklich, ob man jetzt die teuren oder die günstigen kauft, das keine Ahnung.
Also Essentials ist sozusagen das Einsteigermodell.
Ja genau, Essentials ist das Einsteiger.
Ich dachte, das wäre was Tolles. Okay, also Nanoleaf ist eine Bude,
die so Glühbirnen macht.
Die… Na so Streamer-Leuchtmittel hinten an der Wand, damit sind die ursprünglich
mal eingestiegen, aber die machen halt jetzt auch diese Thread-Matter-Leuchtmittel,
die du einfach so in normale Fassung reinschraubst und hast bunt.
Ja, dazu bräuchte ich erstmal normale Fassungen.
Es gibt auch die für anormale Fassungen. Also diese komischen mit so zwei Nüppeln,
die man wie so ein Bayonettverschluss reinklingt.
Wie auch immer die heißen, ich kenne die nur aus Frankreich,
weil sie da viel verwendet werden.
Und im Außenbereich sind die, glaube ich, auch üblich.
Okay, die sind auch relativ günstig.
Eben, sie sind relativ günstig. Das kann man mal mitnehmen und rumprobieren mit.
Und hat nicht das Gefühl, das ist eine Investition, die sich bezahlt werden muss.
Wie gesagt, also Philips U hat jetzt auch welche angekündigt da habe ich allerdings
nicht gefunden bei Philips irgendwie deswegen,
nochmal der Tipp mit den Nanoleaf Dingern die ich, also ich habe,
als sie mit Meta angefangen haben habe ich noch eine größere Packung von den
nicht Meta fähigen, nur Thread fähigen HomeKit Dingern gekauft,
das heißt so schnell bin ich von HomeKit nicht weg,
aber ja Okay.
Jetzt habe ich mich hier gerade verlaufen aber okay, die machen noch was anderes
außer diesen Kram, ne, Smart Glühbirne Materie Threat,
Materie Threat Ja, ist die Kompatibilität hier Leider sind wir vorübergehend
nicht vorrätig, sagt mir die Glühbirne selber Okay, da muss ich noch mal ein bisschen schauen.
Was auch noch ein interessanter Player ist, ist die Firma Akara.
Akara, ja.
A-Q-A-R-A Punkt, äh, com.
Die haben interessante,
Und intelligente Türschlösser. Da sind sie fast so ein bisschen Marktführer,
aber die haben auch Heizungsventile.
Die haben auch Licht, die haben alles mögliche, Kameras, pipapo,
da kannst du auch irgendwie deine Gardinen mit auf und zu machen.
Ich wollte nochmal kurz auf die, worauf wollte ich zu sprechen kommen gerade?
Die haben also auch Light-Switches sozusagen, die relativ günstig sind.
Die sind auch sehr Standard und da ist glaube ich auch alles irgendwie Meta und Träte.
Da muss man mal gucken, ob was für einen dabei ist. Damit kann man sich unter
Umständen ein bisschen Geld sparen.
Bei den Türschlössern, die haben so ein Türschloss,
Türschloss habe ich mir auch angeschaut, ist eigentlich für mich wahrscheinlich
erstmal keine Option, finde ich aber trotzdem interessant das Thema,
vor allem wie die sozusagen die Autorisierung
letzten Endes oder die Authentifizierung letzten Endes regeln.
Während du jetzt bei Nuki, die so hardware-technisch derzeit so das schickste
Angebot haben, diese Nuki-Schlösser der neuen Generation, sind wirklich super
schnell und super schick.
Das sind nicht mehr so Riesenklötze, die du da ranhängst, fast schon so eine Türknaufgröße.
Müssen aber dann eben noch schon über die eigene App irgendwie immer wieder
freigeschaltet werden.
Während halt diese Acaras auch diese Homekey Funktionen unterstützen,
sodass du einfach außen nochmal so ein Pad hast,
Wo du dann mit der Uhr oder Telefon einfach so ein Key präsentieren kannst,
so wie du quasi in London U-Bahn fahren kannst.
Wobei man sagen kann, naja okay, wenn ich sowieso schon an dem Pad bin,
dann kann ich auch gleich Fingerabdrucksensor benutzen.
Dann ist es genauso.
Es sei denn, du trägst deinen Einkauf gerade ins Haus.
Oder du möchtest halt so ein Homekey jemand anders dispatchen.
Kannst deine Uhr gerade noch in Stellung bringen, aber die große Kiste,
die du in der Hand hast, halt nicht loslassen.
Genau, weil man solche Probleme hat. Also das sind echte First-World-Problems.
In meiner Home-Automation ist sowieso absolutes First-World-Problem-Gelände.
Aber ich wollte das einfach mal so meiner ersten Eindrücke auf meine Forschungsreise hier teilen.
Und ich finde Yves ist nach wie vor ein sehr interessanter Anbieter mit guter Qualität,
mit korrektem Support und mit hohen Preisen und Acara scheint deutlich günstiger
zu sein in manchen Bereichen,
ist teilweise featuremäßig vorne,
teilweise vielleicht auch nicht.
Ich habe mir jetzt nicht alles angeschaut, aber das ist so ein Bereich,
den ich mir in der nächsten Zeit näher anschauen werde.
Und Meta hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass es ein super Standard ist und sich
damit auch mit allem integrieren lässt.
Gut, dass wir da jetzt endlich mal einen Standard haben und von diesen Speziallösungen weg sind.
Der Standard hat noch so seine, sagen wir mal, Blindspots zum Beispiel,
kennen die Amerikaner ja keine Fenster, die man sowohl kippen als auch aufmachen kann.
Dementsprechend unterstützt halt auch Matter keine Fenster, die man kippen und
aufmachen kann und solche Sachen.
Nicht nur das, sie unterstützen auch keine Türen mit so einem...
Wie heißt denn das nochmal? Der Schnapper. Wie heißt der korrekte Begriff?
So ein Sommer? Hä?
Nein, der Schnapper. Den, den du am Schluss mit deinem Schlüssel aufschließt.
Ach so, quasi die Klinke, die du mit dem...
Die Falle. Die Falle, das ist der Name, den ich besucht habe. Die Falle, genau.
Und dass man die Falle auch nochmal so separat adressieren kann und nicht nur das Schloss.
Ja, ja.
Also in Amerika ist, wenn das Schloss offen ist, dann kannst du die Tür aufmachen.
Aber bei einer europäischen Tür hast du ja noch die Falle.
Den Schnapper.
Den Schnapper, die Falle. Und es gibt aber dann in Meta halt keine Möglichkeit,
irgendwie die Falle auch nochmal abzubilden und so, dass die dann sich öffnet.
Und deswegen musst du das jetzt mit verbinden mit, ja, wenn du das Schloss aufmachst,
dann zieh auch nochmal die Falle für 20 Sekunden auf und mach sie dann erst wieder zu und so.
Aber das müsste doch inzwischen ein gelöstes Problem sein.
Oder? Das ist kein gelöstes Problem, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass die Diskussionen heiß geführt werden.
Und da Yves da als europäischer Anbieter auch mit dem Spiel ist,
glaube ich, sind das alles nur vorübergehende Probleme.
Aber Yves hat noch keinen Türöffner im Programm.
Ich glaube nicht.
Naja.
Da gibt es dann Nuki. Nuki.
Ja, Nuki gibt es auch.
Alright. So wie zum Thema Home-Kram.
Also ich kann jetzt noch nicht viel Erfahrung teilen. Ich bin jetzt erstmal
in der Inbetriebnahme, aber ja, wir sehen weiter. Okay.
Ja, also ich habe, wie gesagt, ich habe einen von diesen Schaltern von Yves.
Ja, keine Ahnung, der schaltet halt. Also es gibt jetzt nicht viel zu sehen.
Dann wie gesagt diese Rollladendinger, die ich sehr schätze,
weil sie halt sowohl zeitgesteuert als auch sonnenstandgesteuert kannst du die
halt und du programmierst quasi das Ding selber,
das merkt das dann von alleine, da muss glaube ich die Bridge auch nicht laufen.
Dann habe ich jede Menge von diesen Eve Energy Zwischensteckern.
Da ist zum Beispiel meine Kaffeemaschine dran.
Da habe ich natürlich auch eine Uhrzeit programmiert, wo der dann vormittags
oder morgens das Ding anschaltet und nachmittags irgendwann,
wenn ich wirklich keinen Kaffee mehr trinken sollte, die Kaffeemaschine auch wieder ausschaltet.
Ja, so diverses Gedöns.
Die diese Eve Kamera habe ich auch irgendwann montiert die ist ganz spannend,
weil sie tatsächlich mit HomeKit diesen Kamerafeed macht auf das Telefon,
und aber man gleichzeitig, also ich habe gleichzeitig noch eine Automation gemacht,
dass wenn die Kamera ihr Licht anmacht, äh auch noch weiteres Licht angeht.
Weil dann macht man irgendwo so einen Zwischenstecker hin und sagt dann quasi
per Meta jetzt, wenn das angeht, dann mach mal den Zwischenstecker auch an und
wenn es wieder ausgeht, machst du den Zwischenstecker auch wieder aus.
Also solche Sachen, das funktioniert einigermaßen gut.
Okay.
Und ansonsten hatte ich noch irgendwas? Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Also was mir so ein bisschen bei HomeKit dann fehlt, aber das ist in der App,
ist halt so ein One-Time-Ding, wo du sagst, mach mal um zwölf die und die Aktion.
Das gibt es einfach nicht. Ich verstehe es nicht.
Ja.
Oder mach in fünf Minuten das Licht aus. Oder irgendwie sowas.
Das kriegt er nicht hin. Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Ja, ich hab da auch noch so meine Probleme, überhaupt so die richtigen Orte
zu finden, wo man so mit der Automation eigentlich anfangen soll.
Geht das vom Device aus?
Oder Szenen, Aktionen? Was triggert jetzt eigentlich was?
Mich überfordert das alles total. Ich hab eine sehr einfache Automation auf den auf meinen Rollos.
Die laufen aber gar nicht über HomeKit, weil die da schlicht nicht eingebunden sind.
Aber für die habe ich halt so wochentags andere Spielregeln als am Wochenende.
Und wenn ich im Urlaub bin, dann machen die auch noch so richtig random Kram und sowas.
Und das andere, was automatisiert ist, ist jetzt die Heizung,
dass es morgens in der Küche schön muckelig sind und die Jungs nicht amok laufen.
Das ist aber das Einzige. Alles andere Handbetrieb und das reicht aber auch,
finde ich. Also man muss es da nicht übertreiben.
Naja, bei den Heizkörperventilen habe ich natürlich für jeden Raum nach und
nach optimiert, dass das halt so
heizt, wie ich das haben will mit den Temperaturen, die ich so haben will.
Ansonsten bei den Rollos habe ich im Prinzip nur den Winterbetrieb.
Der ist halt nachts zu und tagsüber auf. und den Sommerbetrieb,
wo nachts offen und tagsüber, je nachdem halt Verschattung, damit es nicht zu heiß wird.
Gut, aber das war's dann.
Gut.
Tim, ich hatte noch was zur letzten Sendung.
Ja. Das weiß ich noch gar nicht. Du musst ja noch die letzte Sendung noch mal ein bisschen.
Und die vorletzte auch noch. Es gibt noch so viel zu tun. Du hast gesagt, wir hätten nix.
Ja, das war ja nur so dahin gesagt.
Jetzt hat die Sendung schon zwei Stunden, aber wir haben ja keine Themen.
Also, ihr habt letzte Sendung über E-Paper-Displays gesprochen.
Nämlich das Gadget, was du mitgebracht hast aus Schweden?
Ja.
Glaube ich.
Ich habe mir ein Tolino geschockt.
Und du hast dir ein Tolino geschockt. Genau, also sprich E-Ink-Displays, beides,
die ohne Stromzufuhr ihren jeweiligen Display-State halten können,
dadurch, dass so mikroskopisch kleine weiße und schwarze Kügelchen abgestoßen, angezogen werden.
Gedreht werden oder wie auch immer.
Gedreht werden, wie auch immer der Prozess ist. Und euer Votum war,
dass das doch alles total gut aussieht zum Lesen und der Kontrast vernünftig
ist und alles sei wunderbar.
Also ein bisschen muss ich das präzisieren.
Mein Votum war, dass schwarz-weiß E-Ink-Displays mehr Kontrast haben als Farb-E-Ink-Displays.
Das war mein Votum eigentlich. Und dass sie eigentlich zum Lesen ganz gut taugen.
Klar, man kann auch von einem iPad gut lesen, aber halt zu einem ganz anderen Gewicht.
Man kann vor allen Dingen von einem Buch gut lesen. Also was mich da jetzt so
doch als Bibliotheksmensch und jetzt nicht sonderlich bibliophil,
aber ich bin da ein bisschen ratlos bei solchen Statements.
Also E-Ink-Displays gibt es halt seit 20 Jahren.
Und gefühlt hat sich seit 20 Jahren überhaupt gar nichts verändert,
was dort Qualität angeht.
So, ich habe jetzt hier mal so das vor zwei Jahren Flaggschiff von Amazon hier
dabei. Das ist ein Oasis.
Das ist, glaube ich, so, das Display ist ein bisschen kaputt.
Darum muss ich mir demnächst auch ein neues vielleicht nochmal zulegen.
Aber das ist im Moment, glaube ich, noch State of the Art. Das ist ziemlich
dasselbe Display, was sie jetzt in dem aktuellen Paperwhite auch verbauen.
So, und was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist, bei diesem Kindle hier,
ist die Hintergrundbeleuchtung abzuschalten.
Das heißt, jetzt ist es wirklich nur das E-Ink-Display ohne irgendeinen Hintergrund.
So, und jetzt bin ich hochwissenschaftlich, wie ich sowas dann immer betreibe.
Ich habe ja in meinem früheren Leben mal ein Digitalisierungszentrum geleitet
und da viel mit Scans und Qualitätsstufen gearbeitet. Und jetzt habe ich also
mal professionell ein echtes Buch einfach daneben gelegt.
Ein professionelles Buch?
Ein professionelles Buch? Nein, nein, nein, das ist ein totales Profibuch.
Wir hatten es schon mal in der Sendung. Katrin Passig, Alex Scholz, Lexikon des Unwissens.
Immer wieder gute Leseempfehlung.
Katrin Passig ist fast durchaus eine gute Empfehlung, würde ich sagen.
So nämlich. Das ist jetzt überhaupt gar kein besonders toll gedrucktes Buch.
Das ist einfach ein Buch. Ja, so was glaube ich gut den Mainstream von Büchern
abdeckt. So und jetzt habe ich also mein.
Wie der Nerd sagt, doller Buch.
Doller Buch, genau. Jetzt habe ich also das E-Ink Display und das Buch nebeneinander
gelegt und einfach mal abfotografiert und habe mal Messungen vorgenommen.
Die möchte ich euch jetzt natürlich nicht vorenthalten. Das heißt also,
wenn man jetzt, du hast immer so abstrakte Werte wie irgendwie Kontrastverhältnis
und sonst was alles und ich bin immer ein Freund davon, sowas doch einfach mal
ein bisschen anschaulich zu machen.
Ich poste jetzt mal ein erstes Ergebnis dazu in den...
Chat und vielleicht, Tim, machst du das Bild mal groß, was ich da gemacht habe.
Also wir beschreiben, was ihr nicht sehen könnt.
Links das Buch, rechts das E-Ink-Display und macht ein bisschen größer,
dass man wirklich alles vielleicht gleichzeitig sieht, so ansatzweise zumindest.
Wie größer?
Wenn man alles sieht.
Dann muss ich es kleiner machen.
Ja, genau. Oder einfach das Fenster größer. Du hast ein großes Fenster.
Ja, das ist ja hier optimiert eigentlich.
Ach, gut. Ja, so ist doch fein.
Wir beschreiben, was wir sehen.
So, aber ich möchte die Balken gerne sehen, wenn schon die Höherinnen und Hörers nicht sehen können.
So, was habe ich jetzt gemacht? Ich habe jetzt gar nicht groß rumkalibriert.
Ich hätte jetzt auch einen Farbkeil dazu liegen können und sowas.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, auch noch irgendwo rumzuliegen.
Braucht das aber alles nicht, um den wesentlichen Punkt zu verdeutlichen.
So, die liegen jetzt also beide auf einem und demselben Bild nebeneinander.
Und ich habe jetzt einfach mal in einer ganz normalen Bildbearbeitungs-App,
in meinem Fall jetzt hier Affinity Photo, habe ich mal die HSL-Werte ausgelesen.
Verschiedene Farbräume, RGB kennen wir, CMYK kennen wir, vor allem für den Druck.
Und es gibt auch noch einen dritten, weniger bekannten Farbraum,
das ist HSL, wo du diesen Winkel im Farbspektrum hast.
Und L sagt dann halt den Grad der Helligkeit.
Die Lightness. View, Situation, Lightness, also die Farbe aufgebrochen nach
Farbton, Sättigung und Helligkeit.
Und das ist ein super einfaches Prinzip, um einfach zu gucken,
so wie hell ist jetzt irgendwas.
So, um die Farbe müssen wir uns ja gar keine Gedanken machen,
weil es ist im Wesentlichen ja alles Graustufen.
Du hättest es auch einfach in Graustufen umwandeln können.
Ja, ist ein bisschen, hätte man, aber so haben wir noch ein bisschen was gelernt nebenbei.
So und jetzt habe ich einfach die beiden, das hellste Weiß des Buches gemessen,
das tiefste Schwarz der Druckschwärze des Buches und dasselbe dann halt auf
dem Kindle gemacht. so und was für Werte haben wir jetzt da?
Dieser Leidniswert ist von 0 Pechschwarz bis 100 strahlend Weiß und dort kommt
also jetzt das analoge Buch auf ein maximales Weiß von 87,
fehlen also noch 13, aber ne und ein Schwarzwert von schon sehr sehr sehr guten
6, ja dafür dass es nur bis 0 runter geht.
250 Euro Kindle Oasis hingegen kommt auf einen Weißwert von 67,
also 20 schlechter als das Buch und 29 für das Schwarz, das heißt also das ist
kein Schwarz und das ist ein Grau.
So und sprich, wenn man jetzt die Kontraste nochmal sich irgendwie ausrechnet,
ja, so 87 minus 6 haben wir, also 81 Kontrast beim klassischen Buch,
wohingegen wir 67 minus 29 haben, 38, was nur der Kindle bietet.
So und da kann mir doch jetzt kein Mensch erzählen, dass das in 20 Jahren das
ist, wo man stehen will. Das ist doch scheiße.
Das war jetzt ein Plädoyer fürs Buch. Das Buch hat so seine Vorteile.
Ich bin jetzt traurig, dass ich das Godmeyer-Badge nicht dabei habe,
weil da ist definitiv das Weiß weißer als diese graue Melange,
die du hier präsentierst.
Hat das denn eine aktive Hintergrundbeleuchtung?
Nö.
Dann bringst du nächstes Mal gerne mal mit, dann können wir das nochmal nachmessen.
Der Tolino hat ja auch eine Hintergrundbeleuchtung und ich glaube,
die ist auch so ein bisschen Tageszeit abhängig, ob dann weißer oder gelber ist.
Die kann man aber natürlich auch ausschalten, beziehungsweise mehr oder weniger
Stufen, naja, wird nicht stufenlos sein, aber relativ feinstufig regeln.
Mein Argument war auch ein ganz anderes.
Lass mich den Punkt noch zu Ende machen, weil es kommt jetzt noch eine weitere Messung.
Ich habe jetzt also in einem nächsten Schritt mal die Hintergrundbeleuchtung
eingeschaltet und auf einen ziemlich hohen Werk gedreht.
Um quasi das Gerät so laufen zu lassen, wie es dann quasi verkauft wird.
Und meine Arbeitsthese war, dass es dann zwar heller wird, was das Papier angeht,
dass gleichzeitig aber auch das Schwarz der Schrift heller würde durch das Überstrahlen.
Und da stellt sich aber raus, dem ist nicht so.
Das Weiß wird heller von 67 auf 80, also schon relativ dicht dran an die 87,
die das Papier hier hatte.
Wohingegen sich zwar so der Farbstich quasi hier ändert, aber der Schwarzwert
in Anführungszeichen nur von 29 auf 30 nochmal hoch geht.
Das heißt, der bleibt im Wesentlichen bestehen. Das heißt also,
die Schrift bleibt gleichmäßig dunkelgrau, aber dadurch, dass das Papier signifikant heller wird,
bist du plötzlich dann doch dichter dran an dem, was ein echtes Buch liefert
hier an der Stelle. Das fand ich ein bisschen überraschend.
Das hätte ich gedacht, läuft anders.
Fun Fact am Rande, diese iBooks oder nur noch Books genannte App auf dem iPad
hat kein echtes Schwarz-Weiß.
Du kannst ja diverse irgendwie Dinger anwählen, aber die sind immer alle hellgrau,
dunkelgrau. Aber nichts davon ist schwarz-weiß.
Ich verstehe es nicht, wieso, aber gut, das muss Apple, vielleicht erklärt es Apple irgendwann mal.
Oder sie bauen es ein, dass man auch tatsächlich schwarz-weiß gucken kann.
Das wäre zu einfach.
Das wäre zu einfach. Nee, meine Argumentation war ja eine ganz andere.
Also dass ich bei normalen Büchern, die nur Text haben, die Vorteile eines sehr
leichten E-Book-Readers, also dieser Tolino, wie heißt der, 5 irgendwas, also der kleine,
der wiegt 190 Gramm oder so, ich hatte es gemessen.
Also auf jeden Fall weniger als das iPhone und ist mit 16 Megabyte integrierten
Speicher jetzt, 16 Gigabyte jetzt nicht super üppig, aber dafür sind ja auch
E-Books jetzt nicht riesig.
Also auf gut Deutsch, ich glaube eine Tonne Bücher kriegt man da schon unter. Also das ist so.
Also ich finde E-Books ja total super praktisch.
Also das war auch ein Kommentar in, ich glaube, zur letzten Sendung,
ob ich nicht mal was über die Onleihe erzähle und wie man von Bibliotheken dort Content draufkriegt.
Das können wir mal machen in einer der nächsten Sendungen, da brauche ich aber
in der Tat auch selber erstmal ein neues...
Gerät für, weil das auf dem Kindle natürlich alles so nicht vorgesehen ist.
Auf dem Tolino ist es vorgesehen, zumindest steht es in der Feature-Liste drin,
ich habe es nur nicht ausprobiert.
Ja, das werde ich dann mal tun und dann kann ich das ja auch nochmal präsentieren.
Aber es ging mir halt wirklich nur um dieses Statement, so ja,
Kontrast ist doch super.
Aber bring gerne mal das Batch mit, dann können wir das ja mit demselben hochwissenschaftlichen
Testverfahren mal durchmessen.
Also es würde mich jetzt wundern, ehrlich gesagt, wenn das Display besser wäre,
als das, was da in dem High-End-Modell von Amazon verbaut ist.
Weil so viele Hersteller gibt es jetzt auch nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt würde mich das nicht wundern, wenn Amazon an solchen Ecken und
Enden spart und lieber viel Geld nimmt, aber wenig dafür gibt.
Also so eine graue Soße ist das auf jeden Fall nicht. Das kann ich dir versprechen.
Alright, wollen wir weiter hüpfen?
So, ja. Dann können wir vielleicht mal zum,
zum Fediversum-Kram voranschreiten.
Weil du hast ja Keynotes gehalten, Ralf.
Eine davon habe ich gesehen. Nee, stimmt nicht. Ich habe fast zwei gesehen, sagen wir es mal so.
Naja, weil du warst ja auch im Stream zu sehen bei deiner Göttinger,
Jubiläumsveranstaltung, wo du so als Uropa des Projektes Gründer als Windsurf
wie hieß das Projekt noch gleich? Stutt.
IP vor 25 Jahren erfunden.
Gefeiert wurdest Veteran und dann warst du hier beim Faddy Day Berlin und da
hast du dann auch nochmal gerantet.
Also gerantet war es aber nicht, oder? Es war wohlmeinend geraten.
Vielleicht war es auch ein bisschen gerantet.
Schwere Empfehlungen.
Also ich hatte mit einem Rant gerechnet, aber es kam keiner.
Also ich wollte es dir jetzt ja eigentlich.
Die Möglichkeit geben, dann nochmal zu verschärfen.
Ja, genau. Also ich meine, es war ja sozusagen, du hast ja Kritik geübt.
Aber du hast dann erstmal auf die anderen getreten und dann erst auf die eigenen.
Erzähl doch mal, was du erzählt hast und ich mache dann noch mal ein paar Anmerkungen dazu.
Also was habe ich erzählt? Erstmal könnt ihr euch das Ganze auch noch angucken.
Es ist mittlerweile alles schön publiziert.
Ich werde das demnächst auch mal auf Peertube abwerfen, weil es irgendwie doch
ein bisschen skurril ist, wenn man irgendwie versucht, das Fediverse zu pushen
und dann alles selber nur auf GitHub irgendwie hat. Das ist ja irgendwie nicht true.
Daran arbeite ich noch. Ich habe jetzt irgendwie mir eine eigene Peertube-Instanz
hochgezogen. Mal gucken, wie sich das so alles anfühlt.
Mich hat das Thema umgetrieben halt, ich habe letztes Jahr einen Vortrag da
auch schon gehalten auf diesem Fedi Day in der Seabase.
Und da war so das Thema, wie wir es geschafft haben, die Bibliotheks-Community
auf Mastodon umzutopfen.
Mit irgendwie mittlerweile 1700 Accounts aller großen Bibliotheken,
aller kleinen Bibliotheken.
Die ganzen Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die irgendwie einigermaßen internetaffin sind.
Also keiner ist von denen mehr irgendwie auf X, sondern die haben wir so alle
auf unsere schöne Open Bibio Social Bibliotheksinstanz rumgeholt und das haben
Felix Ostrovski und ich letztes Jahr erzählt und dieses Jahr wollte ich jetzt
nicht schon wieder irgendwie dasselbe und Update und guckt mal,
wie toll die Instanz läuft, sondern ich wollte jetzt ein paar grundsätzlichere
Fragen irgendwie stellen.
Der Kerngedanke war halt, okay, was hindert eigentlich gerade daran,
Mastodon, aber auch das Fidiverse insgesamt eigentlich so richtig abzuheben
und nochmal so richtig Traktion zu kriegen.
Und meine These letztes Jahr war schon so, es liegt nicht an irgendwelchen fehlenden Features.
Also wenn irgendwie vor zwei Jahren die ganzen Journalistinnen gejammert haben,
auf gar keinen Fall können wir irgendwie mit Mastodon arbeiten,
weil es hat ja keine Quotes und ich kann so nicht arbeiten als Journalist.
So und jetzt gibt es bekanntlich Quotes und kein Giorno wird zurückkommen von
Blue Sky, weil jetzt irgendwie das Feature da ist. Also das kann man vergessen.
Sondern was wirkt, da wirken da eigentlich für andere Mechanismen,
die das irgendwie abhalten und dann mache ich so ein paar Thesen auf und eine These ist, dass,
So dieses Fediverse als Gedanke ja total cool ist mit diesem Grundversprechen,
guckt mal so die ganzen kommerziellen Plattformen, also Instagram und X und
Threads und Blue Sky und YouTube, die hassen sich halt alle gegenseitig.
Das heißt, deren Grundgedanke ist es, bleib bei uns, du brauchst die anderen
gar nicht, hier hast du alles, was du brauchst, geh bloß niemals weg und guck
mal da vorne noch irgendwie ein weißes Kaninchen.
Und sämtliche Mechanismen, wie diese Plattformen funktionieren,
sind darauf getrimmt, die User drin zu halten und outgoing Links werden bestraft
und kennen wir alles rauf und runter.
Und demgegenüber das Versprechen des Fediverse, guck mal,
hier haben wir jetzt ein Toolset von verschiedenen Plattformen,
Peertube für die Videos und Pixelfed als Instagram-Ersatz für die Bilder und
eben Mastodon und andere als Kurznachrichtendienst,
die lieben sich alle und spielen alle super zusammen.
Und das ist grundsätzlich eine super Erzählung, wenn sie dann irgendwie stimmen
würde und funktionieren würde. Und das ist halt irgendwie dann… Alles gelogen.
Sagst du.
Ich sage nicht, dass es alles gelogen ist, aber ich finde, wir sind jetzt irgendwie
in so einem Projektstadium, wenn man das mal so aus Projektmanagement-Sicht anguckt.
Es reicht halt jetzt nicht mehr, das zu behaupten, sondern man müsste es auch langsam mal zeigen.
Jenseits von, dass irgendwie Neulinge auf Mastodon halt angenült werden.
Ja, wir sind hier aber nicht auf Mastodon, das ist das Fiediverse hier.
Ja, ja, verstehe ich alles.
Ihr habt ja recht, aber was folgert denn da jetzt raus, außer,
ja gut, dann bist du halt noch irgendwie auf deiner Friendica-Instanz.
Also wo ist jetzt mal der Showcase, wo man sich angucken kann,
wie geil Peertube und Pixelfed und Mastodon und Friendica und was noch alles
da ist, zusammenspielen.
Wo das mal wirklich Sinn macht.
Und diese Showcases, die suche ich also einigermaßen verzweifelt.
Nur, dass es irgendwie über dasselbe Protokoll läuft und dass Outgoing Links
nicht bestraft werden, das ist mir an der Stelle jetzt nicht genug.
Ich hätte jetzt gerne mal ein Konzept und mal irgendwie so ein White Paper,
wo mal für so ein paar Bereiche ausdifferenziert wird.
So stellen wir uns dieses Zusammenspiel mal einfach vor.
Ein Beispiel, was ich dann da reingebe, ist so Konferenz, reden wir ja auch
ständig drüber, aber es brauchen Konferenzen, Events,
Meetups für eine Infrastruktur und
wie könnte man das durch verschiedene Fediverse-Dienste durchiterieren,
also sprich, die Sachen werden gestreamt und können nachträglich angeguckt werden
auf Peertube und eine Bilderdokumentation findet statt, dann eben auf Pixelfed
und vielleicht möchte ich noch irgendwo die Folien abwerfen,
dafür fehlt mir noch irgendwie ein guter Dienst, der sowas macht wie.
Wo werfe ich meine? SlideShare, genau.
Und das Community Management läuft dann eben über, das interne Community Management
läuft dann über irgendwie Friendicar und das Outreach nach draußen,
Kommunikation, passiert dann über Mastodon und hier habt ihr ein Framework,
was das alles zusammenhält und da shoppst du dir deine Konferenz und kriegst
die ganzen Sachen irgendwie cool zusammengebunden und alles über Hashtags.
Das wäre ja mal so eine Idee, sowas mal zu nehmen und damit spielen wir es mal
durch. So, müsste halt mal jemand machen, TM.
So, und stattdessen habe ich im Nachklapp auf meinem Talk dann nochmal ein bisschen
intensiver, wie ich gerade schon gesagt habe, auch so mit Peertube und sowas rumgespielt.
Und der Status Quo ist halt, ich bin jetzt also der Peertube-Instanz von Digital
Courage gefolgt und die haben jetzt ein neues Video publiziert auf ihrer Instanz.
Wie funktioniert irgendwie eigentlich das Fediverse? und das ist hier von Claudia
synchronisiert worden. Die kennen wir ja aus der Podcast-Szene hier.
Hier Claudia Diggenskirchen, Österreich,
die auch immer viel mit Wissenschaftskommunikation macht und so.
Und das war jetzt also dann in meinem Mastodon-Thread drin, also in meinem Mastodon-Kanal.
Und das habe ich dann geliked und das hat auch funktioniert. Wunderbar.
So, dann habe ich aber draufgeklickt auf den Link,
bin gelandet auf der Peertube-Instanz von Digital Courage, soweit alles gut
und dann wollte ich dort nochmal ein Like abgeben.
Und das geht dann aber nicht, weil du ja nicht auf dieser lokalen Instanz keinen
Account hast und registriert bist.
Mir ist völlig klar, warum das technologisch so ist, wie es ist,
aber so werden wir nicht gewinnen.
So, da muss man sich überlegen, was müssen wir für Brücken bauen,
für irgendwie Proxydienste, die man sich dazu shoppen kann, um dieses,
so, wenn wir Fediverse sagen, dann müssen wir es aber auch zeigen und meinen können.
Ja, dieses Thema der Authentifizierung, das muss man nochmal irgendwie anders
angehen, weil niemanden kann ich das vermitteln, dass ich zwar das auf Mastodon
liken konnte, dann gehe ich rüber,
ja in einen anderen Bereich, das Fidiverse will dieselbe Aktion machen,
dann wird mir gesagt, mich haben wir nicht angemeldet, jetzt musst du aber erstmal
wieder, ja ich war doch aber gerade eben vor ein paar Sekunden angemeldet,
mir ist klar, warum der Browser das nicht alles, ja aber da muss man halt vielleicht
eine Browser-Extension schreiben,
gibt es wohl auch schon Ansätze für, die das dann irgendwie durchführen,
findet halt fucking Lösung. Der Status Quo ist scheiße.
Oder man sagt halt, gut, FDW, es ist halt nur Protokoll, mehr wird da nicht passieren.
Aber wenn man sagt so, okay, wir wollen dieses neue Internet mal ausprobieren
und wir wollen das nochmal anders interpretieren, da muss man ja glaube ich
strategisch anderen Blick drauf haben.
Das war so ein Komplex, den ich mir angeguckt habe. Und das andere,
ein bisschen naheliegend, müssen wir jetzt vielleicht gar nicht so lange drauf
rumtreten, war dann halt so Design und UX und.
So Design Patterns, wo finde ich dann halt doch so immer diese,
wir kennen ja so die Entschittification von kommerziellen Diensten.
Ich rede jetzt immer ganz gerne von der Nerdification von Open Source Diensten,
dass halt zu wenig Designer und UXlerinnen drauf gucken und,
die letzten 40 Jahre UX-Forschung halt irgendwie ganz gerne ignoriert werden,
aber das könnt ihr euch dann in dem Video angucken, an was für Beispiel ich das da hochziehe.
Das ist dann schon ein bisschen provokant, vielleicht auch ein bisschen albern,
was ich da mache, aber ich glaube Aber in der Tat, es macht einen Unterschied,
ob ein User-Bild rund oder eckig sind.
Und wie sagen die Amis so schön, I will die on that hill.
Ja, die globale Werbung im Open-Source-Bereich ist Code, ist nicht UX.
Das merkt man an allen Ecken und Enden.
Ich meine, guckt dir ButterFS an, ein Filesystem und die kriegen es nicht mal
hin, eine Command-Line-Interface-UI, also UI so zu bauen, dass man das als normaler Mensch,
als normaler Nerd benutzen kann. Ich habe es nicht verstanden, warum.
Also ja ja.
Der Titel war, den sag ich vielleicht nochmal, weil der finde ich ist halt programmatisch,
Recht haben reicht nicht, wir müssen auch gewinnen so und das sehe ich wirklich
so, die Zeiten werden härter,
ja.
Recht hast du.
Und da muss man jetzt den einen oder anderen Tod, muss man da dann auch mal
sterben an der Stelle und so eine meiner,
Propaganda-Forderungen ist ich nehme kein Open-Source-Projekt mehr ernst,
was als vierte Person nicht, also was mit einem grafischen User-Interface daherkommt
und als vierte Person im Projekt sich nicht um eine Designerin, UXlerin kümmert.
So, das bringt einfach nichts. Wir müssen dort einen anderen Grad der Professionalisierung
angehen. Ansonsten werden wir nicht gewinnen.
Und Recht haben, das hilft einem dann nichts mehr, wenn man wenn immer nur die anderen gewinnen.
Ja
Ich habe dazu Gedanken entwickelt und war ja auch dabei.
Ein Slide hat mir ein bisschen übel aufgestoßen, weil er einfach falsch war.
Du hast da so die drei Oligarchen hingemalt.
Ja, ich weiß, der ist nicht mehr dabei.
Ja, der ist nicht nur nicht dabei, der ist da sogar dagegen und so.
Du hast halt Zuckerberg für Threads eingeblendet, natürlich Elon Musk für Twitter
und der ist dann auch gleich der Vogel.
Also den Blue Sky Gründer halt,
wie heißt da, ich kann erstmal die Folie nochmal in den Chat reingeben.
Dorsey, ist das nicht Dorsey?
Ja, Jack Dorsey.
Ja, und da dachte ich mir so, Ralf, also das ist jetzt, das kann jetzt nicht dein Standard sein.
Es ist immer noch Venture Capital, sie haben eine hohe Nähe zur Cryptocurrency-Szene.
Ich sehe wenig Anzeichen.
Okay, gut. Also, ich greife das mal auf.
Weil ehrlich gesagt, die Fediverse-Community ist halt sehr...
Und hat auch extrem dieses Not-Invented-Hier-Problem.
Und natürlich steht das, was derzeit da an Code und Protokollen draußen ist
mit dem Activity-Pub, das ist ja auch alles nicht brandneu. Das gibt es ja nun schon sehr lange.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wann ist Mastodon gestartet. Das ist mittlerweile
auch schon zehn Jahre her, glaube ich.
Und dieses System hat sich natürlich auch aus einer gewissen Denke heraus entwickelt
und zwar aus einer Community-Denke heraus. Und das ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch okay.
Die Domänen als Heimat ist etwas, was wir aus der E-Mail kennen.
Die Domänen als Heimat haben wir auch bei vielen anderen Systemen und viele
Open-Source-Lösungen heißen ja auch in der Regel immer, es ist empfohlen,
dass du dir das selber installierst und in deinem eigenen Garten anbaust.
Und damit man dann aber irgendwie mit der Welt kommunizieren kann,
dann wird das halt irgendwie föderiert und dann werden da so Protokolle rangeklatscht
und dann tauscht sich das schon irgendwie aus.
Und Jabba und viele dieser Systeme, die so über die Zeit entwickelt sind,
sind in diesem Geist irgendwie entstanden und das hat ja auch was für sich,
weil dann ist es halt auch irgendwie dein Teil, du erreichst deine Community und so weiter.
Jetzt ist allerdings...
Twitter etwas anderes gewesen und es ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch immer noch,
auch wenn es jetzt irgendwie anders heißt, sondern das ist ein System für die ganze Welt.
Es ist ein globales System, es ist keine Community.
Es ist ein System, was viele Communities beherbergt, aber alle Communities reden
mehr oder weniger auf derselben technischen Augenhöhe miteinander.
Jeder Account ist gleich zu jedem anderen Account und alle sind natürlich innerhalb
dieses Systems leicht zu erreichen.
Und deswegen hast du auch schon mal gleich diese erste Convenience,
dass diese Domain gar nicht mehr dabei ist.
Es ist halt einfach nur add Tim Britlove und das ist alles, was du wissen musst
und das kann man sich sogar merken und das kann man auf Visitenkarten schreiben.
Es ist einfach Handy und es ist etabliert und es ist irgendwie da.
Und das hat natürlich dazu beigetragen, dass sich hier auch eine ganz andere
Dynamik entwickelt hat und die kann man meiner Meinung nach eben mit Mastodon
nur sehr eingeschränkt nachbilden aus den von dir schon genannten Gründen.
Du hast einfach ein Usability-Problem durch diese Domain-Grenzen und das ist
auf jeden Fall schon Aber es ist nicht unbedingt das Hauptproblem.
Ein Hauptproblem, was ich aber tatsächlich sehe, ist, dass so sehr dieses Credo von ja.
Misstraue den Autoritäten da drin steckt, muss man allerdings seinem Administrator trauen.
Also wenn ich jetzt auf Mastodon was schreibe, dann schreibe ich das ja nicht
auf Mastodon, sondern ich schreibe es auf einem Mastodon-Server,
der von irgendwelchen Menschen administriert wird, die ich jetzt irgendwie nicht kenne.
Und dann muss ich denen halt vertrauen. Und es gibt ja auch immer wieder mal
Ärger mit so Instanzen, wo Leute ihre Accounts haben.
Ich sage nicht, dass die jetzt alle böse sind, aber man kann ja mal anderer
Meinung sein und sich über die Regeln nicht ganz so einig werden.
Und vor allem kann diese Instanzen halt auch schnell wieder verschwinden.
Da kommt dann immer dieses Argument so, ja, hoste doch selbst.
Oder zieh um.
Oder zieh um. Das Problem, bleiben wir erstmal bei dem hoste doch selbst.
Huste doch selbst. Das ist wirklich ein Scheiß-Argument. Das darf man einfach
in dieser ganzen Debatte nicht bringen.
Das ist wie Bau dein eigenes Auto.
Das ist einfach das moderne Fuck you. Ja genau. Nimm die gesamte Komplexität
jetzt, die wir hier geschaffen haben, auf dich. Du bist jetzt Systemadministrator.
Ja, aber ich verstehe das ja alles nicht.
Ja, dann geh doch zu irgendeinem Hoster. Ja toll, dann geh ich jetzt zu so einem
Hoster, um mein eigenes Mastodon System zu hosten, nur mit dem Ziel,
der einzige User auf diesem System zu sein, um quasi Herr über meine eigenen Daten zu sein.
Und das ist eigentlich nicht geil, weil selbst wenn du das machst,
hast du dann gleich wieder das Problem, dass du eigentlich von allem anderen
abgeschnitten bist, weil du kannst ja nicht irgendwie global suchen und irgendwie
Hashtags folgen, sondern du kriegst halt immer nur so einen kleinen Ausriss,
wo du irgendwie folgst und es ist einfach sehr schwierig, eine globale Debatte zu verfolgen.
Aber das Hauptproblem ist halt eigentlich, dass du die Daten immer noch woanders hingibst.
Und das ist etwas, was einfach meiner Meinung nach generell fehlt in diesem Fediverse.
Das Fediverse ist nämlich nur eine Föderation von Communities,
aber nicht eine Föderation von Menschen.
Und ich habe mir in dem Zuge auch noch mal so ein bisschen den Stand der Dinge
bei Blue Sky angeschaut.
Ich hatte das ja auch schon mal hier thematisiert und mal so geguckt,
was die eigentlich machen.
Weil ich habe mir auch in den letzten Monaten immer mal wieder Interviews mit
dieser Jay Graber angeschaut und ich muss sagen.
Ich finde da nichts, was die sagt, wo ich sagen muss, das ist irgendwie falsch.
Die denkt sehr klar. Und um diese ganzen Verquickungen mit diesem Jack Dorsey
vielleicht nochmal zu verstehen.
Also Jack Dorsey ist ja einer von diesen Twitter-Gründern und Betreibern und
hat dann eben irgendwann mal,
als die Drogen entweder gewirkt haben oder aufgehört haben zu wirken,
ich weiß nicht so ganz genau in welchem der beiden Zustände er auf solche Ideen kommt,
hat er ja mal darüber fabuliert, dass ja Twitter eigentlich ein offenes Protokoll
sein sollte und dass Twitter ja irgendwie föderiert sein sollte und dass es
irgendwie kein Closed-Shop sein sollte.
Ich weiß nicht, das haben ihn nicht seine Investoren eingeredet,
da hat glaube ich einfach der Nerd in ihm gesprochen, das ist zumindest meine Interpretation davon.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er diese Aussage auch wiederholen würde, mittlerweile ist
er halt nicht mehr so ein Fan von diesem Projekt.
Aber er hat eine Forschungsgruppe gestartet, die mal so über so ein Protokoll mal nachdenken sollte.
Und das hat diese Jay Graber geleitet.
Und die hat es dann aber auch geschafft, von vornherein das Projekt so aufzuhängen,
dass es eben nicht Teil von Twitter ist, sondern unabhängig betrieben wird.
Was den großen Vorteil hatte, dass zu dem Zeitpunkt, als Twitter dann verkauft
wurde, dieses Projekt nicht Teil dieser Verhandlungsmasse war,
sondern einfach weiter vor sich hin existiert hat.
Und mit Laverle ist das eine PBLLC, also das ist jetzt nicht das,
was wir unter eingetragener Verein oder gemeinnütziger Verein verstehen,
aber das ist, sagen wir mal so das, was im amerikanischen Rechtsraum,
glaube ich, dem noch am allernächsten kommt.
Also das ist eine Public, was heißt das nochmal genau,
Public.
Blablabla, hilft mir doch mal einer. Public Benefit Limited Liability Company.
Public Benefit kann man ja als gemeinnützig übersetzen. Obwohl es wahrscheinlich
eine andere Bedeutung hat.
Ja, I'm not a lawyer. Aber es ist nicht dasselbe, aber es ist das,
was dem vielleicht noch so ein bisschen am nächsten kommt.
Anyway, das ist auf jeden Fall die Rechtsform, unter dem dieses Projekt geraten
ist. Trotzdem haben sie Investoren, das heißt, da wird Geld zugespügt und das stimmt auch.
Da kommt es halt irgendwie auch von Kryptobros und weiß der Geier,
wer da noch alles Kohle eingeworfen hat und das ist auch nicht besonders überraschend,
weil die schmeißen halt auf alles, was irgendwie Kommunikation hat,
irgendwie Geld, weil die wollen überall dabei sein.
Also Hauptinvestor ist halt eine Bude namens Blockchain-Capital.
Ja, es ist, ja. Oh Gott. Also weder weiß ich genau, wie da die Deals sind, ja,
noch weiß ich, ob die real irgendeinen Einfluss haben, so, aber das sind jetzt
nicht die Besitzer irgendwie davon, ne, und ja.
Davon mal ganz abgesehen, wollte ich einfach nur noch mal das Augenmerk darauf
richten, was da jetzt eigentlich existiert und inwiefern die Atmosphäre versus
Fediverse sich sozusagen verhält.
Und das ist schon wirklich interessant. Also du hast halt als Basis dieses Systems
dieses AT-Protokoll und dieses
AT-Protokoll definiert eben so verschiedene Entitäten in diesem Netzwerk.
Vor allem hast du dann erstmal die Orte, wo die Daten der User gespeichert sind.
Das sind die sogenannten Personal Data Storage, PDS-Systeme.
Und diese PDS-Systeme sind zum Beispiel auch so gemacht, dass da eben auch einfach
nur ein User drin sein kann.
Kann es auch viele haben, wie Blue Sky. Blue Sky betreibt quasi PDS für dich,
damit du das nicht tun musst.
Aber du kannst halt den Blue Sky PDS Code nehmen und irgendwie selber fahren
und dann hast du deine Daten wirklich dort.
Host du doch selber.
Host du doch selber. Aber du hostest jetzt nicht so einen kompletten Web-Server
mit irgendwie User-Accounts und Web-Interface und so weiter,
sondern das ist wirklich nur ein kleines, tiny,
Data-Teil, was einfach nur Protokoll
spricht und deine Authentifizierung macht. So dein eigener OAuth.
Und wenn du jetzt so einen Client benutzt in diesem Atmosphere Netzwerk,
dann postest du zu diesem PDS.
Da schreibst du quasi deine Daten rein und dann kündet dieses PDS der Welt mit,
indem es dann eine andere Entität weitergibt, nämlich dieses Relay.
Das ist so diese Firehose, wo irgendwie so alle Daten zusammengetragen werden.
Das ist auch, sagen wir mal, der teuerste Teil der Zeit in dem System.
Um den zu betreiben, weil natürlich da alle wie blöde irgendwie Daten reinwerfen.
Das Blue Sky System hat derzeit knapp 40 Millionen User last time ercheckt und
dementsprechend ist da halt eine Menge los.
Wie bei der Twitter-Firehouse, das war halt auch einfach schon so ein Datenstrom
ist da wahrscheinlich schon gar nicht mehr der richtige Ausdruck,
sondern da geht richtig was ab und das ist teuer.
Und selbstverständlich kann nicht jeder so ein Relay betreiben,
mal so eben, so ohne weiteres.
Aber muss man ja auch erstmal nicht, weil dieser Relay ist halt für alle offen.
Auch wenn er quasi derzeit von der Kohle von Blue Sky bezahlt wird.
Und es auch wirklich nur einen einzigen gibt bisher.
Genau. Aber,
Es weitere geben könnte, also das Protokoll, du kannst heute schon einen aufmachen
und es gibt auch glaube ich irgendwie so testweise welche, aber jetzt nicht
wirklich, dass welche seriös betrieben werden,
aber wenn du einen zweiten aufmachst, dann könnten die PDS-Seite genauso bedienen.
Also es ist halt überhaupt nicht an Blue Sky gebunden.
Dann gibt es halt so Systeme, die nennen sich App Views. Das ist sozusagen das,
was halt aus diesem Relay-Daten rauszieht und auch cached, um sie dann an Clients weiterzuleiten.
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt den Blue Sky Client hast, dann benutzt du quasi den
Blue Sky App View, der holt sich diese Daten aus diesem Relay raus,
cacht die zwischen und verteilt die eben an die eigene App.
Und wenn du jetzt ein anderes System aufmachen möchtest auf Basis dieser Technologie,
dann kannst du dich halt überlegen, ob du dich einfach in denselben Relay hängst
oder ob du vielleicht sogar einen eigenen Relay aufmachst.
Auf jeden Fall kannst du auch PDS anbieten, aber du kannst auch die existierenden
PDS, auch die von BlueSky benutzen.
Am Ende stellst du primär in einem weiteren App-View deiner Applikationswelt
sozusagen deine Art und Weise, von wem du diese Daten präsentieren möchtest, bereit.
Das ist jetzt mal im Big Picture sozusagen das, was Atmosphere derzeit so darstellt.
Aber wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, hast du dann dort auch wieder
dieses, ich sag mal, E-Mail-Adressen-like-Problem,
dass du halt nicht einen Ad-Namen hast, sondern dass du eine komplette Domain
nach dem Ad noch hast, oder?
Nein, weil, also jein,
derzeit hast du einen Ad-Namen.
Namen, der wenn du nicht sagst, wie der sein soll, dann vergibt den quasi deinen PDS-Hoster.
Also wenn du jetzt dir derzeit einen AdRoddy auf BlueSky machst,
dann heißt der AdRoddy.Besky.App, weil die den so nennen, aber du kannst,
wenn du irgendeine Roddy-Winkenschürfel,
Domain hast, dann kannst du den halt auch addwinkenschöffel.de nennen.
Also du kannst quasi in deiner Domain einen Namen eintragen.
Dann machst du nur so einen Eintrag, so einen DNS-Eintrag, so einen TXT-Rekord und dann hast du es.
Und deswegen heiße ich auf bluesky addtim.britlauf.org und addmetaebene.me.
Achso, das ist dann nur addDNS-Name.
Genau.
Andere Namensauflösungen sind durchaus vorstellbar, komme ich gleich zu.
Jetzt nochmal kurz im Vergleich zum Fidiverse. Das finde ich ist schon mal ein
echtes Pfund. Diese Sache mit dem PDS.
Personal Data Storage. Du speicherst deine Daten selber und du kannst beliebig
zwischen den Diensten hin und her ziehen, wenn es beliebige Dienste gibt.
Aber dann kopierst du auch die Daten mit rum.
Nein, sie bleiben einfach in deinem PDS.
Ah, okay. Also der eigentliche Storage ist getrennt von dem Rest von dem Gedöns.
Richtig, das ist ein eigenes System, ist ein Personal Data Storage.
Und das ist etwas, was es in diesem Fediverse konzeptionell einfach überhaupt nicht gibt.
Und das finde ich in gewisser Hinsicht lustig, also lustig ist ein bisschen irre,
weil ja nun mal dieses Fediverse in der Regel eigentlich von Leuten propagiert
wird, die halt einfach immer so total mit ja, meine Daten müssen ja geschützt
werden, ich muss sie ja selber speichern.
Davon ist da aber nichts so, sondern man gibt das an den Mailbox-Betreiber sozusagen ab.
Das ist so ein bisschen so diese Mailbox-Denke aus den 80er Jahren,
das Fertiverse derzeit so im Design drin hat.
Jetzt gibt es noch zwei, drei andere Sachen, die muss ich auch nochmal erwähnen,
weil ich die auch sehr wichtig finde, weil das etwas ist, was es halt so in
dem Fediverse halt auch nicht gibt.
Es gibt halt innerhalb des Atmosphere-Systems gibt es diese Labeler-Funktion.
Also es ist sozusagen innerhalb dieser Protokollwelt ist vorgesehen eine Möglichkeit,
sich einzuklinken als Labeler.
Labeler bedeutet nichts anderes, du reviewst Post und fügst in ein Label hinzu.
Und ich kann dann wählen einen oder mehrere Labeler, die ich beziehen möchte,
die ich nutzen möchte und da gibt es ganz, ganz, ganz viele zur Auswahl,
wo du sagen kannst, ja, ich möchte gerne, dass die hier nach LGTBQ kompatiblen
Content labeln und hier möchte ich gerne einen Spam- und Scam-Labeler haben
und hier möchte ich einen Cool-Stuff-Labeler haben Und ob die Systeme manuell
betrieben sind oder automatisiert sind oder mit AI laufen, völlig egal.
Es gibt aber innerhalb dieser Protokollwelt einfach dieses Prinzip,
dass es Dienste gibt, die du freiwillig annehmen kannst und auch wieder abschalten
kannst und auch mehrere auf einmal.
Du musst dich nicht auf einen festlegen, die sozusagen für dich labeln sollen
und der Datenstrom, der dich erreicht, ist dann sozusagen vorgelabelt.
Du weißt einfach so, ah, da steht dran, ist gefährlich, ist böse,
haben andere für mich auf Basis welcher Technologie auch immer gemacht und damit
kann ich was anfangen oder damit kann ich nichts anfangen, dann wechsle ich
meinen Labeler oder ich benutze vielleicht auch gar keinen Labeler.
Aber es gibt diese Möglichkeit zu labeln und das ist etwas, was halt schon mal
diese ganze Problematik von...
Reviewing von Content und Warnings und so weiter mit abdeckt und damit natürlich
auch zu einer gewissen Sicherheit beiträgt.
Sicherlich nicht perfekt und es gibt auch viele Labeler, die auch schon wieder
die Arbeit eingestellt haben, weil das irgendwie alles nicht funktioniert hat.
Da stecke ich jetzt auch nicht zu sehr drin, aber man kann auf blueskylabelers.io
kann man sich zum Beispiel eine riesige Liste anschauen, was es da alles für Labelers gibt.
Ich schmasse das mal gleich in den Slack mit rein.
Ähm,
So. Und außerdem, und das finde ich auch sehr schön, gibt es halt dieses Prinzip von Feeds.
Und das kann auch jeder machen. Also ich kann auch selber beschließen, so Feeds anzubieten.
Viele tun das schon heute. Das heißt, es gibt einfach irgendwelche Leute,
die sagen, ja okay, ich stelle selber Content zusammen.
Ich muss jetzt gar nicht allen möglichen folgen, sondern ich folge einfach dem
ersten FC Union Fans Feed und dann gibt es halt jemanden, der diesen Feed für
mich bestückt und ich kann in meinem Client sagen,
so jetzt will ich ja auch nur diesen Feed lesen. Alles andere interessiert mich jetzt gerade nicht.
Ich will jetzt einfach mal nur Content, der aus diesem Feed kommt und ich bestimme
aber selber, welchen Feeds ich folge.
Das ist so quasi so handgemachter Algorithmus und das ist etwas,
was ich extrem cool finde, weil ich ganz oft das Problem habe,
dass mir einfach zu viel gleichzeitig kommt.
Manchmal will ich mich einfach nur auf ein Thema konzentrieren und dann kann
ich einfach zwischen diesen Feeds hin und her schalten und dann habe ich das.
Und das ist auch etwas, was in diesem Protokoll mit drin ist.
Und das sind meiner Meinung nach so die wirklich netten Sachen.
Jetzt gibt es natürlich diese ganze Diskussion mit okay, wie zentralisiert ist
denn das und inwiefern ist man denn jetzt von Blue Sky abhängig und so weiter.
Jake Raver sagt ja selber, sie wäre Billionaire Proof mit ihrer Technologie.
Da ist auch sicherlich was dran, weil eben dieses Protokoll ist schon so designt,
dass man im Prinzip jederzeit die Userbase, die da ist, einfach so übernehmen kann.
Du bist halt in dieser Atmosphäre drin und BlueSky ist jetzt einfach nur ein
Client, der halt irgendwie sowohl Personal Data Storage anbietet,
als eben auch diesen AppView macht.
Also gut, sie betreiben auch noch diesen Relay, da komme ich gleich nochmal
zu. Aber das ist so das Ding.
Es gibt jetzt allerdings tatsächlich ähm.
Die Bestrebungen, dieses Protokoll weiterhin zu standardisieren.
Also die Kernsachen, also das, was das Relay betrifft und was den Personal Data
Storage betrifft, also ich würde mal sagen, die beiden wichtigsten Komponenten,
der wichtigste Teil des Protokolls, das ist jetzt eine IETF Working Group,
also es ist jetzt vorgeschlagen worden, eine IETF Working Group einzurichten.
Die gibt es jetzt noch nicht, aber das ist jetzt sozusagen der Prozess,
der jetzt gestartet wurde.
Das ist also sehr gut denkbar, dass dieses Protokoll diesen Weg nimmt,
auch wenn wir jetzt noch nicht so weit sind.
Und was noch ein kritischer Punkt ist, ist der sogenannte DID-PLC.
Und das ist, sagen wir mal, die einzige wirkliche knifflige,
derzeit zentrale Geschichte, nämlich diese Auflösung der Ad-Namen.
Weil das ist ja quasi nicht Blue Sky, sondern wie auch immer der ist,
irgendwo muss ja diese Auflösung, welcher Personal Data Storage gehört zu diesem Ad-Namen,
das muss ja irgendwo stattfinden.
Und das ist halt so eine Digital Identity, DID, so nach Internetstandard und
dafür gibt es eben so einen Public Ledger Controller, heißt das glaube ich PLC.
Also das ist sozusagen das eine zentrale System, was diese Auflösung macht.
Und es gibt derzeit noch kein Proposal, wie man das dezentralisiert.
Das heißt nicht, dass das nicht möglich wäre, das zu dezentralisieren,
aber es ist derzeit technisch glaube ich nicht möglich.
Unmittelbar auf der Agenda, also vielleicht denken da Leute drüber nach, das weiß ich nicht.
Was allerdings Blue Sky jetzt angekündigt hat, weil natürlich betreiben sie
diesen Dienst derzeit auch, aber den wollen sie jetzt in die Schweiz abgeben.
Also sie möchten gerne eine Organisation gründen in der Schweiz und dort Die haben da.
Ja keine Milliardäre.
Nee, das sind alles nur Millionäre.
Immer sehr neutral, die Schweiz.
Nicht links und nicht rechts, sondern vorne, oder? War da mal was?
Ja, aber wenn das sowieso schon so halb an DNS hängt, dann kann man natürlich
das eigentlich auch ganz an DNS.
DNS ist eine Möglichkeit, das zu machen. Du kannst diese D-IDs auch direkt angeben,
also jetzt nicht unbedingt im Client, aber so auf Protokoll-Ebene letztlich
geht es da drum, diese die ID anzugeben und es gibt aber einen Auflösungsdienst über diese Ad-Namen.
Und das kann halt eine Domain sein oder beziehungsweise über diese Domain findest du derzeit, wo es ist.
Deswegen heißen halt die ganzen Blue Sky Accounts halt die Sky App,
weil das ist dann sozusagen die Domain, die definiert, wie das dann aufgelöst wird.
Klar, nur man könnte es insofern dezentralisieren, als dass man das dann quasi
an DNS abgibt, das ganze Problem.
Ja, aber das ist natürlich the nerd way. Also du willst schon irgendwie auch
andere Möglichkeiten haben, da eine Registrierung zu machen.
Also ich kann da nicht sehr viel zu sagen. Ich habe das jetzt nicht komplett durchdacht.
Ich wollte einfach nur mal kurz berichten, was da so der Stand der Dinge ist.
Und der Stand der Dinge ist der, um Amerika rauszunehmen, weil die wahrscheinlich
auch schon verstanden haben, dass das ein Problem ist, soll das jetzt erstmal
in die Schweiz marschieren.
Was ich jetzt nicht als die Lösung aller Probleme sehe, aber das ist definitiv
erstmal ein nachvollziehbarer.
Ja, es verlangsamt zumindest die Übernahme, wenn irgendjemand das versuchen sollte.
Ja, genau.
So, noch zwei, drei Anmerkungen.
So ein PDS selber zu betreiben, ist jetzt vielleicht auch nicht jedermanns Sache,
aber es ist zumindest nichts, was besonders hohe Anforderungen hat.
Also sozusagen so etwas zu hosten, ist jetzt nicht vergleichbar mit einem Massenkurs,
so einen Server, weil das Ding halt nur Protokoll spricht.
Also mittlerweile hat es auch ein Web-Interface, muss man dazu sagen,
das ist jetzt jüngst dazugekommen.
Du kriegst so ein generisches OAuth-Login-System sozusagen da drin,
dass du dich eben darüber identifizieren kannst.
Und das ist eigentlich auch ganz cool, weil da sieht man mal sehr schön,
dass das sozusagen auch unabhängig von Blue Sky ist.
Also sie haben das extra jetzt sozusagen in so einem neutralen Design gemacht,
weil der PDS ist erstmal nur ein PDS in diesem Atmosphäresystem und gehört erstmal
zu überhaupt niemanden außer zu sich selber und du machst deine Authentifizierung darüber.
Das heißt immer, wenn du dich in einem Ad-Protokoll basierten Dienst anmeldest,
meldest du dich an deinem eigenen PDS an.
Ah, okay.
Und der authentifiziert das und sagt, ja, das ist auch der, der hat hier Passwort,
irgendwie Two-Factor-Authentication, was auch immer, Parsky,
der ist das jetzt und dann bist du diesem Dienst gegenüber bekannt.
Jetzt gibt es nicht so viele Dienste in dem Atmosphärland, aber es gibt welche,
die vielleicht mal ganz erwähnenswert sind.
Also abgesehen natürlich von Blue Sky jetzt selber gibt es zum Beispiel White Wind.
Whitewind ist so kleine Beispiele.
Das sind jetzt keine großen fetten Teile, aber da kann man mal ausprobieren,
wenn man jetzt einen Blue Sky Account hat, kann man sich da einfach mal anmelden
und mit rumspielen und dann sieht man auch, wie dieser Anmeldevorgang geht.
Also Whitewind ist so eine kleine Blogging-Plattform. Da kann man dann sozusagen
mit dem eigenen Account sich anmelden und dann darüber was posten.
Was habe ich noch gefunden? Dann gibt es noch sowas, das heißt Frontpage.
Frontpage ist kein Technomagazin.
Frontpage ist, glaube ich, so eine Art,
Slashdot-Versuch. So ein kleines Experiment.
Also mit so News-Upvoting und so weiter, um irgendwie rauszufinden,
was irgendwie ist und das dann irgendwie zu kommentieren.
Und das dritte, was mir noch aufgefallen ist, ist ein System, das heißt Smoke Signal.
Das ist so quasi für Upcoming Org so ein Ersatz, wo man so Events posten kann.
Es ist jetzt alles nicht sonderlich refined, aber ich fand den Blogbeitrag von
dem Menschen, der das aufgesetzt hat und warum er das gemacht hat,
ganz insightvoll und stelle gerade fest, dass ich mir die URL nicht gemerkt habe. ich vollidiot.
Suche ich gleich nochmal raus. Genau, aber das sind so Beispiele, wo man das.
Mal ausprobieren kann zumindest. Smokesignal.events und den Blogbeitrag, den suche ich noch raus.
Ja, wenn man jetzt selber seinen PDS selber betreiben will, was halt geht,
dann gibt es halt die Software da von Blue Sky, also Soft-Git-Hub irgendwo und,
damit kann man dann halt auch alles machen, weil das speichert halt meine eigenen
Posts, die Bilder, die ich gepostet habe,
aber auch meine Likes, meine Follows, das sind alles Dinge, die da drin sind
und deswegen kann man das halt auch migrieren.
Es gibt jetzt auch so Account-Migration, also man könnte jetzt theoretisch ein
PDFs aufsetzen und seinen Account von dem Blue Sky PDS umziehen.
Habe ich aber nicht ausprobiert, habe nur gesehen, dass es irgendwie gibt.
Und dann wie gesagt, dieses Unbranded Webinterface, was halt benutzt werden
kann, um sich anzumelden.
Zwei Sachen noch.
Es gibt natürlich auch Probleme bei Blue Sky.
Es gab zum Beispiel so ein Parallelsystem, das nannte sich Black Sky,
was halt irgendwie so versucht hat, irgendwie so die schwarzen Community,
die sich natürlich immer wieder überall gemobbt gefühlt hat,
wahrscheinlich auch zu Recht, was separat aufzusetzen.
Die haben aber nicht wirklich eine eigene Infrastruktur aufgebaut.
Also die haben, glaube ich, nur die Personal Data Storage übernommen.
Also sie speichern sozusagen die Accounts für dich, um die von Blue Sky weg
zu haben und haben wahrscheinlich auch so eigene Labeler und sowas am Start.
Aber sie benutzen aber dann auch noch die Software...
Sie benutzen das Relay und auch den App-View von Blue Sky.
Deswegen unterliegen sie sozusagen auch noch der Moderation von Blue Sky.
Also sie haben sich nicht wirklich da getrennt.
Das Problem dabei ist wohl, dass die von Blue Sky veröffentlichte Open Source
Version von diesem App-View, also was quasi so den Content für das Netzwerk
ausmacht, nicht identisch ist mit dem, was sie quasi als Blue Sky betreiben.
Also inwiefern sich das Problem dann noch löst oder noch ein größeres Problem
bleibt, das werden wir mal sehen und da gab es natürlich dann entsprechende Sachen.
Jetzt gab es das war glaube ich so ein bisschen auch der Anlass für mich das
mal hier so aufzubringen, das wollte ich mal mit euch diskutieren jetzt gibt
es so Leute, die machen so auf Blue Sky auch noch so Apps für iOS irgendwie
die auch so ein bisschen so Instagram mäßig sein wollen,
hier deine Fotos und so weiter aus Deutschland, die jetzt so Vorschlag gemacht haben, man solle doch,
ein europäisches Blue Sky als protobasiertes Netz aufmachen.
EU Sky oder was?
Euro Sky.
Klingt so ein bisschen wie ein Defense Contractor.
Ja, nee. Also ich meine, die versuchen das schon ein bisschen.
Ich sag gleich, ich kenn die Leute nicht Und ich kann ja auch überhaupt nicht
einschätzen, ob die irgendwie nur dummes Zeug reden oder total brillant sind.
Kann alles irgendwie sein.
Mir geht es jetzt einfach nur um die Idee an sich und die finde ich ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht mal so schlicht.
Weil was sie im Prinzip propagieren ist mit dieser Idee, dass man ein eigenes
Relay aufsetzt, was halt mit öffentlichen Geldern finanziert ist.
Dass man sagt, okay, gebt mal her die Euro-Kohle, wir haben ja genug,
ins Data Center damit und dann fahren wir unseren eigenen Relay und wir fahren
vielleicht auch unsere eigene Eurosky-PDS Hosten für euch und unseren eigenen
App-View kriegen wir vielleicht auch noch,
installiert und wir machen dann halt auch Apps auf und vielleicht auch mehr
als eine App so ein ganzes Ökosystem Und dann können wir unabhängig von anderen,
mit der einzigen Ausnahme der PLC, die dann in der Schweiz sitzt,
zum Auflösen der Ad-Namen.
Haben wir sozusagen auf derselben technologischen Basis, die hier entwickelt
wird als Open Source, haben wir ein offenes System, wo die Leute quasi Herr
über ihre eigenen Daten sind und global posten können.
Und du kannst halt damit auch alle anderen Sachen bei Blue Sky halt auch benutzen.
Also du bist sozusagen nicht in dem einen oder dem anderen System,
aber du kannst halt sagen, ich will nur über das europäische Ökosystem hier
reingehen und wenn das amerikanische System billionärifiziert ist,
dann weggetrampt ist, dann bleibt das halt auf jeden Fall noch über.
Also ich halte nicht sonderlich viel von, wie man sich vielleicht denken kann.
Weil mir ist einfach nicht verständlich, was zu der Annahme führt,
dass jetzt eben Blue Sky und das ganze Ökosystem drumherum nicht genau derselben
in Schittification anheim fällt, wie alles andere auch.
Und dein einziges Argument ist jetzt, ja das Protokoll ist halt geiler.
Ja das mag sein, dafür ist aber schon jetzt das App-Ökosystem des Fidiverse geiler.
So, die haben halt einfach schon dort mal auch andere Apps am Start.
Die spielen nicht geil zusammen, habe ich gerade eben ausgeführt.
Das ist aber meines Erachtens ein lösbares Problem.
Auch wenn du sagst so, ja, ne, mach halt deine Instanz auf, das kann doch nicht
die Lösung sein. Nee, sicherlich nicht.
Klar muss ich meine Daten jetzt im Fidiverse irgendwo hingeben,
aber wir könnten doch mal so
ein paar Player geben, denen ich meine Daten auch ganz gerne geben würde.
Also beispielsweise überlegen wir derzeit, ob wir nicht als Bibliotheken dort reingehen und sagen so,
ja in eurer Stadtbibliothek kriegt ihr mit eurem Bibliotheksausweis auch einfach
einen Masterdown-Account mit dazu bei eurer Bibliothek.
Die machen das seit ein paar tausend Jahren, das sind nette Leute,
die haben noch nie irgendeine Entgertification auch nur einen Meter gegeben.
So und schon hast du einen...
Ein Ökosystem, dem du vertraust und was stabil ist und durchfinanziert und ja,
warum denn eigentlich nicht?
So und stattdessen jetzt wieder Milliarden EU-Gelder auf eine Architektur abzuwerfen,
die dann am Ende des Tages dann doch irgendwie ein bisschen shady ist. So, warum?
Was ist denn da shady dran? Also das verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Also du sagst jetzt einfach, ja das wird jetzt alles entschüttet und es ist
shady. Also was ist daran shady?
Weil jetzt da Blockchain, LLC da Kohle reinwirft.
Es ist halt völlig unklar, was sie für ein Geschäftsmodell eigentlich anstreben.
Darum könnten sie sich ja mal kümmern. Außer Venture Capital anzuhäufen.
So, was ist deren Geschäftsmodell? Die müssen ja irgendwie mal von irgendwas
leben. Wie stellen die sich das denn so vor in fünf Jahren? Da könnten sie doch
mal ein White Paper zuschreiben.
Wo sehen sie sich denn eigentlich?
Ja, wo sehen sie sich in fünf Jahren? Wo ich meine Bibliotheken in fünf Jahren
sehe, das kann ich dir glasklar runter definieren.
So, das ist mir bei dieser ganzen Truppe völlig, völlig unklar.
Ja gut, aber die Truppe kann ja auch pleite gehen, das Protokoll gibt es ja immer noch.
Ja, aber die prinzipielle Schönheit jetzt von so einem Protokoll,
du hast ja auch gesagt, es gibt auch dort durchaus Schwachstellen.
Ja, du kannst selber ein Relay hochziehen.
Aber wer kann das schon? Ich habe nicht gesprochen, ja. Nur gesagt,
in dem Design hast du natürlich Komponenten wie den Relay, die sind,
aber das ist ja sozusagen auch das, was du haben willst.
Leute sind ja bei Twitter und bei Threads und so weiter, weil du diese Firehose haben willst.
Du willst irgendwie auf einem Level sein und in Realtime diese Updates bekommen.
So, aber all diese Probleme hast du auf Mastodon gelöst, wenn du einfach einen
vernünftigen Client nimmst.
So, und das ist im Moment ein Projektproblem, dass du als erstes sagen musst,
nein, nimm bitte jetzt nicht den offiziellen Clients, sondern nimm eben Ivory
oder nimm Icecubes oder nimm Mona, um jetzt mal so die großen iOS-Clients zu nehmen.
So und dann hast du diese ganzen Probleme mit Discoverability und so weiter
aber auch mal wirklich effizient gelöst.
So dann hast du da kein Problem mehr, wenn du auf einer Instanz bist,
die einigermaßen durchföderiert ist.
Und das wären ja beispielsweise von öffentlichen Playern angebotene Instanzen.
So und dann bleibt meiner Meinung nach dann aus einer theoretischen Schönheit
eines Protokolls so praktisch auf der Straße nicht so viel Unterschied drin. So it's good enough.
Ja, aber was ist, wenn ich meine Daten halt einem besonders vertrauenswürdigen
Speicherort zuführen möchte?
Na, dann ist die Frage ja, was ist das? Das könnte ja beispielsweise deine Firma
sein, der du da besonders vertraust.
Oder es kann dein Sportverein sein oder es kann deine Bibliothek sein.
Oder wenn du es denn wirklich unbedingt sicher haben willst,
ja, dann machst du halt deinen eigenen Server. Das ist mit einer Sache wie Cloudron,
hast du das in fünf Minuten hochgezogen.
Ja, aber ein eigener Server bringt ja ganz viele andere Probleme mit sich.
Dann musst du da halt irgendwie permanent Software updaten, musst Logs checken.
Mit einem Dienst wie Cloudron hast du das nicht mehr.
Aber du hängst ja dann auf jeden Fall nicht auf derselben Art und Weise in der
Firehouse, als wenn du jetzt irgendwie auf mastodon.social bist.
Das kommt drauf an, wie vielen Leuten du folgst.
Ja, genau. Das hängt davon ab.
Ja, da kommen wir jetzt nicht zusammen. Du willst halt Geld auf dem nächsten,
zentralisierten US-Projekt abwerfen.
Ich sage nur einfach, das sind Ideen, die sind jetzt im Raum,
die werden auch diskutiert werden und ich finde ehrlich gesagt jetzt auch erstmal
absolut nachvollziehbar, weil das ja durchaus eine Infrastruktur ist,
die funktionieren kann.
Blue Sky hat sich jetzt noch nicht bewährt. Auf gar keinen Fall.
Und selbstverständlich hat das Fertifest eine absolute Existenzberechtigung.
Ich sage jetzt nicht, das muss jetzt alles weg. Ich sage nur,
ein paar Dinge, die dieser Szene eine Menge wert sein sollten,
wie zum Beispiel das Speichern der eigenen Daten und sozusagen eine Kommunikationshoheit.
Eine persönliche Kommunikationsheit und nicht auf Basis von Community ist in
diesem System nicht drin.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass das nicht noch kommt. Man könnte das ja auch da mal
denken vielleicht, dass man sowas auch hat. Es muss ja nicht unbedingt alles
auf dieser Instanz liegen.
Es kann ja sich vom Protokoll her auch entwickeln, dann wäre das ja immer durchaus
etwas, worüber man diskutieren kann.
Das ist vielleicht nicht ganz einfach, aber das ist sicherlich auch nicht unmöglich,
aber de facto gibt es das nicht. Es gibt aber auch dieses Prinzip dieser Feeds
nicht, es gibt das Prinzip dieser Labellers nicht.
Also viele Moderationsprobleme, die diese Netzwerke so mit sich bringen,
sind hier auf jeden Fall nicht nur mitgedacht, sondern eben auch implementiert.
Und das finde ich auf jeden Fall diskussionswürdig und ich finde einfach das
ist Quatsch, Blue Sky jetzt und
das ganze Ad-Protokoll-System genauso zu behandeln, als wäre es Twitter.
Also das ist einfach Quatsch es implementiert ein ähnliches System wie Twitter,
also es versucht etwas zu implementieren, was so funktionieren kann und auch
tatsächlich auch funktioniert wie Twitter aber es ist halt nicht Twitter und
es ist auch nicht Threads sondern es ist eine wirkliche Alternative zu solchen Firehose,
basierten Globalchats und dass die populär sind, das wissen wir einfach.
Das ist alles, was ich sagen will. Und deswegen sollten wir das nicht aus dem
Auge verlieren und schon gar nicht so standardmäßig so abtun mit,
ja, da ist ja mal ein Millionär durch den Flur gegangen, deswegen ist das alles
Bubu. Also das ist ja wirklich auch Quatsch.
Nun ja.
Ein Millionär dran vorbeigetragen worden.
Ja, also ich als Gewächs des öffentlichen Dienstes, Public Money, Public Code.
Ich hätte gerne Social Media als Gesamtökosystem gerne in öffentlich finanzierten Strukturen.
Die Frage, was passiert eigentlich, wenn da ein Millionär vorbeikommt und da
Milliarden draufwirft?
Wie verändert das das System oder ist es überhaupt sinnvoll für einen Milliardär?
Der tut es ja nicht aus Gutmenschentum, sondern es ist ja ganz klar,
dass diese Medien eine Möglichkeit sind, Macht zu erringen.
Also man sieht es an Meta, man sieht es an Twitter etc.
All diese Milliardäre haben sich ihre eigenen Medien gekauft.
Und ist das System dagegen robust, ist ja die eigentliche Frage.
Und kann ich jetzt nicht beantworten, aber es scheint ja tatsächlich so zu sein,
dass die Blue Sky Leute versuchen, genau so etwas zu verhindern.
Ja, und ich denke, das Design gibt es auch her. Also abgesehen von diesem zentralen
D-ID-Auflösungsspeicher, da wirklich das einzig zentrale Element ist in dem
ganzen Spiel, ist alles andere dezentral.
Und bei Mastodon hat man schon auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl,
dass es funktioniert sowieso so schlecht, dass ich das keinen Milliardär kaufen würde.
Naja, also mit einem vernünftigen Client funktioniert das super.
Ja, klar, mit dem vernünftigen Client, aber ja.
So, und die gibt es halt dann doch wie Sand am Meer. Und die Macedon-Leute selber
sind da auch durchaus jetzt hinterher.
Ich habe jetzt mit dem neuen PR-Menschen ein bisschen ja gesprochen,
der war ja auch auf dem Feli Days.
Die haben da jetzt viel zu tun, außer den Charakter ihres ganzen Projektes ein
bisschen umzukrempeln. Ich glaube, da wird das eine oder andere sich auch noch ergeben.
Aber das werden wir dann ja alles noch erleben.
Na gut.
Gut, was haben wir noch?
Also vielleicht einfach anschließend so zur, ich bin ja dafür,
es gibt nichts Gutes, außer man tut es.
Habe ich noch ein bisschen Infrastruktur gebaut, auch für das Fidiverse und für Mastodon.
Also ehrlich gesagt nur für Mastodon, nämlich für den Vortrag,
damit man auch ein bisschen was zu zeigen hat, die 2.0 Version meiner Mastowall.
Wir erinnern uns die Anzeige, wie man,
wie damals in den guten alten Twitter-Republika-Zeiten für ein Event oder sonstige
Veranstaltungen so eine Masterwall bauen kann.
Das heißt, zu einem gegebenen Hashtag wird einem dort alles angezeigt, was es so gibt.
Ich gucke jetzt gerade mal, nehmen wir mal sowas hier in der Art.
Und da habe ich versucht, mal ein Problem zu lösen, was Mastodon ja durchaus
hat, nämlich diese Discoverability.
Das heißt also, wie finde ich jetzt eigentlich interessante Accounts und Leute,
die auch zu meinem Thema irgendwas schreiben.
Vielleicht, Tim, könntest du das mal auf den Screen werfen, damit man so klickt
und gleichzeitig was sagt, genau.
Klicken und gleichzeitig was sagen. Genau, wir beschreiben die Traumzustände
der modernen Welt. Was ist hier los?
Klickt er wild auf den Beamer?
Aber es passiert jetzt nicht. Wie lässt sich das hier nicht...
Was erlaube, Apple?
Wie lässt sich das hier nicht dragen? So, jetzt ist es gedrackt, geklickt.
Genau, ich habe die Optik mal ein bisschen angepasst, dass das so ein bisschen
fresher alles aussieht.
Und es gibt jetzt oben rechts so einen neuen Umschalter, wo man verschiedene Views umschalten kann.
Und der zweite ist so ein People-Tag.
Genau, einen weiter rechts.
Und dort sehen sie dort klickt sieht man leider nichts das ist schade warum
sieht man dort nichts ist eigentlich alles alles okay mach nochmal reload,
machen wir ein bisschen breiter das fenster aber eigentlich skaliert das auch
auf mobilgeräten und so problemlos.
Kaputt. Also was du eigentlich demonstrieren möchtest ist, dass das System anzeigt,
welche Leute posten denn eigentlich mit diesem Hashtag.
Genau, das heißt also, dass man nicht nur jetzt die Karten mit den Postings
hat, sondern auch sieht,
wer dort alles schreibt und die werden gerankt nach Anzahl der Postings,
die sie in den letzten 30 Tagen zu diesem Hashtag geschrieben haben und man
kann auch dann in dieser Ansicht gleich aufklappen, was haben die dazu geschrieben,
um sich auch noch einen Eindruck davon zu machen, so lohnt das wirklich denen zu folgen.
Und dann hat man direkt daneben auch in der Tat einen schönen Follow-Button,
um sich schnell dann interessante Leute dazu zu klicken.
Und da läuft man dann in genau das Problem rein, was ich vorhin schon mal angesprochen
hatte mit der Authentifizierung. Das heißt, da muss man sich auch einmal gegen
seine Mastodon-Instanz authentifizieren.
Aber das habe ich, indem ich in der Tat jetzt eigenen Out-Server auch betreibe
dafür auf einem kleinen Lamp-System, dann so runtergebrochen,
dass es dann wirklich mit einem einzigen Klick dann auch erledigt ist.
Das heißt also, da kommt man dann relativ geschmeidig dran.
Da musst du nochmal reinreiben hier, das scheint nicht zu funktionieren.
Ich habe es jetzt schon mit dem zweiten Browser ausprobiert.
Machen wir mal irgendwie Shift, Reload oder sowas, dass der Cache weg ist.
Oder machen wir mal ein anderes.
Versuch mal noch einen dritten Browser.
Ich wüsste nicht, warum das gerade nicht. Also bei mir läuft es hier gerade.
Das verwundert mich jetzt.
Ha, works for me.
Ja.
Verstehe.
Let's ship your machine.
Tja.
Es kommt ein echt noch hinten. View People. Genau, den Link nochmal.
Den Link nochmal.
Sonderbar. Hast du irgendeinen Browser-Plugin? Da ist auch überhaupt nichts am Start.
Nicht im Chrome. Und schon gar nicht im Firefox.
Firefox ist auch alles empty hier.
Kannst du ja mal als Hashtag mal Freakshow nehmen oder so.
Freakshow? Glaubst du, irgendjemand twittert gerade über uns?
Das Schrei ist Schrei.
Mastotootet. Postet.
Mastotoot.
Mastotooten.
Wer tut das denn? Mastotoot. Freakshow. Freakshow.
Genau. Den zweiten immer raus. So ist damit, genau. Man kann da bis zu drei Hashtags kombinieren.
Und dann geht es nochmal auf das People.
One month ago, 22 days ago. Keiner redet über uns.
Ja, das prangere ich an.
Außer wir selbst.
Das läuft wirklich so gar nicht hier bei dir.
Warum? Tja. Wannst du mal sehen, aber wir sind schon so out hier irgendwie.
Also bei uns wird noch nicht mal auf Masse rangekriegen.
Ja, ja, ja. Es geht da hin. Ja, wir senden hier in die Lehre hinein.
Vielleicht kann der Chat ja mal kurz schreiben.
Das meinten sie nämlich immer, im Internet ist immer noch genug Platz.
Send es einfach in den Void.
Das versendet sich. Das versendet sich aber so richtig.
Das hat man doch früher beim Radio immer gesagt.
Ja, das versendet sich. Das ist jetzt bei uns auch.
Du kannst dich ja mal testhalber, Geh mal oben rechts auf das Connect-Icon,
ob das irgendetwas ändert.
Das Connect-Icon. Was ist denn das Connect-Icon? Das hier?
Genau.
So ein fancy Link.
Genau, da gibt es jetzt einen, auf welcher Instanz du bist.
Ach, da muss ich mich jetzt anmelden.
Genau, und dann wirst du direkt wieder zurückgeschickt und bist angemeldet.
Jetzt muss ich dem hier noch alle meine Datenpreis geben.
Das ändert auch nichts an dem View.
Das ändert auch nichts.
Kannst du mal die Browser-Konsole mal aufmachen, ob du da irgendwelche Fehler schmeißt?
Wollen wir das jetzt hier wirklich während der Sendung?
Irgendwas da ist doch eine rotes...
Nein, wollen wir nicht. Aus.
Exception hier. Fehler.
Fehler.
Type Error. Das musst du... Back to the drawing board, mein Freund. Hier, jQuery.
Errors. Ist ja egal. Es ist ja gut gemeint.
Gut gemeint ist aber nicht gut gemacht.
Tja, so ist das.
Es hat schon mal funktioniert. Auf Ralfs Laptop, ihr müsst also alle auf Ralfs
Laptop gehen und dann läuft das dann.
Ja, das ist doch wirklich, das atmet doch den richtigen Geist.
Schreibt mal in den Chat, ob das bei euch läuft. Das ist gerade weird. dass es nicht geht.
So und womit hast du das gevibe codet?
Das habe ich gevibe codet in der Tat im Wechsel zwischen,
ChatGPT 5 und CloudSonnet 4.5 Also ChatGPT 5 ist ja schon ein bisschen länger
raus und hat ja schon einen ganz guten Ruf für Coding,
Und Claude Sonnet kam dann die Woche vor dem Fedi-Day raus und dachte ich,
na dann lassen wir das nochmal gegeneinander antreten und habe ich es relativ
häufig so gemacht in Cursor,
dem einen LLM das Problem gegeben und lösen lassen und geguckt,
okay, wie weit ist er gekommen, dann revertet und dann der anderen LLM denselben
Prompt quasi vorgeworfen, dass man so ein bisschen AB-Test hat,
wie schlagen sich so die beiden Systeme bei einer und derselben Aufgabe und
einem und demselben Hintergrund.
Da guck bei den Leuten läuft es überall.
Irgendwas ist hier mit deinem Rechner komisch, Tim.
Das kann schon sein.
Und für die Sachen, die ich da mitgemacht habe, war so mein Fazit,
die sind total gleichauf gerade.
Bei dem einen war mal Cloud Sonnet besser, bei dem anderen war mal JetGPT besser, auch vom Stil her.
Könnte ich da nicht wirklich einen Finger drauf halten, was da jetzt irgendwo,
innovativer oder konservativer oder sonst wie wäre.
Ist das natürlich nicht wirklich eine systematische Auswertung,
aber so zwei Tage habe ich da schon dran rumgebruckelt und ich würde sagen,
das tut sich gerade nicht viel, die beiden Systeme und die sind generell beide gut klargekommen.
Ist das allerdings auch eher ein überschaubares Projekt, was wir jetzt hier haben.
Ja, naja, ich habe mich ein bisschen gewöhnt an Claude,
Der alte Claude und ich. Wir haben da übrigens im Chat noch eine Frage bekommen
vor der Sendung. Ich habe mal nach Fragen gefragt.
Wir sollten das vielleicht mal mit diesen Fragen mal ein bisschen etablieren nochmal.
Ich weiß, wir haben das schon mal probiert, das hat nicht so gut funktioniert.
Aber die Frage war, das finde ich ganz gut die Frage, jetzt muss ich noch kurz
vorlegen, wo die Frage, wo ich die hingeschrieben habe.
Wo ist die Antwort?
Ich suche mal kurz die Antwort, genau. Die Frage war, was wir nicht,
welche Anwendungen würdet ihr nicht Weib koden?
Alles im Krankenhaus.
Ich würde sagen,
Gar keine. Im Sinne des Wortes Anwendung, also wenn es da auch Anwender gibt.
Also wenn man sozusagen Software jetzt wirklich for the public macht,
dann muss man auf jeden Fall vorsichtig sein. Sagen wir es mal so.
Auf gar keinen Fall sollte man jetzt ein System bauen, was, also klar,
dein Mastowall, überschaubares Ding, läuft irgendwie lokal im Browser und nobody
cares. Das ist überhaupt nicht das Ding. Für so kleine Sachen alles wunderbar.
Anwendung im Sinne von größeres System, was wirklich komplexe Dinge tut,
denen man irgendwie auch vertrauen muss, wo Security eine Rolle spielt, schwierig.
Generell finde ich, sollte man überhaupt gar keine Software in die Welt rausschicken,
die nicht von den Programmierern auch verstanden wird. Man kann sich natürlich helfen lassen.
Und ich glaube, das ist so der Hauptwert derzeit eigentlich,
ist so dieses Planen, Abwägen. Also ich habe sehr gute Ergebnisse,
so mit so früh gleich so einen Dialog zu suchen und man sieht das jetzt auch
bei den letzten Updates mit Cursor.
Also die haben ja jetzt auch so dieses Planen ist jetzt richtig so Teil des
Konzepts und damit spart man auch nochmal Tokens.
Es geht jetzt sozusagen richtig erstmal in so einen Planungsmodus,
wo auch klar ist, wir schreiben jetzt nichts, aber wir erzeugen einen Plan.
Es gab ja dieses Ask, wo nur so, ja, ich chatte jetzt mal mit dir und hier wird
überhaupt keine Datei erzeugt und Planen ist so,
ja, wir erzeugen schon Dateien, nämlich Pläne und wir setzen das aber jetzt
nicht wirklich in Code um.
Und da muss ich sagen, es ist wirklich sehr hilfreich insbesondere wenn man
auch gleich so mit so Rückfragen kommt also ich schreibe jetzt gerne so am Anfang rein,
Ja, ich würde gerne das und das machen, hier lalala, ich habe mir das so und
so vorgestellt und dann am Schluss so, was meinst du denn so? Hast du Fragen?
Und dann kommen da wirklich interessante Sachen, weil du dann eben so konfrontiert
wirst mit, hast du das bedacht, hast du das bedacht?
Ich habe nicht so genau verstanden, wie du das gemeint hast,
das könnte ja dies und dieses meinen und so weiter.
Also so Unklarheiten raus. Und das hilft einfach super dabei,
mal überhaupt mal so den eigenen Scope abzustecken.
Wo will ich hin? Wie designe ich das?
Was gibt es vielleicht für bekannte Patterns, die man hier anwenden sollte,
könnte oder vielleicht auch nicht anwenden sollte?
All diese ganzen Sachen. Dinge, die man vielleicht auch noch nicht kennt.
Und ja, ich würde das so angehen.
Also eher als Nachschlagewerk, als Berater, als Planungstool und occasionally
für Sachen, die nicht wichtig sind.
Also wir sitzen jetzt zum Beispiel gerade an so einem neuen Projekt und da ging
es dann irgendwie darum,
zum Rumspielen brauchen wir jetzt erstmal so einen Data-Import,
damit man erstmal Daten in der Datenbank hat und überhaupt erstmal richtig weiterentwickeln
kann. Das ist keine kritische Komponente.
Das sollte dann später nicht der Importer sein, den man dann irgendwie als Teil
des Systems begreift, sondern einfach so als Developer-Tool.
Dafür ist es super, auch um mal schnell zu testen, funktioniert die API,
wie ich sie habe überhaupt, kriege ich damit jetzt was hin, besteht sozusagen
mein eigenes System hier gerade den Real-Life-Test, wenn ich da dagegen Vibe-Code und so weiter.
Das sind auf jeden Fall Sachen, mit denen man sich extrem viel Zeit sparen kann.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, vor allen Dingen Dinge überhaupt erstmal rauszufinden, wie sie funktionieren.
Also ich habe ja so eine Nextcloud installiert und das ist ja auch so ein sehr halbseitenes Projekt.
Also das ist ja wieso.
Dass es in PHP geschrieben ist ja ja genau.
Das ist so wie WordPress naja egal also ich habe es zum Laufen gekriegt und
habe halt mir aber relativ viel Unterstützung von den AIs geholt,
um immer wieder zu fragen, ja wie mache ich denn das wie mache ich denn das, wie mache ich denn das,
ja manchmal erfindet er halt dann irgendwie noch ein paar Command Line Switches
bei Befehlen dazu, wo du dir so denkst,
aber im Großen und Ganzen, wenn man das Problem halbwegs beschreiben kann,
kriegt man auch eine halbwegs brauchbare Fehlerbeschreibung und wie man das
Problem denn ungefähr gelöst bekommt.
Interessant sind halt so Sachen, wo wenn du früher die,
die Foren durchgewühlt hast zu einer Frage und alle stellen die gleiche Frage,
aber es gibt keine Antwort,
dann kriegst du heute halt von der von der AI halt auch keine gute Antwort,
weil es die halt nicht gibt.
Niemand hat das Problem bisher gelöst und was soll die AI denn da Magisches tun?
Also das ist schon so, naja, es ist keine Ahnung, also ich weiß nicht.
Also ich würde sagen, grundsätzlich alles mit Schreibrechten,
da wäre ich schon mal sehr vorsichtig, also das ist so eine Grenze,
wo ich immer sage, das machen wir jetzt vielleicht mal besser nicht wo ich es
aber nach wie vor fantastisch für finde ist, um Proof of Concepts,
rauszuhauen also ich laufe, weil du gerade sagst Nextcloud, ich laufe seit einem
halben Jahr bei uns durch die Gegend und sage so,
wir werden es technisch ermöglichen, dass wir unser discourse-basiertes Intranet
mit einer transparenten Nextcloud, die selber gar nicht,
wo das rechte System gar nicht zum Tragen kommt, sondern quasi nur mit Hashtag,
also Hashcode Security by Obscurity URLs Public Links generiert und dann am
Ende Collabora Office-Dateien bearbeitbar werden.
Sodass du im Discourse sagen kannst, in einem Thread.
Ich möchte jetzt hier eine Word-Datei erstellen und dann klicke ich da drauf
und es wird direkt das Kollaborer hochgefahren und Nextcloud als Middleware ist quasi unsichtbar.
So, und alle, die Zugriff haben auf diesen Thread innerhalb von Discourse,
können also quasi dann kollaborativ Office-Dateien bearbeiten.
Ich sage seit einem halben Jahr, so, das wird funktionieren.
So, und jetzt habe ich mich aber mal hingesetzt, letztes Wochenende und habe
es auch mal gebaut und jetzt kann ich zeigen, dass es funktioniert.
Und das ist ein Riesenunterschied.
Und jetzt kann man es irgendeiner Bude geben und sagen, so jetzt mach das bitte mal in ordentlich.
Ja, ich hatte halt, also ...
Ich war ja in China, also Freakshow berichtete und wir sind da ja mit dem Chor
hingefahren und dann gab es so dieses Problem,
wo schmeißen wir denn alle mal unsere Fotos gemeinsam ab, dass wir die alle
irgendwie im Originalgröße so dateimäßig alle haben und dann halt auch andere
Leute Fotos runterladen können.
Da habe ich gedacht, naja gut, ich gucke mir das an, habe mir so die diversen
Cloud-Varianten angeguckt, die es da gab und dann ist die Entscheidung auf Nextcloud gefallen.
Und dann habe ich das Ding installiert und bin ja so ein bisschen vom Glauben abgefallen.
Also das ist so, so von der Benutzung her ist es so, als wäre es gerade aus
der Beta-Phase raus oder noch nicht. Also du kannst ja zum Beispiel...
Vielleicht ist es das ja auch.
Nee, ist schon Version 3 irgendwas. Du kannst da also in Ordner Fotos hochladen
und wenn du die Fotos als Files hochlädst, dann kriegst du kleine Vorschaubildchen,
so entweder als Liste oder als Icons, wie man es so kennt.
Du kannst die Fotos aber auch als Fotos hochladen und dann kannst du sie in ein Album tun.
Aber meinst du, die beiden Komponenten würden irgendwie interagieren?
Also du kannst nicht mal sagen, guck mal, mach mal aus dem Ordner,
den ich da habe, ein Fotoalbum.
Nee, du musst die Fotos alles nochmal neu hochladen. Wer macht denn sowas?
Naja, Version 3, ich bitte dich.
Also,
keine Ahnung, ich bin nicht sehr begeistert. Ich hoffe, dass ich dieses Problem
Nextcloud auch bald gelöst habe, dass alle, die wollen, hochgeladen haben,
alle, die wollen, runtergeladen haben und ich die Kiste wieder platt machen kann.
Ein Feature nicht haben ist ja nicht so schlimm, wie es funktioniert nicht.
Also ich meine, wenn das, was sie anbieten, zumindest halbwegs funktioniert, ist ja okay.
Ja, tut es. Es war frickelig, aber ich habe es irgendwie zum Laufen gekriegt.
Also ich bin auch kein Riesenfan von diesem Nextcloud-Ansatz.
Wir behaupten jetzt, wir hätten für alles eine App in unserem Nextcloud-Biotop.
Und dann guckst du dir das Wiki an und dann guckst du dir die Bilddatenbank
an und dann guckst du dir das Pad an und denkst so, es ist halt nicht so,
es ist nicht best of breed, es ist auch gar nicht geil.
Und es ist vom Design her auch wieder alles total, jeder macht dann wieder seins.
Es ist halt ein offenes Ökosystem.
Aber kein Freund. Also von daher ist jetzt auch meine Strategie Nextcloud eher verstecken.
Ich finde selbst die Nextcloud-Basis GUI schwierig.
Sie ist besser geworden und es ist keine Vollkatastrophe. Aber spätestens wenn
du anfängst irgendwie so Rechte zu administrieren in der Nextcloud denkst du
dir auch so, Leute, setz doch da mal ein UXler ran.
Ja und dann so Dinge, wie du machst, einen neuen Account und in dem neuen Account
sind dann irgendwie beschissenste Beispieldaten drin.
Das kannst du ja wiederum parametrisieren, das kannst du ja alles beim Ausrollen
angeben, was die quasi Boilerplate-Geschichten sind für einen neuen Account.
Ja, aber nicht einfach.
Naja, Dokumentation lesen muss man schon.
Ist jetzt Nextcloud eigentlich gerade das Thema? Also wir müssen das ja nicht weiter vertiefen.
Ja, so für ein paar Minuten haben wir über Nextcloud. Wir müssen es auch Und
wie du meintest, nicht vertiefend, das ist schon okay.
Ich war halt so underwhelmed und andere Sachen habe ich gar nicht so richtig zu machen.
Irgendein anderes Ding habe ich noch ausprobiert, aber das konnte dann noch
weniger und war noch instabiler. Also es war alles ganz merkwürdig.
So, wo wir aber gerade dann doch so ein bisschen über AI gesprochen haben.
Ja, uns fehlt da immer noch irgendwas ein.
Wollte ich nochmal kurz erwähnen. Da hatte ich überlegt, ob wir mal demnächst
mal vielleicht den Jens einladen. Da bin ich jetzt nicht zugekommen.
Oh Gott, hoffentlich finde ich jetzt hier den Link und zwar wie heißt es hier
so schön New Project Makes Wikipedia.
Wollen wir es doch nicht wirklich machen wenn Jens kommt?
Ich wollte es mal kurz erwähnen Okay,
Und zwar hat Wikimedia Deutschland das angekündigt tatsächlich eine neue Datenbank
die sozusagen, also es heißt Wikidata Embedding Project,
Ich grübel noch ein bisschen, ob dieser Name eigentlich ein guter Name ist,
aber das ist auf jeden Fall das Projekt und da geht es darum,
den ganzen Wikidata-Kram in einer AI-kompatibleren Form darzustellen.
Also sozusagen dieselben Daten einfacher durchsuchbar zu machen,
so für vektorbasierte, semantische Suche, wie das so schön heißt.
Genau, und das ist irgendwie etwas, was sie tun.
Bisher gab es ja sozusagen nur so SparkQL als quasi so SQL-artige,
vielleicht ein bisschen der falsche Ausdruck, aber sagen wir mal so ein präziser,
klar benannter Abfragestyle, der halt so ein bisschen an SQL,
vielleicht nicht unbedingt angelehnt ist, aber daran erinnert, sagen wir es mal so.
Und es gibt wohl irgendwie so ein Keyword Matching, aber irgendwie nichts,
was jetzt wirklich gut von diesen AI-Tools gut durchsucht werden kann.
Und ich finde das eigentlich ganz gut, dass sie das machen, weil ich denke,
dass es ein Fehler wäre, jetzt Wikidata hier aus dem ganzen Spiel irgendwie rauszuhalten.
Und auch Alternativen dazu zu bieten, jetzt nur lad doch alles runter und mach
deinen Quatsch alleine.
Dafür ist glaube ich dieser Datenbestand mittlerweile auch schon zu groß.
Ja, also das können wir vielleicht wirklich mal in einer späteren Sendung aufgreifen.
Fand ich auf jeden Fall ganz interessant.
Dann habe ich noch ein Gadget entdeckt, was ich nicht gekauft habe.
Aber ich glaube, da müssen wir mal drüber reden. Und zwar gibt es ja diesen Raspberry Pi.
Den gibt es ja in zwei Varianten
also genau genommen gibt es den auch in mehr Varianten aber es gibt ihn unter
anderem in einer klassischen Ich-bin-ein-Rasperi-Pie-Format und eine Million
Gehäuse und Steckersysteme gibt es dafür um das Ding in allen möglichen Richtungen zu erweitern,
und dann wie schön hier auf meinem Tisch, gibt es ja den Raspberry Pi,
also das ist jetzt der 400er, der hier steht, also das ist quasi Wie die.
Hörer nicht sehen.
Also eine flache, weiße Tastatur.
Wie ihr jetzt gerade seht, gibt es den Raspberry Pi auch in einer Tastatur eingebaut.
Habe ich glaube ich auch schon mal erwähnt. Und finde ich auch ganz toll,
eigentlich das Produkt, weil ehrlich gesagt, ich hätte auch gerne noch einen Bildschirm dabei.
Das wäre eigentlich ganz gut. Einfach noch so ein kleiner LCD noch dabei,
Das fände ich auch noch ganz geil.
Aber so ist es auf jeden Fall cool. Da hat man immer gleich eine Tastatur am Start.
Hättest du einen Laptop?
Ah, Laptop, genau so heißt das. Ja, so ein Raspberry Pi Laptop.
Da brauchst du noch eine große Powerbank und schon bist du...
Naja, es muss jetzt nicht mit Akku und so weiter sein, sondern einfach nur so,
dass man das irgendwo so hinstellt, Strom anschließt und dann passt das schon. Aber okay.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich auch irgendwelche fertigen Lösungen, habe ich noch gar
nicht geguckt, ob man irgendwas quasi an dieses Gehäuse einfach ranattachen kann. Wahrscheinlich.
Anyway, auf jeden Fall gibt es da seit einiger Zeit den Raspberry Pi 5 und dementsprechend
gab es dann auch, wenig überraschend, den Raspberry Pi 500.
Und der Raspberry Pi 500 ist...
Bunt.
Genauso wie der Raspberry Pi 400, bloß halt schneller.
Nein.
Doch. Also ist irre.
Und der ist bunt, mit bunten Tasten.
Nein, er ist nicht bunt.
Hintergrundbeleuchtung.
Nein, ist er nicht.
Aber ist doch hier im Screenshot zu sehen. Also ihr seht das jetzt nicht.
Im Screenshot ist überhaupt nichts zu sehen. Was es jetzt gibt,
ist der Raspberry Pi 500 Plus. Und der ist bunt.
Dammit.
Der hat nämlich eine ganz andere Tastatur und also während der 400 und 500 eher
so eine Tastatur haben, wie so ein MacBook würde ich sagen, ne?
Ist das mit dem 500 Plus ganz anders. Das ist nämlich so eine Klackertastatur. Die klackert.
Wie, die klackert?
Ja, die macht Geräusche.
Wie so eine gute alte Sherry Doppelklick?
Ja, kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen. Also ich habe zwei Videos gesehen.
Die macht auf jeden Fall ordentlich Alarm und als besonders auffälliges Gadget
hat sie unter jeder Taste eine LED.
Unter jeder Taste eine Farb-LED.
Weil es kostet ja nichts.
Gut, es ist nichts übermäßig Neues, aber ja.
Nee, also für ein Raspberry Pi ist das was Neues.
Aber es scheint nicht auf den jeweiligen Buchstaben durch. Sehe ich das richtig?
Die sind nicht so transparent gebaut.
Nee, nee, es scheint nur außenrum.
Es ist nur, genau.
Weil es könnte ja interessant sein, um irgendwie Funktionsgruppen für Keyboard-Shortcuts
und sowas dann auch wirklich abzubilden. Aber wenn das nur so drum rum strahlt,
ist das so ein bisschen fuzzy, oder?
Meinst du, das ist präzise genug für eine einzelne Taste?
Es ist präzise genug für eine einzelne Taste, das kann ich insofern bestätigen.
Ich meine, ich habe das Ding noch nicht in der Hand gehabt, ich habe mir nur Videos angeschaut.
Der einzige Nachteil ist, dass dieses Interface noch nicht spezifiziert zu sein scheint.
Ich gehe mal schwer davon aus, dass das bald kommen wird oder vielleicht auch
schon so weit ist und ich habe es noch nicht mitbekommen, aber initial gab es
jetzt erstmal keine Möglichkeit oder zumindest keine öffentlich dokumentierte
Möglichkeit, wie man jetzt an diese LEDs rankommt. Aber das wird natürlich stattfinden.
Und das Ding wird,
ausgeliefert mit, glaube ich, vier verschiedenen Farbmodis, die du machen kannst.
Also entweder alles in einer Farbe
oder die ganze Zeit so ein hin- und herwabernder Rainbow-Scheißdreck.
Addressable RGB, was hattest du erwartet?
Naja, nichts anderes habe ich erwartet. Ein Modus hat mir allerdings sehr gut gefallen.
Und zwar gibt es einen Modus, wo quasi jede Taste, also wo sozusagen eine rote
Lampe unter der Taste, die du gerade gedrückt hast, eine Weile nachleuchtet.
Oh, hat man so einen Trail dann da.
Genau, das ist so ein Trail.
Oh, dann glüht das so. So schön, haben will. Aber das ist bestimmt sexy.
Da dachte ich auch so, ja okay, das ist jetzt mal wirklich eine Innovation im Tastaturbereich.
Das scheint mir auch so ein Tastaturschreiblernen Anwendungs danach zu rufen.
Also drücke immer die Taste, die leuchtet.
Also Erik postet hier gerade im Chat ein Foto von dieser Tastatur,
der tatsächlich nahelegt, dass die Buchstaben transparent sind.
Allerdings zeigt das auch wieder sehr schön, wie sehr sie es leider verkackt
haben, die Beschriftung auf dieser Tastatur ordentlich hinzubekommen.
Sehr klein, nicht zentriert und alles völlig sinnlos. Also das verstehe ich
nicht, warum man jetzt die.
Kowalski schreibt gerade, Trail Mode ist für Passwörter perfekt. Ja, genau.
Da hilft natürlich ein gut integriertes Betriebssystem, was weiß,
wenn du ein Passwort eingibst, dass du dann automatisch das ...
Stimmt, Trademort ist natürlich ein Sekretärproblem.
Wir werden kein Apple Pie sehen, also das kannst du vergessen.
Wieso? Also ich meine, ein Mac weiß, wenn du ein Passwort eingibst.
Meine Vision Pro weiß das auch.
Jaja, schon, nur da läuft kein Mac OS auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Warst du dann auf kein Mac OS drauf?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Was ist denn das für ein Scheiß?
Vielleicht haben die ersten Leute auch schon und so weiter.
Naja, also da kann man bestimmt schöne Sachen bald mit bauen.
Also es gibt Lösungen, um tatsächlich ein gesamtes Mac OS in einem Container
irgendwie zu containerisieren.
Ich habe allerdings nur quasi den Blogpost beziehungsweise das Ding auf GitHub gesehen, aber nicht das,
das eigentliche hab's nicht ausprobiert wo wir schon bei so Bastellösungen sind,
habt ihr schon von dem Open Source Drucker gehört?
Ja, hab ich gehört Und?
Was ist deine Meinung dazu?
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich da schon also generell muss ich sagen,
finde ich das eine gute Idee, ist halt ein Tintenpisser Ich hasse Tintenpisser, aber meinetwegen.
Ja, aber die Idee so nach der Art, jetzt gibt es so viele Firmen,
die für etablierte Drucker Billigpatronen nachgebaut haben.
Jetzt kann man die doch eigentlich auch direkt benutzen. Finde ich eigentlich ganz, ganz witzig.
Ja, also einen Open-Source-Drucker halte ich für eine verdammt gute Idee.
Das Design ist hier ganz interessant, weil der ist ja so ein bisschen dafür
gemacht, an die Wand gehängt zu werden, weil der zieht ja sein Papier von einer Endlosrolle.
Genau, und schneidet sie dann aber auch ab.
Und schneidet sie ab. Das ist natürlich mega.
Und er macht DIN A4 hochkant. Also sprich, du kannst auch DIN A3 ausdrucken.
Also die Breite der Rolle ist DIN A4 hochkant.
Die Breite der Rolle ist DIN A4 hochkant?
Also 29 Zentimeter.
Kannst du noch längere Banner sogar auch drucken.
Du kannst lange Banner drücken, aber du kannst halt auch DIN A3 Seiten ausdrucken, wenn es sein muss.
Okay, jetzt verstehe ich es langsam. Das sieht ja auf dem Bild da gerade nicht so nach DIN A4 aus.
Nee, sieht nicht so danach aus, aber angeblich ist es so.
Okay, vielleicht gibt es ja auch verschiedene Druckbreiten. Kann das sein?
Ich meine, wenn das da so eingefädelt wird.
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wo man dieses aufgerollte Papier herkriegt.
Das Ganze sieht aus wie so ein Kleenex-Box, wo oben eine Klopapierrolle drauf ist.
Das ist wirklich eine tolle Idee.
Und vor allem, was ich besonders gut daran finde, ist, dass der eben nicht so
aussieht wie andere Drucker.
Also der erfüllt auf einmal ganz andere Use-Case. Die kannst du zum Beispiel
an die Außenseite eines Gebäudes,
machen und dann hast du so einen automatischen Flugblattverteiler.
Der druckt dann immer ein Flugblatt,
schneidet es ab und es fällt dann automatisch so auf die Bevölkerung.
Auf gut Deutsch kannst du auch hinten ans Auto ranmachen.
Ja, weiß ich, der wird dann wahrscheinlich schnell.
Oder eine Drohne montieren. Dann hast du ein Flugblatt verteilt.
Ja, okay.
Also es ist wirklich ein interessantes Design. Die Frage ist,
wie lange hält das Messer? Ja, was das abschneidet?
Weil wenn du dann plötzlich so eine Wrisselkante hast, so, dann ist der Sex-Appeal
glaube ich schnell dahin.
Aber grundsätzlich tolle Idee. Da musst du dann noch Diamanten noch rantackern.
Ja, genau.
Schlaft sich selber.
Ich glaube, der eigentliche Appeal an dem Ding ist,
dass es ein Drucker ohne Entschertification und Cloud und Gedöns ist,
sondern es ist halt so ein Teil, wo du Treiber bekommst, die du installierst
und dann funktioniert er einfach.
Dann schreibt er dir auch nicht vor, welche Tintenpatronen du zu kaufen hast etc. etc.
Wie, da muss man Treiber installieren.
Also ich nehme mal an, keine Ahnung, da das Ding irgendwie noch in der Crowdfunding-Phase ist,
wird es wohl noch eine Weile dauern, bis wir die Teile also dann auch in relativ
gutem Zustand, aber klar.
Okay, also man muss dazu sagen, das Ganze ist Crowdfunding irgendwie,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Und existiert noch nicht, sondern es ist sozusagen eine Idee und das,
wie ich finde, eine ganz, ganz gute Idee, also generell.
Innen drin ist ein Raspberry Pi Zero verbaut.
Mhm.
Hm.
Ja.
Also es ist einfach eine coole Idee, einen Drucker neu zu denken.
Das feiere ich schon mal hart.
Nach den 3D-Druckern, die man selber bauen kann. Jetzt die 2D-Drucker,
die man selber bauen kann. Also...
Ja, das hätte ich gerne als Laserdrucker.
Das ist wahrscheinlich technisch ein bisschen anspruchsvoller.
Warum?
Weil so eine Lasereinheit wahrscheinlich doch relativ aufwendig ist und die
kriegst du wahrscheinlich auch einfach nicht von Drittherstellern mal so eben
in Stückzahlen eingekauft.
Während Tintenpatronen, ich meine, es gibt ja diese Tintenpatronen mit Druckkopf.
Auch von Billiganbietern, wenn du das Zeug von HP oder Epson nicht kaufen willst.
Wie, es gibt Tintenpatronen mit Druckkopf.
Ja, die HP Druckkopf.
Doch schon immer.
Dinger sind schon relativ lange, ist der Druckkopfteil der Tintenpatrone.
Ach so, ich habe noch nie drüber nachgedacht.
Und deswegen bauen die den halt mit solchen Patronen.
Als Nachbau überall gekriegt.
Also zwei Reihen werden hier unterstützt, HP 63 und HP 302 steht hier auf der Projektseite.
Aber auch nur die beiden halt, ansonsten müsste es halt wieder irgendwie alles um...
Ja, ich denke mal, ich denke mal, wenn dieses Beispiel Schule macht,
dann kriegt man vielleicht auch von den etablierten Herstellern wieder Drucker,
die irgendwie vor allen Dingen drucken,
zuverlässig und nicht irgendwie eigentlich nur ein Vehikel sind,
um überteuerte Tinte oder überteuerten Toner zu verkaufen.
Wie war das? Druckertinte ist teurer als Blut. Auf den Liter gerechnet?
Okay, also so ein Teil hier, was weiß ich, ich habe hier mal auf irgendeine Tonerbude geklickt.
15 Euro für so 550 Seiten angeblich schwarz.
Also Farbe, schwarz, 550 Seiten, wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Testseiten.
Ja. Your mileage may vary, heißt wahrscheinlich das Sternchen, ne?
Ja, okay. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe ja kein gutes Verhältnis zu Tintenschalldruckern.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei euch so ist.
Farblaser zu Hause.
Echt so Laser Guys hier, ne?
Ich habe auch einen Laser, vor allen Dingen einen, der erstens einen Ethernet-Port hat.
Und zweitens AirPrint kann. Das sind so die beiden Dinge. Einstecken und drucken.
Und drittens ein Brother-Drucker ist.
Nee, es ist tatsächlich ein HP.
Wirklich?
Aber er tut.
Okay.
Und zwar tut er, ohne dass man Software installiert. Also ich habe keine HP-Software
installiert, sondern dadurch, dass es ein AirPrint-Drucker ist.
Kann man einfach drucken. Ja, eben. Das ist einfach geil.
Und solange sie bei dem Ding nicht auch mit AirPrint um die Ecke kommen,
brauchen sie gar nicht anrufen.
Also ich habe so einen Brother-Drucker, der ist an sich ganz okay.
Man muss halt nur ab und zu mal im Internet nachgucken, wie nochmal diese komische
Konami-Code ist, um irgendwie zu sagen, nee, der Dona ist jetzt nicht leer.
Der Dona, der passt schon.
Aber das meinte ich mit N-Shirtification. Sie versuchen halt den letzten Cent
aus dir rauszuquetschen.
Ja, wobei bei Brother hält es sich halt sehr in Grenzen. Also Brother finde
ich generell als Company ist noch extrem gut zu vertreten.
Die Drucker sind sehr zuverlässig, softwaremäßig überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Ich hatte mit HP zwischenzeitlich sehr viel Ärger und habe dann das HP-Lager
komplett verlassen, aber ich war da auch nie so richtig drin.
Also Epson soll in Sachen Tintenstrahldrucker ja auch noch relativ okay sein,
habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Also HP hat ja die eingeführt mit den verschlüsselten Druckköpfen,
wo sich die Tintenpatrone, die du kaufst, dann verschlüsselt erstmal gegen den
Drucker authentifiziert,
um Nachbauten zu vermeiden.
Und der auch mitzählt, also du kannst auch nicht nachfüllen,
weil der hat gesagt, ich habe mein Kontingent verdruckt und Schüss.
Also solche Sachen, das ist schon fies.
Ja, das ist das Gillette-Modell. Funktioniert ja für viele auch ganz gut.
Also offensichtlich verdienen sie ja noch Geld mit diesem ganzen Business.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das daran liegt, dass wirklich so viele Leute überteuerte
HP-Originalpatronen kaufen.
Also ist das so? Wahrscheinlich, ne?
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn du so, sagen wir mal,
So unsere älter Generation, die halt einfach einen Drucker brauchen,
um mal Sachen auszudrucken und nicht so viel drucken und dann soll er nicht
so groß sein und so und dann stellen sich halt einen hin mit Markenname und
fertig, ohne darüber nachzudenken.
Der Drucker, ja klar. Und die Frage ist ja, wo kaufen sie ihre Supplies?
Kaufen sie jetzt, wenn der Drucker sagt, ich bin leer und klicken auf den Link,
den ihnen der Treiber vorwirft und dann kriegen sie da das her?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich der Markt ist.
Oder der Bote klingelt und hat die Patrone schon in der Hand.
Das HP hat doch auch sowas eingeführt.
Schönen Drucker haben sie da. Wäre doch schade, wenn der morgen nicht mehr drucken würde.
Ja, genau das.
Das Rockefeller-Prinzip.
Ich glaube, es ist ja auch Enterprise-Kram.
Wir bestellen das einfach so und fertig.
Aber genau gegen sowas ist ja dieses Open Printer gedacht und das finde ich
auch einfach sehr gut, dass da jemand mal sagt, jetzt reicht es mal,
wir bauen den jetzt selber.
Der Open Printer wird jetzt sicherlich nicht Enterprise.
Gucken wir mal. Lass den erstmal funktionieren. Ich finde die Idee super.
Das ist echt gut. Gibt es vielleicht auch ein paar andere Produktkategorien?
Wie gesagt, Laser fände ich geil.
Ja, also wenn das Ding funktioniert und dass die damit auch halbwegs Geld machen,
dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das Mark 3 oder Mark 4 dann auch ein ganz fähiger Drucker ist.
Also der erste ist sicherlich nur für Enthusiasten, die sowieso rumfrickeln, aber das ist auch okay.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, this product is launching soon.
Das ist ein Laserdrucker mit Endlospapier, wäre ja auch mal was.
Hatten früher die Laserdrucker ja auch.
Was? Welche?
Ja, es gab Laserdrucker, also mit diesem gefalzten Unendlich-Papier, doch, doch, die gab's.
Nie einen gesehen. Immer nur diese Matrix.
Laserdrucker, nee. Nur die Matrixdrucker haben das gefalzte Papier gehabt.
Nee, nee. Es gab Laserdrucker. Ja.
Nein, gab es nicht.
70er, irgendwann, wann das erfunden wurde.
Es gab in den 70er keine Laserdrucker.
Was? Ja.
Ja, ja. Wir haben relativ schnell Papier ausgeworfen. Die Druckqualität war
auch nicht so richtig hoch.
Laserdrucker?
Ja, ja.
In den 70ern?
Ja, ja. Früher 80er. Ja, wir müssen nochmal nachgucken.
Der erste Laserdrucker meines Wissens war der Hewlett Packard Laserdrucker und
mit einer HP Einheit hat auch Apple seinen Apple Laserbreiter rausgebracht und
das war von Anfang an immer Letter A4.
Ich habe nie einen anderen Laserdrucker gesehen. Endlos Papier ist einfach eine
Domäne von Kettendruckern und Matrixdruckern.
Du meinst wahrscheinlich die Kettendrucker.
Angeblich gab es aber die halt auch nicht in der Matrix-Drucker-Variante,
sondern tatsächlich mit Laser in diesen komischen, diesen geknickten und mit den Stanzlöchern.
Tim, googeln wir doch mal IBM 3800. Das ist aus dem Jahr 1975 und hat die bescheidene
Länge von drei Metern und ist ein endlos Laserdrucker aus dem Rechenzentrum.
Was, IBM, wie hieß der?
IBM 3800.
Okay.
Gut, ich sprach auch nicht von Desktop-Druckern.
I stand corrected. Okay.
Also hier sieht man es wirklich mit Menschen drin, hier in diesem Visual.
Das schmeiße ich auch mal an.
Also so Ameisen gegenüber der Druckmaschine hier.
Geil.
Naja, früher war alles groß an Rechnern.
Okay, gut, ich meine, es ist in gewisser Hinsicht, hätte ich mir auch selber
denken können, Dass natürlich,
bevor man auf diese Desktop-Größe gekommen ist,
die Technologie vorher schon mal in irgendeiner Form Large Scale hat und dass
das IBM gemacht hat, überrascht mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so richtig, auch wenn,
warte mal, was hat hier die Rolle von Xerox?
Nee.
Im Interpress.
Ohne Xerox.
So, Xerox hatte den Xerox 9700 ab 1977.
Siemens Nixdorf hatte den Siemens 9730. Das waren dann die 80er. Also, ne?
Also, es gab sie.
Okay.
So, jetzt muss man mal kurz gucken, wann mein erster Drucker,
mein erster Laserdrucker, überhaupt hergestellt wurde.
Also ich habe meine Karriere des Druckens mit einem 24-Nadel-Drucker von NEC begonnen.
Der war relativ zuverlässig, nicht übermäßig schnell, aber hat ganz ordentliche Qualität gedruckt.
Das stimmt. Noch ein Neun-Nadler, weil NEC waren ja die ersten mit 24 Nadelern.
Ja, genau.
Aber die sind auch erstmal mit neun Nadelern eingerückt.
Ja, aber mein erster Drucker war gleich ein 24 Nadeler und das hatte sich damals
auch irgendwie gelohnt.
Okay, also mein Drucker ist tatsächlich 1990 erschienen.
Der QMS PS410. Klassiker. Ja, Drucker. Also,
Drucker sind Jetzt nicht nochmal Drucker.
Leute haben, mal ehrlich, man hat zu seinem Drucker doch nochmal eine andere
emotionale Verbindung als zu manch anderen Peripherien.
Hass?
Es gibt weniger freuliche Dinge, die ich mit irgendwelchen Druckern in meinem Leben verbinden würde.
Wirklich?
Ja. Meistens ärgert man sich über irgendwas. Irgendwas ist nicht perfekt im
Ausdruck. Es dauert zu lange.
Der Treiber muss schon wieder aktualisiert werden. Es steht oben auf dem Schrank
und ich komme nicht an das Pendel dran.
Diese Klapp-Displays zeigen alle nur Blödsinn an.
Ja.
Grundsätzlich ist das sicherlich für viele Leute so.
Das Papier ist leer. ja, wie rum muss ich das Papier jetzt in die Kassette reinlegen,
damit es auch von der richtigen Seite aus bedruckt wird.
Jetzt habe ich irgendwie das Formular, muss ich es jetzt linksrum oder rechtsrum
noch drehen vorher, muss erstmal einen Testdruck machen.
Ich will den beidseitigen Zusammenklappflyer machen.
Sind die Ränder alle gleichmäßig, damit ich es hier vernünftig ausschneide?
Also Drucken ist einfach alles nur scheiße.
Aber findest du nicht, dass du auch ein bisschen undankbar bist?
Also ich finde ja einfach so Geräte, wo einfach so ein fertiges Printprodukt
rauskommt, das ist ja auch ein Wunder.
Also ich bin ja alt und ich kenne ja noch die Zeit, als man,
die einzige Möglichkeit der Vervielfältung war so Matrizenkopierer.
Ja klar, sicher.
Diese Rototdinger mit dem Spiritus.
Das roch immer so gut.
Und das war so das, was du auch so im Kopier Dienstleistungsbereich überhaupt
bekommen konntest und es sah einfach saumäßig scheiße aus und.
Ja, und dann kamen die Matrix-Drucker und machten Ja.
Aber die waren,
auf jeden Fall auch einen Schritt nach vorne. Ich habe einen der Klassiker gehabt,
also den Nachfolger des Klassikers, den Epson FX 80 ist der Klassiker, ich hatte den 85.
Das war so der erste solide neuen Nadeldrucker, der so richtig alles weggehauen
hat, so den irgendwie auch nix klein kriegen konnte.
Klar, man musste so mit dem Characterset und so weiter arbeiten,
so war das ja damals, weil es gab ja noch irgendwie keinen wirklichen Standard
und so, aber hat funktioniert.
Also ich habe irgendwie meine Abi-Zeitung habe ich irgendwie auf dem FX 85 irgendwie ausgedruckt.
Also ich habe mal in einem Büro gearbeitet, da hatten sie noch einen Typenraddrucker.
Oh!
Das ist ja quasi eine elektrische Schreibmaschine ohne Tastatur.
Die sind auch geil.
Und das Teil war so unglaublich laut. Also der war, wenn,
das Schallschutzgehäuse korrekt geschlossen war, war er unanständig laut und
wenn es nicht korrekt geschlossen war, war er unerträglich laut.
Also das Ding war wirklich, aber er hat halt ausgeworfen, was so aussah wie
auf der Schreibmaschine Hand getippt.
Das war...
Tja, Froschfrau schreibt gerade, Drucker sind noch schlimmer als Kaffee-Vollautomaten.
Mi, mi, mi Papier, mi, mi, mi dies und das. Ja, so nehme ich.
Ja, ja.
Aber es ist so ein bisschen mit Druckern, es ist wie mit Beziehungen.
Da kann man auch Glück haben.
Viel Zeit drin versenken.
Und trotzdem geht es schief.
Ich hatte wirklich mit den meisten meiner Drucker eine gute Zeit.
So wohl mit dem FX-85. Die Nex hatte ich glaube ich selber kein...
Und dann kam dieser PS410 und wer hat gesagt, der hat auch einen PS410 da oben?
Kurz noch mal erwähnen. Jan Timms schreibt, PS410 war auch mein erster Leser
an meiner privaten Sun-Snob.
Hatte als notwendiges Feature eine Serie des Schnittstelle. Man konnte auch
per Terminal mit seinem Postscript-Interpreter reden.
Wie habe ich den da auf den gedruckt? Damals eigentlich hatte der nicht Netzwerk
schon? Der hatte doch ein Netzwerk.
Hatte der Ethernet? Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht mehr. Naja,
auf jeden Fall beim Drucker.
Opa erzählt vom Druckerkrieg.
Genau, beim Druckerkrieg muss man einfach, also generell, man muss einfach darauf
achten, also wähle den Drucker gut aus.
Also beim Drucker wirklich zehn Freunde fragen, wie die Erfahrungen sind und
dann findet man auch die richtigen Partner fürs Leben.
Und Etiketten drucken. Meine Güte.
Ja.
Bis du dann die richtigen Label-Vorlagen hast und dann sind die aber wieder
nicht richtig und dann stimmen die Abstände deiner Ränder in deinem Druckertrag. Nein.
Und dann hast du eins ausgewählt, was doch schon weggedruckt war und dann druckt
er nur auf die Plastikunterlage.
Und ja, ja, Label-Drucken ist auch ein schönes Thema.
Also schön, dass das alles theoretisch geht, aber es ist in der Praxis,
es ist so ein Schmerz immer.
Wenn ich Pakete verschicke, mache ich das alles hier mit meinem Laserdrucker.
Ja, inzwischen geht das ja auch halbwegs. Also ich meine, du klickst dir bei
der Post eine Paketmarke, druckst sie aus, schneidest sie durch und klebst sie
in einen Teil aufs Paket.
Also das ist ja irgendwie jetzt keine große Kunst mehr.
Na gut.
Wie viel seid ihr denn noch? Ich habe noch zwei Themen, die am Anfang übergangen wurden.
Na dann leg mal los.
Also erstes...
Wurde ja gebeten, dass ich noch mal zur Messerfolge noch mal ein Feedback gebe des Feedbacks.
Und das Blog ist ja explodiert nach der Folge mit Huckel über Messerschärfen.
Das stimmt, warum nur?
Das überrascht mich null. Es gibt so ein paar Themen, wo ich glaube,
dass da Nerds und Nerdinnen halt nicht stillhalten können. Messer gehören definitiv dazu.
Ich hätte noch so ein paar Themen, wollte mit uns über Pfannen reden.
Also Bratpfannen wäre auch so ein Kandidat.
Aber das meiste, was da kommentiert wurde, war schön.
Ich habe mich da eigentlich gefreut, da kam viel Gutes. Viele von der Fraktion
so, nur diese Schärfgeschichte ist das einzig glücklich machende und eine Fraktion,
die auch durchaus laut war, war,
Da reicht doch ein normaler Wetzstahl. Und bei meinem Bekannten in der Profiküche
haben die nichts anderes.
Und das kann doch dann nicht schlecht sein.
Und da hat wiederum ein anderer Kommentator, ich weiß nicht mehr wer es jetzt
genau war, im Blog einen YouTube-Kanal rübergeworfen.
Und den möchte ich euch allen nicht nur nicht vorenthalten, sondern allerwärmstens ans Herz legen.
Und zwar ist das Kanal Outdoors 55.
Genau, etwas skurriler Name Outdoors 55.
Hat 366 Videos hochgeladen und ist wirklich messervoll Nerd.
Was den aber abhebt von so ziemlich fast allen anderen, die ich bisher geguckt
habe, ist, dass er auch einfach bei aller so Verschrobenheit,
die er dann auch durchaus so als Typ mit reinbringt, einen quasi wissenschaftlichen Ansatz hat.
Das heißt, er hat also zum Beispiel ein sehr, sehr gutes Mikroskop,
wo er sich die Schneiden wirklich im allerfeinsten Detail angucken kann, um zu gucken,
was ist denn da jetzt mit dem Grad passiert und wie viel wird da abgetragen
und was sind die Vor- oder Nachteile von welchem System auch immer.
Und da kann man wirklich mal ein paar Stunden rein versenken.
Da habe ich wirklich sehr, sehr viel gelernt in einer kurzen Zeit,
wäre jetzt falsch, ich habe da schon etliche Stunden reingegeben,
aber danach sieht man manches klarer.
Unter anderem hat er eine ganze Folge, die habe ich jetzt so schnell nicht gefunden,
kann ich auch nochmal raussuchen für die Shownotes, wo er wirklich mal...
Durchspielt, was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn man halt ein gutes Messer über
so einen Wetzstahl rüberzieht, also einen runden, normalen, wie man das so kennt.
So einen habe ich auch in der Küche.
Und natürlich wird dadurch das Messer scharf und kann dann schneiden.
Ja, kurz halt.
Kurz halt, so. Aber das heißt, sobald du zweimal irgendwo auf dem Schneidbrett
aufgekommen bist, ist dann halt, er guckt dann halt mit dem Mikroskop sich an, was passiert denn da?
Der Grat wird halt aufgerichtet durch diesen Wetzstahl, dieser sehr,
sehr grüne, sehr, sehr dünne, sehr feine Grat, gleichzeitig aufgeschartet,
sodass du quasi so eine Minisäge produzierst damit.
So und die schneidet natürlich super, ein, zwei Mal, bis, da es so dünn ist,
diese ganzen quasi Sägezähne, wenn du so willst, alle abgeknickt und alle weg
sind und ab dann ist sie sofort wieder stumpf und du musst wieder nachschärfen.
Das ist nämlich auch der Grund, warum dann in diesen Profiküchen,
die eben so einmal pro Stunde über diesen Wetzstahl rüber gehen,
weil es dann halt einfach mal die Schärfe sofort wieder weg ist.
Und demgegenüber hält er dann halt so nach einer Methode von Huckel und mir
geschärftes exakt selbes Messer, wo er dann also irgendwie vier Stunden durch
irgendwas durchschneidet und es ist danach immer noch genauso scharf wie vorher,
weil du halt nicht nur diese,
hochgekannte Mikrosägezahn-Kante hast.
Also toller Kanal, genau Tim hat ja jetzt mal ein Video, wo man sieht,
wie sieht so ein Schärfungsprozess aus und was passiert da und Was passiert da nicht?
Das guckt euch mal an und dann können wir wieder in der nächsten Runde weiter diskutieren.
Der guckt auch, wie ist der Härtegrad von den Messern?
Wie ist der Schärfewinkel? Hat also alles an Equipment durchgetestet.
Ganz toller Messer-Nerd-Kanal.
Das ist wirklich irre.
So, dann habe ich noch etwas zu.
Du willst es doch auch.
Noch ausschließlich erfreuliche Botschaften ganz zum Schluss, so muss es sein.
Und zwar hatten wir ja, erinnert ihr euch vielleicht an die Chain of Pain Folge,
wo es darum ging, wie kriege ich für meine Kiddies eine Playlist aus iTunes
oder sonst wo in mein Auto rein, obwohl es 19 Jahre alt ist und keine MP3s abspielt
und kein Bluetooth hat und ähnliches.
Das erste ist, wir haben ja nach einem Begriff gesucht und die Chain of Pain
hat dann gewonnen und es wurde aber von etlichen mir dann nochmal rübergeworfen,
so dafür gibt es schon den Profi-Begriff,
warum noch was anderes erfüllen und die Leute haben recht, es ist Yuckshaving.
Yuckshaving ist der offizielle wissenschaftliche Begriff für genau,
ich mache lauter unsinnige Dinge in Kette hintereinander, es muss aber sein
für das eigentliche Metaziel.
Und warte mal, jetzt habe ich hier den falschen Link in den Chat nochmal geworfen,
wo ist das hier, den Victionary Eintrag wollen wir haben.
So, da ist er. Ist das auch schon ein paar Jährchen her, ist irgendwie aus den
90ern oder sowas der Begriff und beschreibt exakt das, was ich da gesucht habe.
Hat ein bisschen den Nachteil, dass er nicht selbsterklärend ist.
So, also sprich, man muss halt irgendwie das Mem kennen und den ganzen Kontext
kennen und dann ist es in der Tat präzise, aber von daher ist so eine Chain
of Pain dann vielleicht erstmal handfester.
So, in der Sache ist es aber so.
Gegen anderslautenden Behauptungen lese ich ja doch sehr gründlich,
was ihr so in den Kommentaren schreibt.
Und auch was da so an Hinweisen und Tipps und Tricks reingeht.
Und was ich ja ignoriert hatte, war diese ganzen, ja, da musst du nur dein Teil
umbauen und die ganze Verkleidung auflösen. Und es geht auch alles ganz schnell.
Fraktionen, aber es hatten auch ein paar Leute nochmal geschrieben,
guckt ihr vielleicht doch nochmal diese FM-Transmitter an.
Da hat sich in den letzten Jahren nochmal ein bisschen was getan.
So, wer erinnert uns, zum letzten Mal hatte ich die irgendwie vor zehn Jahren
ausprobiert. So ein, zwei Modelle hatte ich damals und das war irgendwie soundtechnisch gar nichts.
So, und dann gab es also da draußen eine gute Seele namens, den erwähnen wir
jetzt auch mal, das hat er sicher verdient.
Der Eugen P. Rogoff, Grüße, der hat gesagt so, ich habe ja einen über.
Den schicke ich dir einfach mal.
Probier doch mal aus, was du davon hältst.
Der hatte den, weiß der gar ja woher. Gut, sind also angekommen,
ich reingesteckt, ausprobiert und dann hat dieser Test eigentlich zwei Dinge
ergeben, nämlich das erste war,
dass ein Teil...
Der Probleme, die ich damals hatte, in der Tat gelöst wurden dadurch,
dass die neuen aktuellen FM-Transmitter nur noch auf diesen Grenzwellen,
ist wahrscheinlich jetzt der falsche Begriff,
im FM-Spektrum ganz vorne und ganz hinten sind.
Also 785 und 108,0 auf der anderen Seite.
Da wo in Europa weitestgehend kein einziger Radiosender irgendwo ist.
Aber die Radios kriegen das noch rein.
Da fangen sie halt an, aber da ist kein Sender, weil dann werden sie zu sehr auf der Kante.
Genau. Und das kann in der Tat das Autoradio von meinem 19 Jahre Mercedes-B-Klasse,
kommt in diese Randbereiche rein.
Du könntest auch irgendwas dazwischen einstellen, aber es macht einfach total
Sinn, die zu nehmen, weil du da keine Interferenzen von anderen Signalen drin hast.
Höchstens andere alte Benze, die sowas ähnliches machen.
Naja, die Reichweite ist ja so zwei bis maximal vier Meter, die dafür spezifiziert
ist. Also dann ist es glaube ich eher unwahrscheinlich, dass du da neben dir
dann jemand hast, der dann da auch rumfällt.
Kann passieren, aber ist mir jetzt noch nicht passiert.
So, also das Problem war, fand ich
dann ganz gut gelöst. Auch irgendwie Konnektivität war super. Das Ding...
Machte eigentlich einen wirklich viel besseren Eindruck als die anderen Sachen,
aber es klang halt immer noch scheiße.
Also der Sound war halt immer noch irgendwie muffig, klang alles irgendwie sehr
komprimiert und irgendwie nicht ansatzweise irgendwie eine Soundstage oder sowas.
Und ich wäre da jetzt, um dieses Problem zu lösen, jetzt nicht übermäßig kritisch
gewesen, aber das war halt noch unter dem, was ich da bereit war zu ertragen.
Also doch mittelmäßig kritisch schon noch.
Mittelmäßig kritisch schon noch. Ein bisschen irgendwie nach Musik sollte es
sich schon noch irgendwie anhören.
So und dann habe ich auch was gemacht, nämlich nochmal geguckt auf im Internet und beim Amazon.
Was ist denn da so das Rechts-Unten- Modell? Das heißt also,
wenn ich jetzt mal beliebig viel Geld auf dieses Thema HFM-Transmitter draufwerfen
würde, was bietet der Markt mir denn da an?
Und ratet mal, was so ein Rechts-Unten-Modell kostet in so einer Produktkategorie.
FM-Transmitter fürs Auto?
100, 120.
Okay. 25 Euro. Man kann nicht mehr als 25 Euro für einen FM-Transmitter ausgeben.
Das finde ich beruhigend.
Ich hatte Angst.
Ich muss mal eben gucken, ob ich den...
Aber was lässt sich glauben, dass das das Rechts-Unten-Modell Nur weil es nichts Teureres gab?
Genau. Also das ist einfach das Teuerste, was bei Amazon in der Rubrik hat.
Okay, aber rechts unten heißt ja nicht nur das Teuerste, das heißt ja auch das Beste.
Ja, aber es ist auch das Bunteste. Guck mal.
Ach so.
Das hat hier einen Charging-Standard 3.0 dran.
Ich habe hier meine Brille gerade nicht dabei. Ich muss mal eben gucken, wie heißt das hier.
Was sehen wir denn jetzt?
Was sehen wir jetzt hier? Ich muss erst mal den Namen eintippen,
damit ihr das auch alles in Farbe von mir beschrieben bekommt. Und KM30.
Was ist das jetzt hier?
Kuh...
Ich habe da den merkwürdigen Gedanken, gibt es denn auch DAB-Sender?
Niemand. Also DAB ist einfach noch unverbreiteter als Fettiverse.
Töteter als Töteter. Ich hatte mal ein Auto, das hat er im DAB-Radio.
Ja, empfangen können die das alle, aber da sendet vielleicht auch irgendjemand.
Naja, aber du willst ja den Sender, so ähnlich wie den.
DAB ist so eine typische Technologie, die an sich ganz gut gemeint ist und würde
es UKW nicht geben, aber es ist halt so, du kannst UKW eh nicht abschalten.
UKW ist unabschaltbar und ist good enough und deswegen wird sich da nichts zu,
das andere ist halt Internet. So, was haben wir jetzt hier?
Das ist dein 25 Euro Music-Tuner.
Genau, Music-Tuner. Von der Firma, wie heißt das, Viech?
Also erstmal lernt man, wenn man so die Listen durchgeht, es gibt offensichtlich
drei Modelle, die von 30 Firmen angeboten werden, aber im Wesentlichen alle
exakt gleich aufgebaut sind und nur sich in minimalsten Details überhaupt unterscheiden.
Das ist eine leichte Winamp-Anmutung. Ein Nulac-C Bluetooth-Adapter.
Der zeichnet sich von der Optik her noch dadurch aus, dass es einen völlig überflüssigen,
Equalizer-Visualisierung hat, wo man also angeblich dann noch irgendwie sieht.
Und ist es so farbig wie auf dem Bild?
Es ist so farbig wie auf dem Bild da. Ja, das schon. Und man kriegt aber immerhin
dann auch wirklich, wenn man über Bluetooth verbunden ist, hier die Information
mit welches Lied spielt er gerade und so weiter.
Das ist dann wiederum ganz nützlich.
Auf dem Screenshot sah das irgendwie groß und eindrucksvoll aus.
Wenn man es nicht so in der Hand hat, ist es eher so tiny.
Was aber ein Vorteil ist, weil
dadurch passt es dann halt auch im Auto irgendwie so dahin, wo es soll.
Es ist kleiner, als ich erwartet habe.
So und was mich jetzt aber getriggert hat, als ich das durchgelesen hatte,
war ich nur mäßig motiviert, den jetzt irgendwie zu kaufen und auszuprobieren,
war so eine Fußnote kann sogar Stereo.
Hä?
So, was?
Wie kann sowas Stereo?
Wie kann sowas, was können denn die anderen?
Bei FM ist ja Stereo Standard, oder nicht?
Ja, das denkt man dann so, ne?
Ist nicht so.
So, und dann habe ich den halt, den mir hier der Hörer zugeschickt hatte,
da hat die so, wie, kann kein Stereo?
Reingesteckt, das ist Mono. Die sind alle Mono.
Diese ganzen doofen, normalen FM-Transmitter schicken alle ein komprimiertes
Mono-Signal dahin, weil besserer Empfang oder sowas.
Komprimiert?
Und dieser Null-Exi-Bluetooth-Adapter, es scheint einer der wirklich ganz wenigen
zu sein, die wirklich ein sauberes Stereo überhaupt rausschicken.
Kostet aber auch 25 Euro.
Kostet auch 25 Euro.
Waren die anderen denn auch Bluetooth?
Die waren auch alle Bluetooth. Also es ist kein Problem des Bluetooth-Standards,
sondern das, was das Teil selber dann an die Antenne schickt.
Sind Sie sicher, dass Sie nicht einfach auch das falsche Bluetooth-Profil ausgewählt haben?
Theoretisch denkbar, aber mein Autoradio hat halt so eine Anzeige,
ob es Mono empfängt oder Stereo empfängt.
Und die hat bei den anderen wirklich nur Mono angezeigt an der Stelle.
Das wäre dann glaube ich unwahrscheinlich.
Und da dachte ich, na gut, das willst du jetzt aber wissen.
Deiner hat wirklich nur Mono. Gucken wir doch mal, ob es einen Unterschied macht.
Gut, ich das also dann reingesteckt und verbunden. Das geht alles mittlerweile
war ja wirklich total super smooth mit Bluetooth, muss man sagen so. Und was soll ich sagen?
Es hat einen völlig okayen, guten, klaren.
Höhen- und Bassmusikplayer.
Wer hätte es gedacht?
Wer hätte es gedacht? Man hat...
Ich hätte ja gar nicht schämen müssen.
Man hat wirklich... All die Stunden. Man hat einen separaten Bassregler,
einen separaten Höhenregler, die so...
Wozu ist das Mikrofon?
So, okay, für Freisprechanlagen. Damit kannst du halt auch dann telefonieren
über dein iPhone so und hast dann den Ton des anderen irgendwie...
Das ist ehrlich gesagt so scheinbar deren Haupt-Use-Case. Dass da mit jemand
Musik hört, ist, glaube ich, eher so Zufall.
Es hat noch zwei USB-A-Anschlüsse an der Seite, wohin man also dann auch sein
Handy irgendwie noch aufladen kann.
Alles fein. Und einen MP3-Stick, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Der eine ist ja
mit so einer Note gekennzeichnet.
Genau, du kannst einen MP3-USB-Stick dran pappen. Auf der anderen Seite hat
es auch noch eine SD-Karte, glaube ich, oder kompakt Mini- irgendwas.
Mini-SD.
Micro-SD.
Oder auch noch irgendwie ein MP3-Chip rein, wenn du immer so dieselben 400 Songs hören willst. so.
Also für die 25 Euro bringt das eine Menge mit.
Ja und sogar noch ein AUX-Out.
Genau, wo du auch noch in der Mini-Klinke rein kannst.
Aber kann man den auch noch mal über
was anderes als nur über diesen Zigarettenanzünder mit Strom versorgen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Weil ich meine, gut, das kannst du wahrscheinlich auseinanderbauen.
Kannst ja irgendwie direkt einbauen, das Teil irgendwo 12 Volt.
Dann kannst du auch wieder rauchen.
Also es gibt hier unten noch einen Anschluss. Das könnte es sein.
Nein, das ist ein Mini-Klinke inne.
Das ist falsch beschriftet. Ja, das ist falsch beschriftet hier.
Das ist ein Eingang, den kannst du schalten auch, wenn du es nicht über Bluetooth verbinden willst.
Es ist ein bisschen schade, wenn man den über USB-A sowieso schon anschließt,
dass du darüber auch nicht das Audio rüber schicken kannst. Das hätte ich nochmal praktisch gefunden.
Aber Bluetooth hat ja auch so seine Vorzüge.
Noch ein bisschen flexibler hier und da. Auf jeden Fall it just works.
Du musst dich auch überhaupt nicht jedes Mal pairn, sondern sobald ich mich
jetzt ins Auto setze, verbindet sich automagisch mein iPhone damit.
Ich schalte den eingespeicherten 108er-Kanal ein, die Musik ertönt,
ich kann über Siri alles steuern. Das ist fantastisch.
Merkt Apple Maps auch, dass du jetzt in deinem Auto bist oder überhaupt das
iPhone und sagst, okay, der Automodus geht an und ersetzt den Pin in der Karte, wenn du aussteigst?
Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Keine Ahnung.
Und vom Sound her, ich habe es dann natürlich verglichen mit CD und du hörst
einen Unterschied, aber ich würde sagen, das ist so eben der Unterschied zwischen
guter Radioempfang und CD.
Und du musst schon ordentlich hinhören, um zu hören, ja die Höhen sind ein bisschen
schärfer und der Bass ist nicht ganz so präzise und jadda jadda,
aber sobald du auf der Straße bist, hörst du schon kaum noch einen Unterschied
und wenn du auf der Autobahn bist, halte ich es für ausgeschlossen,
dass noch irgendjemand einen Unterschied hört zu CD.
Von daher Weißt du, hörst den Unterschied nicht?
Mission accomplished, Problem gelöst, Jack kann nach Hause geschickt werden,
was ich in dem Fall aber auch wieder skandalisierungswürdig Ich finde,
ich habe halt auch so Vergleichsportale dann nochmal studiert.
So, was testen denn die Leute so und renommierte, nicht renommierte Testzeitschriften.
Glaubt man nicht, dass irgendjemand von denen den Sound anspricht.
Ja, denen geht es immer nur um irgendwie Sprachverständlichkeit und wie gut
arbeitet das jetzt irgendwie mit dem Telefonmodus und sowas.
Dass man sowas irgendwie nehmen könnte, um irgendwie einfach mal Musik zu hören,
dann scheint also ein völlig abwegiger Use Case zu sein.
Ich habe keinen Test gefunden, der irgendwie die Soundqualität von Musik bewertet
hat, geschweige denn erwähnt hat, dass es einen Unterschied geben könnte zwischen Stereo und Mono.
Kann denn dieses Gerät auch eine UKW Station ID mitsenden?
Damit meinst du was? Oder willst du was bezwecken?
Über UKW gibt es ja auch noch einen Datenkanal.
Ah, verstehe.
Wo drin steht, du hörst jetzt Antenne Tralala.
Ah, lustig, weil er die Informationen ja eh schon hat und selber anzeigt. Ich glaube nicht.
Also das ist ja nur eine Information, die da noch mit rein moduliert werden muss.
Ja, kann mein Radio aber nicht anzeigen. Von daher kann ich dir diese Frage
schlicht nicht beantworten.
Ach so, dein Radio kann das nicht anzeigen? Ach so, ja stimmt.
Weil das ja Asbach-Uralt ist.
Das ist graue Uhrzeit.
Das müsste ich mit meinem Radio mal versuchen, weil der ja auch Songs und so
anzeigt. Aber es kann sein, dass das ein DAB-Modus war.
Das wäre natürlich dann auch nochmal lustig. Aber man muss das immer auf 100%
Lautstärke setzen und auch das iPhone auf 100% Lautstärke, weil aus irgendeinem
Grund durch diese FM-Transmitter-Geschichte nur ein sehr leises Signal rüberkommt.
Aber es ist ohne Rauschen und es ist ohne Verzerrung. Das heißt,
das kann man auch einfach beides machen, beides auf Maximum drehen und dann
hat man eine sehr normale Lautstärke auch.
Übers normaler Autoradio machst du dann halt die eigentliche Lautstärkeanpassung.
Weil, ich habe gerade mal, das ist ja so lange her, dass ich mich damit beschäftigt
habe, RDS heißt der Standard.
Ganz praktisch, Radiodatensystem heißt das glaube ich einfach.
Und das kennt vier Unterkategorien, also PI ist die Program Identification,
also das ist sozusagen die Senderkennung, da könnte das Ding halt einfach Ralf anzeigen.
Ja, Radio Ralf.
Dann gibt es RT, Radiotext, Laufschrift mit zusätzlichen Infos wie Songtiteln.
Kann man also tatsächlich übertragen, warum machen das die Radiosender nicht?
AF, Alternative Frequencies, Liste alternativer Frequenzen des selben Programms.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht ganz so relevant.
Und Verkehrsfunk kannst du noch einblenden. Das wäre sozusagen auch geil,
wenn das Ding sozusagen noch so ein,
Keine Ahnung, was könnte man damit... Achso, selbst wenn es stumm geschaltet
ist, kannst du sozusagen alles wieder ganz laut machen.
Schrieb. Stau auf der Autobahn, bla bla bla. Schrieb.
Aber RDS ist doch bestimmt wieder nur so eine deutsche Geschichte, ne?
Es gibt auf Quora eine Frage dazu, ob es irgendeinen gibt, der RDS auch schickt.
Gibt es da eine Antwort zu?
Das ist angeblich in ganz Europa und in vielen weiteren Teilen der Welt.
Guck an. Nordamerika hat sowas ähnliches. Natürlich nicht das Gleiche.
Weitgehend kompatibel.
Tja, also das müssen wir einfach mal ausprobieren.
Okay.
EN62106 lautet der Standard. Tja, der wird gelernt in der Freakshow.
Okay, also es gibt dieses Gerät auch unter 30 verschiedenen Firmennamen.
Natürlich, du hast ja nicht gedacht, dass Nolexi irgendwie groß ist.
Es ist doch wieder so ein random Amazon-China-Name.
Ja, ja.
Ja, ja. Zu viele schlechte Bewertungen. Einkassiert, erstmal einen neuen Namen raushauen.
Genau.
Ja. Gut, also das, der Forschungsstand.
Dann ist das ja nochmal gut ausgegangen. Das ist nochmal gut ausgegangen.
Ich weiß nicht, wer jetzt Jax schäfen soll.
Obwohl das schon auch so ein bisschen nach, sagen wir mal, Jungjax schäfen klang.
Aber ich bin froh, dass ich jetzt den Begriff ein bisschen verinnerlicht habe,
weil ich habe den schon oft gehört, aber ehrlich gesagt nie so richtig durchdrungen.
Und nach der Definition, die ich jetzt so gelesen habe...
Ich meine, du hattest ja sozusagen dieses, eine Kaskade von Entscheidungen,
die am Schluss immer alles schlimmer machen, war da eine Formulierung?
Nee, also die einfach, die man im normalen Leben nie machen würde,
die einfach schlecht sind, aber alternativlos, weil sonst erreicht man das Ziel nicht.
Wirklich gut, weil das ist ja hier auch so ein bisschen die Definition.
Also man will irgendwas erreichen, aber auf dem Weg dahin wird es immer döver.
Und man denkt sich so, warum die Umwege, diese ganzen Dependencies.
Oh Gott, und diese Fehlermeldung. Und jetzt muss ich hier noch einen neuen Toner kaufen. Oh Gott. Ja, ja.
Gut. Ich denke, damit haben wir es für heute beisammen.
Ich denke auch.
Liebe Leute,
was kriegen wir noch für Hinweise?
Bei Radio Bremen bekommst du per Radio-Sendern
in dem Songtitel auch Fußballergebnisse per Text eingeblendet.
Da brauche ich keine RDS dazu, da brauche ich nur den Chat hier mitlaufen zu lassen.
Den natürlich im Auto auch immer, egal.
Eine Kleinigkeit vielleicht noch, vielleicht sollten wir den Hörern noch verraten, warum jetzt Montag.
Achso, kannst du gerne verraten, ja?
Na komm, verrat.
Ralf, konntest du nicht mehr am Donnerstag, weil du dir irgendwas anderes vorgenommen hast.
Ja, meine Woche ist einfach so vollgestopft abends mit diversen,
regelmäßig, nicht jede Woche, aber doch häufig.
Geste Woche muss er das Jack schäfen.
Häufig anderen Terminen und Aktivitäten.
Donnerstag ist Jack-Tag.
Und quasi so der höchste Übereinkommens-Tag bei uns dreien war dann der Montag.
Also kann durchaus sein, dass die Friekshow jetzt häufiger am Montag kommt und
nicht am Donnerstag, was bisher so ein bisschen der Kompromiss war,
aber das kann sich auch wieder ändern.
Das ist doch ein super Start in die Woche. Was will man mehr?
Das stimmt allerdings. So, jetzt haben wir auch gestartet. Dann können wir ja
sagen, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, oder?
Ja, würde ich sagen. Vielen Dank.
Das tolle Outro anmachen natürlich. Selbstverständlich, das geht hier dazu. Zum guten Ton und so.
Ja, dann hören wir uns sicherlich bald wieder in einer neuen Ausgabe der Future.
Demnächstens.
Leute, macht's gut, bis bald.
Tschüss.